Yeah.
Okay.
do do
you
Okay, the board will convene and with the salute to the flag is the first order of business.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America, and to the republic for which it stands, one nation, under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Okay, we have first order of business will be to swear in our new member.
And then the board will adjourn for executive session.
So you're all just getting seated and you'll have to leave for the executive session.
I'm sorry about that.
But that's the way we need to proceed.
So the first order of business, I will have our new member come forward, Olivia Sisson, who is our student member.
More about her background later.
OK, if you'll raise your right hand and put your left hand on the, hold that.
Yes, thank you.
OK.
I, Olivia Sisson, do solemnly swear.
That I will support and defend the Constitution of the United States.
Against all enemies, foreign and domestic.
that I will bear true faith and allegiance to the Constitution of the United States, and the Constitution of the State of California, that I take this obligation freely, without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion,
and that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties upon which I am about to enter.
Thank you.
You're now a member of the State Board of Education.
Okay, with that done, we will need to clear the room and we will then proceed with our executive session and during that executive session
We will consider the cases of D.J.
v. the State and related complaint from the U.S.
Department of Justice and Vergara v. the State of California.
Yeah.
you
you you
Yeah.
you
do do
Yeah.
you
So,
Yeah.
do do
do
Yeah.
Okay, the board will reconvene and I need to announce that the report out on the closed session, the board discussed and or took action on the following cases.
D.J.
versus State and related complaint from the U.S.
Department of Justice and Vigara versus the State of California.
Now we're ready for the report of the superintendent.
Thank You mr. President board members good morning and back to school summer is winding up a lot of excitement as students and teachers Get back to the classrooms The biggest news of the last month that to share with you right at the start here is the progress we've made as indicated on our assessment and I hand it out to you all a chart showing that in
the Smarter Balance assessments, we have seen significant gains in all categories across the state, all student groups.
And the chart I have shared with you, I think, summarizes that.
I won't go into detail, but just to point out that there was a 5% increase
across all students for English language arts and four percent increase across all student groups for our mathematics.
You can see the breakdown of different student groups from Hispanic and Latino, African-American, Asian, ethnicities, disadvantaged students, English learners.
And so you see a pretty good summary here and challenges.
While there's momentum
There's still a long way to go to address the achievement gap.
We're thankful for the thousands of teachers, administrators, parents, students who cooperated so well in having the assessment for 3.2 million students successfully implemented.
We also want to thank Michelle's Center and Kerrick Ashley, everyone else on the CDE team who helped make that possible, and the board staff team who helped make that possible.
I want to thank Eagle Rock Elementary School in Los Angeles who hosted us, where we were joined by Superintendent Michelle King and L.A.
Board President Steve Zimmer.
And then we went from there to San Leandro High School back up in Northern California here.
and just put a spotlight on great things going on there.
While the state average was 5% in English language arts, in San Leandro High School, they had a 10% increase for African Americans and an 8% increase for Latinos, just to give you an example on English language arts.
So we're grateful for these good examples that are making their way forward.
The other extraordinary thing compared to the national scene was that we only had an opt-out of 1% of parents saying they didn't want their students to take the test.
New York, the exemption rate reached 20%, and in Washington State, for 11th graders, it was more like 50% opt-out.
So, collective good work of the state board, President Kurz, the governor, all of us on my team, and the education stakeholders around the state that we set a positive climate for proceeding and basically reached a pretty strong consensus that this is the right way to go and had parent cooperation in that.
The next thing I wanted to report on was the English Learner Roadmap Workgroup and invite anybody interested in joining that group to help us develop a resource guide for English learners.
We are pleased we received the CE Foundation from the Sobrato family a grant to
produce this roadmap.
This guide will assist local education agencies as they implement California's 21st century college and career standard goals, curriculum and instruction programs.
Applications and resumes are due by the 29th of September if you're interested in joining.
We've seen longer, earlier, more intense fire challenges around the state.
Wanted to let you know that through emergency powers that I have as superintendent, we're making districts whole.
If they had to shut down classes, if they had to shut down schools and lost attendance.
So that is something we've been working actively with school districts in the areas stricken by the fires.
During the three days I served as acting governor, some of you might know that I had that opportunity.
I signed emergency declarations to enable California to receive millions of dollars in FEMA and federal money to, again, help our communities recover from these fires.
And went to the fire scenes themselves to thank the firefighters who are doing a noble job.
The other very important thing that I did as acting governor was I declared one of the days of the three days to be, change lives, become a teacher.
And just put a spotlight on the teacher shortage and on the value of being an educator, being a teacher, the great personal rewards and professional satisfaction.
So with that, I also would say the good news is still there in terms of polling that I've seen where the public believes we need to invest in schools and that the progress we're making is something that the public is pleased with.
across from lower class sizes and bringing back art, music, drama, civics, and other technology improvements in the schools.
So I'll just mention again that I'm strongly in favor of Prop 55 getting passed and renewed, and Prop 51, which is the school facilities, a $9 billion measure.
So the first Prop 55 brings in about $8 billion a year, seven to eight billion, and Prop 51 will bring in one time $9 billion.
So with that, I have one last pleasure to share with you the appointment and introduction of two new CDE division directors.
So I'd like to introduce them to you.
You'll be seeing them more frequently here at the board.
One is Donna Wyatt.
She's the new director of Career and College Transition Division.
She has extensive experience in career technical education at the classroom, county, and district levels.
And she most recently comes from working as the head of the CTE Curriculum Instruction Office in the Oakland Unified District.
So with that, Donna, there she is.
So welcome, officially.
her first meeting.
And the other person's a little more familiar, a little more close to home here for us, Kristen Wright, who has been doing a wonderful job for the State Board.
She is the new Special Education Division Director, and this is a very important position that we were so pleased that she was able to come forward and
Take this, she has more than a decade of experience working in special education, obviously did a great job being liaison between the State Board and CDE, and her background in special education brings a wealth of personal and classroom experience to a new role.
So Kristen doesn't need introduction, but please stand up in her new position.
And with that, Mr. President, we're ready to move forward.
Okay.
Thank you very much on that.
And we appreciate meeting the two new staff members and look forward to working closely with them.
And I wanted to have several announcements to make.
I'm going to give a little bit more background on our new student member, Olivia Sisson.
She is a student at the C.K.
McClatchy High School right here in Sacramento.
And she's been active in the student council since 2015 and is currently the student body secretary.
Olivia's held several positions at the Sacramento City Youth Commission since 2014, including events coordinator and treasurer.
She tutors in the Sacramento Reading Partners and is an active member of Venture Crew 136.
Finally, I'd like to mention she has been a ballet dancer since 2001, performing with the Sacramento Ballet and as a soloist with the Crocker Dean Ballet Company.
When she finds any time to relax, I don't know.
So welcome and we look forward to working with you.
Okay, will their parents stand up please?
This is quite a meeting to get your inaugural with.
And so I also have an announcement about a new staff person in the State Board of Education office and would like to welcome Leilani
Aguinaldo, who is joined the SBP office team as Director of Policy and Legislation.
Lalani comes to us from the governmental relations work and through for Los Angeles Unified School District, where she was a director.
And prior to that, she worked for Assemblymember
Furutani as legislative director and previously was a legislative advocate for both the Asian Americans for Civil Rights and Equality, as well as the law offices of Ignacio Hernandez.
She graduated from UC Berkeley with a BA in economics.
I'd also like to announce that... Should we have her stand?
Yes, let's have her stand.
Please stand up.
I'd also like to announce that Malia Gonsalves has joined the State Board of Education Office as an Executive Assistant.
Board members, she will be handling office scheduling, helping with agenda items, and posting.
So let's have Malia stand.
She's here.
Way in the back.
Finally, I'd like to acknowledge Kristen Wright's departure from the State Board of Education Office, where she has been our staff person on special education, computer science, and other areas of interest within and concern for the board.
And of course, as Tom announced, she's the new Director of Special Education Division at the CDE, so we'll be working closely and continue with our
interaction with her over many important issues in the special education field.
So I would like you to join me in wishing her and her new appointment.
I'd like to announce that we are recruiting for four of our advisory councils.
We had an announcement on September 6th.
We're looking for people on a county superintendent to the advisory commission on charter schools, a curriculum coordinator and classroom teacher to the Child Nutrition Advisory Council,
a superintendent to serve on, or other administrator to serve on the California Practitioners Advisory Group, and we're also recruiting for 2017-18 student board members.
Finally, next, a change in the agenda item.
There was a revision to waiver item seven, which was posted on Tuesday, September 6th.
Spanish interpreter services will be available for all for our items this morning.
We have two public hearings, item 12 and item 13.
We also have two addendum.
Item 4 has an addendum as does item 11 have an addendum.
The consent calendar and waiver requests are as following.
We proposed waiver consent calendar items
be on consent W01, W02, and W06 through W17.
And then the proposed regular consent calendar includes items on our board agenda 6 through 11 in that order.
So now I have the reminders for the board and the audience.
If you want to remove items from proposed consent calendars, board members, please advise our executive director by 3 p.m.
today.
You have your electronic folder and our agenda can be accessed through an electronic agenda.
The audience, you need to sign in at a table just outside the room.
Binders are on the table with separate pages for each item number.
Please put down the item number for which you would like to speak.
And we have a general public comment item of 14, which does not specifically address any items listed on the board's agenda.
Public comment will be limited to one minute per speaker and the red signal will signal you when your time limit is up.
If you want to give the board members anything or submit any copies, please leave 25 copies with the staff at the front desk here on my right.
Speakers, please introduce yourself.
and the organization you represent before you begin to speak.
And we have tv monitors also with overflow rooms for the crowd at this point.
So board members, if you need to recuse yourselves, please do so before any discussion on the item.
So we're now ready for item one and I want to sort of give us the order of
what we're going to do here.
I'm going to make a few framing remarks at the beginning.
Then Nancy Brownell and Carrick Ashley will make a proposal which will include the motion in their proposal and they will also make a presentation on background items.
Then we will call on our liaison board, liaisons on this item, board member Strauss, board member Burr.
Then we will ask for board member technical questions.
And after those are done, we will proceed to public comment so that the board can hear that after they're clarified on technical questions.
And then we will have board deliberation.
And so that'll be our order of business at this point.
So let me just make a few overall remarks about this.
There are many functions of accountability, not just finding schools and districts that are not meeting performance standards.
This accountability plan also wants to better understand what's going on in districts and schools in order to figure out how better to assist and improve them.
These many functions require a broader base and conceptual framework for accountability than we've had in the past.
Secondly, the Board is implementing a law of the Legislature from 2013, the Local Control Funding Formula.
That law contained eight state priorities, 22 specified metrics, and 13 subgroups.
So this is going to be complex, and we're going to talk about how we will communicate with the public about this, but we're implementing the law.
And the law outlines, as our attachment 4 indicates,
clear intervention and technical assistance policies for this accountability program.
And so we're really just an attachment four on what the procedure is to intervene and provide technical assistance.
We're following the law very closely on that.
Third, we have aligned to the federal statute.
But not to the proposed federal regulations by the U.S.
Secretary of Education.
The Secretary of Education in Washington received 21,000 comments, including many comments from us, many other states and organizations.
And so we really don't know what the regulations will be.
We'll probably not find out until
at least December, and I expect a lot of these issues will go over to the next administration.
We have five top-line state indicators in our program, which also satisfy the five top-line indicators required by the federal Every Student Succeeds statute.
But we also have a mix of state standards that are uniform across the states and local indicators.
So areas of school climate, parent engagement, for example, will be locally designed indicators and the state will vet various instruments that locals might use for these surveys and they will be related to the local control and accountability plans called LCAP.
Finally, any prototypes you've seen of what we're doing is sort of like looking at the operating system for a new phone.
It is not the end user product.
We have been, I think, unfairly criticized in some cases that this is not what your iPhone you're going to end up with.
This is the operating system of the iPhone.
So yes, it does look more confusing.
We have some months after this to actually devise what the end user will see in that regard, and it won't be as complex as the kind of displays we've had to do so far as we deliberate on this system.
And lastly, this is an action that will be taken with a commitment towards continuous improvement.
We will, as outlined in our attachments, be studying several improvements.
This is the baseline.
We, for example, will substitute chronic absence for suspensions.
Suspensions will only last a year.
And that gives you an idea that it is indeed a continuous improvement project.
So, with those framing comments, I would like then for our presenters to come up and present their analysis and discuss our motion.
Good morning, board members, Superintendent Torlakson, public members here, nice to see you today.
Just a little reminder, we do have a new technology system, so I know that our folks in the booth there are working on it, but if odd things happen, it might be because of that.
If other odd things happen, I don't know.
My name is Nancy Brown-Allen.
I'm staff to the State Board of Education.
It's a pleasure to talk about item one.
And my colleague, Carrick, will be joining me at times to talk about more specificity.
So a little bit of the brief context.
Obviously, this item has been one that has been a discussion at board meetings and many other opportunities with stakeholders.
A reminder, obviously, that for the last really six months or so, there has been a lot of intense work evolving the system.
In March, the adoption or the discussion of the architecture of the accountability and continuous improvement system and the thinking on your part and staff recommendations related to how the component pieces need to be considered in the larger context.
In May, the determination of looking at a balance of local and state measures and plans for really moving towards this one coherent local, state, and federal system ultimately for accountability and improvement.
In July, robust discussion about the standards and performance expectations with some additional direction to staff to continue to develop.
Both the standards and the look at how a web-based rubric system could work and how the design features need to be considered.
September, obviously, we are here, and this is not about approving the template today.
That has been delayed, but about really looking at the evaluation rubrics.
So, as usual in this item, there were some memos in August that really went into great detail.
You additionally have passed out in your folders some of the lookup tables around the setting of the performance expectations for the state standards as just a quick reference.
The attachments that are here really focus on the overview of the design elements for the evaluation rubrics, the actual proposed standards for the state standards,
and the proposed standards for the local performance indicators, along with some criteria for eligibility of technical assistance, support, and more intensive intervention, a draft timeline, obviously, of the work that will be continuing to move forward, and references to the California Code.
relative to LCFF.
I've circled the attachments 1, 2, 3, 4 specifically.
These are really linked to the actions you are taking today specific to moving the development of the LCFF rubrics particularly.
So staff thought it would be helpful to sort of ground us in the recommendations for action.
This is, for many of us, kind of a momentous opportunity to move to the next phase of implementation of the LCFF.
system as a whole, including now the evaluation rubrics.
So just as a reminder, the purpose of the discussion today and the input from the public is really focused on the actions that hopefully you will be taking through the course of the meeting.
So this is quite a hefty recommendation, as noted in the item itself.
The first one, which is linked to attachment one, really focuses on the following components that have been evolving over time based on a concise set of indicators.
both state and local for the evaluation rubrics, the identification of the performance standards, the criteria for determining the local agency LEA eligibility, the statements of model practices, and links to additional resources.
Those are the big concepts that actually are part of the design features that make up the rubric system, which I will be talking about in more detail.
The second part of the recommendation, which is included in Attachment 2, focuses on really the proposed performance standards based on the methodology that was approved in the prior meeting to establish the cut scores and performance categories.
And that folder that you have from the department staff really has the background in summary fashion of those charts in case you should need it.
This is, again, looking at the cut scores and categories for progress of English learners, high school graduation rate, college and career indicator, suspension rates by LEA type, and as noted on the slide, these are linked to the specific priorities, as Mike mentioned in the introductory comments, around the priorities identified in the legislation.
Continuing as part of attachment three, the recommendations are for the proposed standards for the local performance indicators.
And as noted and as you'll see in the models and obviously what was identified in great detail both in the August memo and in the item itself is the focus on the capacity to take a look at the local performance indicators through the lens of MET
not met for two years because there is not a complete set of data available for all of these.
So those are listed there, including Priorities 9 and 10, which focus on the expectations of county programs in their LCAPs.
And lastly in this section is the criteria for determining eligibility for technical assistance.
This is again been an increasing set of recommendations moving forward that the purpose obviously of using the rubrics also entails the kinds of support and technical assistance in a continuous improvement model that would be of use to districts across the state.
And that's outlined in Attachment 4.
In addition to those major actions, there are four additional focused areas for continued development of the system by staff.
And so, as you well know, this has been an ongoing project.
We're reaching a point where there are a lot of pieces in play.
There will be continuing development of the work moving forward.
including, as number six indicates here, approve the proposed process by which the State Board will be able to review the evaluation rubrics, particularly in this first couple of years.
Obviously, the ongoing work will be informed by the use by local education agencies, charter schools, county programs,
So that opportunity within this first year really is a part of the board's role in continuous improvement as noted in some of the principles for developing a new system is that we've all got to get better at what we're doing at both the policy and the practical level to really support our schools and districts.
So a reminder that the work staff has done since July was really based on the approved design of the evaluation rubrics that included as noted in the prior
board items, a concise set of state and local performance indicators, the standards, which have been discussed over both the May and the July state board meetings, and the methodologies for determining those.
The criteria for determining eligibility for technical assistance as provided again in the statute with some very specific language of when that needs to occur.
And the ongoing work on the draft statements of model practices as options to assist schools and districts and the links to much more detailed resources.
So given that, the importance here in the decisions you're making today go back to, again, some of what President Kirsch said this morning, that the accountability and continuous improvement system has really been focused for the last two years on
much more about the local control and accountability plans and the annual updates as districts have implemented those.
The evaluation rubrics are a new tool coming on board for use this year and moving forward, and the context of the support and assistance system as a part of the entire efforts to build a system that does focus on continuous improvement.
Just a reminder that the evaluation rubrics, as identified in the LCFF statutes, are intended to serve some major purposes.
To support LEAs in identifying their strengths and weaknesses in areas needed for improvement, to assist in whether LEAs are
eligible for a tiered system of technical assistance leading to more intense intervention for pervasive problems, perhaps, and to assist the superintendent in determining whether LEAs are eligible for more intensive state and support and, of course, the ongoing work that the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence will be doing.
So, the work that you're seeing today and the decisions you're making really focus on the statutory deadline of October 1st, 2016 that was extended from last year.
As you might remember, boy, a long time ago, September 2015 feels like.
The initial phase of this implementation really provides opportunities for LEAs to work with the rubrics along with other interested groups to see how this information then can become useful to them in analyzing their LCAPs and moving toward their annual updates and priorities in terms of their actions and services that may be needed as a result of what the data is showing.
And the goal has been simultaneously that this web-based system be user-friendly to multiple groups of audiences, which, as President Kirst mentioned, this is a complex system.
Some in the public, I think, have criticized some of the work in the press, for example, but the idea is when you're moving toward a much more holistic, multidimensional system,
how that looks and what you are able to communicate really becomes critically important.
So, the components of the LCFF evaluation rubrics that we have been working with through the course of the last, really, 18 months is this notion that, as Member Strauss and I like to talk about, those of us that are very familiar with rubrics
have struggled a little bit as many stakeholders have is, what kind of rubric is this?
And this is a different kind of rubric if you are an English teacher or a math teacher or a history teacher that looks at a four or five point spread.
This is the very weak dimensions, these are the very strong dimensions and we'll give you a number and that'll get translated into a wonderful grade on your capacity as a student.
It has many dimensions of that, but the components are that there's a top-level data.
display that gives a quick picture of how a school's district and student groups are doing.
There is the data analysis tool that is able to move into more detailed data reports and you'll see some prototype mock-ups today that might include that.
The statements of model practices and the links to additional resources.
That is the picture of
what the evaluation rubric system includes at this particular initial phase of work.
So the design repeats from the prior slide that we have been working on.
And this slide 13 is an example of staff taking advice from the board, as always, from the July meeting.
We worked with our colleagues at WestEd and brought in a graphic designer who has much more knowledge of iconography than most of us do, also have the capacity to use the kind of technology programs that allow you to do this kind of work.
So this is a simple example that we also spent some time, August 20th, there was a policy discussion on August 19th
with an array of stakeholders about some of these models.
There was an additional webinar on August 26th that WestEd sponsored that allowed people to kind of look at some of these mock-ups in a way to give feedback, but the concept here is much different than our last little
Excel spreadsheet set of boxes.
This, again, is a model.
This is not, I'll repeat, this is not necessarily the final product.
But the idea that here would be a simple kind of look at here are the state standards, here are the local, on this one they said self-assessment indicators.
Again, this was an early prototype from three weeks ago, I think.
The color coding, which I'm going to talk about in more detail related to setting the status and change dimensions across the packet you have for the cut scores, and the idea then that by clicking on the arrows,
and you could get to much more detail.
But we actually were quite pleased with this as a way to begin to help shape how a web-based system would really look in the system.
So on that note, I'm going to, oh, and I have to say it because it's such a great story.
The icons on this particular graphic are called Harvey Balls.
They are called Harvey Balls.
They are the round ideograms that consumer reports use.
They are actually a technical term that helps visual communication.
Yes?
They are commonly used to describe complex data.
Harvey Poppel is the inventor of these, not to be confused with Harvey Balls, who invented the smiley face.
So a little factoid of information that we learned in the development of this that who'd have thought.
So as a result of this initial look at information,
Oh, okay, well, I think if I get to this one, it'll be easier, but thank you.
And I'll try to come back on that.
So taking that concept that said we did have to have a little more specific use of symbols and text, we began working with colleagues at the San Joaquin County Office, along with WestEd,
I may need help making this screen bigger.
Someone.
Here we go.
So again, many disclaimers.
If somebody from technology can help me make the screen bigger, that'd be great.
Anyone?
Thank you.
So San Joaquin County Office and WestEd in working with the department staff and state board staff began to say this concept again of a web-based tool was still a little vague.
So this is really a complete mock-up
The real one may not look exactly like this, probably will not.
We wanted to have some advice from the technology folks on the team to really help us think about this in a more detailed way.
So here's the notion
of how in this prototype the web-based system might be easily accessible, clear, and informative to multiple audiences, and I'll come back around on those categories.
So here's a sample kind of landing page.
Obviously, this was just an attempt to put together some of the key information.
So, these three boxes, for example, that, again, there would need to be some additional text information and directions for people to how to get to a navigatable site, which will come in the development.
But here are categories of the rubrics.
The LCAP eTemplate, once it becomes online, and for purposes for now, the SARK, obviously, as part of a tool that is in place.
The idea that the technology folks are building this so it can be easily searchable.
that it can also be accessed on a phone.
So, for those of us that don't have as much of the technical expertise, we learned that you build from the smallest device up, right?
So, in order to have a system that's easily accessible on multiple devices, it has to work on the phone, which is, for example, much more about arrows that go down the page as opposed to across, because there's not as much space, obviously, on certain kinds of technology.
So as a pretend LCFF rubric model, as my grandsons might say, is this pretend or is this real, Gramps?
This is pretend.
But the concept is here.
So for example, if I click on the rubrics,
I would get then to a similar kind of page that we see in lots of data that would take me to all of the districts in the state.
We're going to be using the West Chavez Unified School District.
I click on that and this takes me to this idea of a top level display.
And a reminder that for now, we are using pie-shaped or fruit slice-shaped icons.
We're just using the colors.
This obviously may not stay in this format, but this is to help us kind of get the picture of, as Eric Crane, our colleague from WestEd, said at the July meeting,
To see Peg right, the goal is to get to green.
It's excellent if our schools and districts and student groups are performing in a category that is blue or green because that demonstrates a high level of success.
The idea is that there could be some tabs across the top for more detailed reports.
Again, this is a more simplified version.
So we have the state indicators.
This, for purposes of this prototype, this is the number of all student groups.
And again, someone will say, some of this data doesn't make sense, Nancy.
Correct.
It's probably good it doesn't make sense.
So people recognize this as a
prototype mock-up that still has a lot of developmental work to do, but our sense is, as you've also indicated, how might this really work, is that we're getting much closer.
So these are all student groups that are here identified in the state, and the state has
Local performance indicators, remember, are just at the district level because it's the met, not met.
We just put the rating in there for now.
This would need to be clarified.
The other thing that we've been talking about with our colleagues in San Joaquin is there could be some rollover boxes that I might rollover on this and it will tell me what all student groups mean.
That's the number of subgroups.
It could tell me what the blue color means.
It could go into more detail about what does it mean to be red or orange.
And of course, this piece is among the student groups in this state indicator.
Two groups are in the red-orange category, right?
This is the quick look at, oh, I've got to do some more detailed work.
Clearly, if I look at math assessment without having a lot more information, it may say to me, gosh, we've got some issues going on with mathematics very clearly.
On the other hand, a suspension rate doesn't look too bad.
I could always probe for more details.
So the importance, remember, in getting to the ratings is the work that you have in the folders from the department around status.
How are we doing in reaching standards met, for example, in assessment or exceeded?
And are we increasing, for example, the number of student groups who are continuing to improve over time?
If I click on English Language Arts, I get to, again, different ways that I might organize the reports.
There will be text, of course, that explain this report provides the color-coded rating for a single indicator.
So we took English Language Arts, and this shows me for West Chavez Unified.
Among all of my student groups, this is the quick rating
along with the Statements of Model Practices for English Language Arts that might trigger some more of our self-reflection and conversation at the district and school levels, and then there would be
some links to external resources.
A very important piece for the board, obviously, the ELA-ELD framework with specified chapters that might be of much more interest.
There could be some information, obviously, about the task performance.
That link would take us to the department's website.
So the hope would be that in a few clicks,
there's quite a range of information that I could get to, whether I'm a parent or whether I'm a superintendent.
As I look at the tab here, if I want to see, well, of all those subgroups, let's see who's doing well in our district.
And that takes me to the rating colors that are the student groups who are doing well, blue and green levels, meaning they have a high status of performance on the English Language Arts Assessment, and they're continuing to increase over time, right?
So that reminder
with the lookup charts you have in the packet, that's how we get to that color coding.
It's that look at the status and change dimensions across the indicators.
If I want to see on the other hand, well, where are we still needing some assistance?
I can very quickly see that for this district and these obviously are numbers of 30 or more students to be able to generate the data.
We get to a look that says, hmm, we have a lot of work to do as a district when we want to probe a little more deeply.
We could begin looking at our assessment results in literacy and English language arts.
Is it specific to particular grade levels?
So again, in a very short amount of time, as a district team, as a parent advisory group, there are some ways that we begin to say, in addition to what we're finding at the local level, there needs to be some additional work that may lead to some changed actions and services in our LCAP related to meeting the needs of our student groups.
And again, lastly, as a mock-up prototype that could be developed over time, if I click on English Learners, this then takes me to my group of students who are English Learners, and I get a quick look at how they are doing across
all of the state indicators related to whether there's progress or change going on.
We see that there are some good things here that we can feel good about in the context of what's happening for this particular group of students in our district.
We still have some work to do, for example, around obviously the college and career readiness.
So while this is not
The real web-based user interface, it's much closer than the Excel spreadsheet version of July.
We know there's some consternation that things do seem to be changing.
Yes, that is correct.
Change is a good thing in the development of a web-based user system.
and the opportunity to, again, with your thinking and decisions today, the further refinement and development of the web-based system with the expectation that our colleagues in San Joaquin would have
The data populated by the end of November of 2016 for this year, our colleagues at the California Collaborative are very anxiously awaiting some models that are close to real because they're planning the training across the state for the use of the rubrics and the use for strengths and weaknesses analysis for helping districts this year in phase one really trying these out in a way
so that by January, February, if the data is available the end of November for districts to review and provide feedback.
We know there's not a lot of time between the end of November and January, given the school schedules, but ultimately there will be some data issues that probably need to be resolved
so that by January it could become a working public system whereby districts and their stakeholders could also use this data as they begin analyzing where they're doing well, where they may need to look again within the context of their annual updates and their LCAP revisions for the 17-18 year.
So on that note, I'll take
Clarifying questions, that's.
No, I think we're going to have our liaisons talk and then we'll have you back for if there are technical questions, clarifying questions.
So, uh, member Burr, member Strauss.
the whole presentation?
Yes.
Okay.
I wasn't sure if Karen was going to speak or not.
So a couple things I just want to reinforce, and since I get to be the first one out of the gate, my first comment is how deeply appreciative I am of all of the work that both the board staff, the department staff, superintendent, all of you have done over the last couple of years to get to this point.
Because I sort of reflect back and go, wow, did we ever think this was going to happen?
And also to just sort of reiterate a little bit about what Nancy said and to build on President Kirst's comments, this is a very complex system.
We live in a very complex state that has 10,000 schools, over 1,000 school districts, about an equal number of charter schools, all of the subgroups that we're learning about, and so
While it would be great if we could just produce one piece of paper and say, this is it, it's just not possible, and it's not possible in the world in which we live.
But I do think that what we're going to be asked to vote on later today is really reflective of the kinds of things we've been talking about over the last couple of years.
And probably most importantly, to again reinforce what President Kerr said, it makes operational a state law.
which contains very specific priorities.
If I were writing it today, I would probably want it to have fewer, because I do think that adds to the complexity, but nevertheless, it has eight for LEAs, it has 10 for County Offices of Education, and 22 metrics, and for 13 or 14 subgroups that we have to be responsible for.
So given all of that, and given our responsibility to do that, I think we are in a really good shape to have that happen.
I want to reinforce a couple of things, and we'll get to some of these in a lot more detail later on, but just what President Kirst said, this is intended to be an integrated system.
Because if you think about three years ago, we didn't have a new federal law.
The federal law was Carrick's Christmas gift, as I recall, when we got the reauthorization of NCLB.
So now we add another complexity on top of it.
But I just want to reinforce what we have said over and over again, that this will be an integrated system.
There will not be two systems.
There will not be a state system and a federal system.
Some of our letter writers seem to confuse that, so I just want to make sure, and maybe we all want to say it out loud or in unison, but it will be an integrated system, and that's the important part.
The one piece that I think is relatively new in our conversation, both in all of the written information that we got, and we heard a little bit about it today and we can talk about it more, is what I always called the so what question.
Now we've defined all this stuff, we've set standards, we've figured out, you know, what we think LEAs should be trying to do, and then the question is, and what do you do if they don't?
what happens.
And I just want to say at the outset that we take our responsibility at the state very seriously.
We are the backstop for the children of California and that we will make sure that they don't fail.
And the way we do that is through a differentiated set of technical assistance that is grounded in whether or not our subgroups are doing well.
Again, I think some of our commenters sort of lost that piece of information.
And it's laid out very clearly in the statute that, you know, if you, we start down beginning next year when we have all this information, if you fail in one or more subgroups, meaning you're not meeting the standards,
then we start helping you.
We start helping you at the county office level, which is our first line of defense and who are the agents of the state in doing coaching, linking you to peer networks, etc.
We then go up to the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence, which will provide some more intensive assistance.
and is working on that right now.
And then ultimately, if you fail over a number of years and over a number of subgroups, Superintendent Torlakson is required to step in, come to us for approval with even greater intensive assistance.
So I just wanted to kind of highlight that because I think it's the first time and there does again seem to be some confusion around that.
I think we'll talk about that in greater detail later, but just want to call your attention to attachment four.
because I think it really clearly lays it out.
And for those of you who love to read statute as much as I do, education code 52072 is crystal clear about what the role of especially the superintendent and ultimately the state board as that backstop for the constitutional rights of all the children in our state.
Okay, board member Strauss.
I just would like to echo member Burr's thanks to the staff of CDE and State Board.
We've come a long way.
I think the reality is it's really complex and I think we know we're not there yet.
I think each meeting we see subsequent progress and I also would like to say thank all the staff for the memos in between because it kind of helps you follow
the threads of how all the pieces are coming together.
And I think the reality from our analysis and from the presentation that Nancy made today and from the work is that we have a lot of placeholders of where we're starting from that we hope will develop over time.
So I wanted to highlight technically some concerns I have and that is shared before public comments and then I think all of us will have some more comments afterwards.
First,
College and career indicator has been a lot of conversation.
It's been a moving target as a former high school principal.
We know that college and career is a complicated issue as kids get older.
And it's far more than just A to G. It's far more than just tests.
And I think we are
clear about the need for developing the career technical area.
We don't really have clear measures about that.
There's been a huge investment on the state on our career pathway trust.
So obviously lots more work needs to be done in that area.
The other thing is there's been a lot of discussion about the four levels and are you really prepared
Are you somewhat prepared?
Are you not prepared at all?
And we know that even students who graduate A to G and pass high school exit and have a decent score on EAP get to UC or CSU and have to do remedial courses.
So we do know that even with that level that's currently in place in high schools, we find many students not fully ready when they enter high
college and also that our independent colleges don't use those some of those measures.
So I think with that there's been a lot of work and I appreciate what the technical design team's done to try to get us at a beginning level.
I appreciate the transition from CST to Smarter Balanced.
We now have a couple years of Smarter Balanced.
CST is a more limited and less rigorous than some of the stuff we're doing now with our
11th grade smarter balance.
But I feel like the college and career is just at a beginning level and I want to make that really clear that that's what we feel all that it gives us a starting point but it will be developed over time from far more issues about numbers of APs, other course taking patterns and
the whole idea of what does it mean to be really ready when you leave us at the end of high school.
And so I have some clear concerns in that area and I look forward to continuing to have some feedback.
I think we're going to get some more input each board meeting is my understanding.
But where we are is really, I think, just a beginning level for looking at what we need to do over that.
I think also there's an issue of readiness level with the standard three versus standard two on Smarter Balanced for 11th grade.
We know that our Smarter Balanced score levels are much more rigorous than what we had before.
And so that was established by a national process.
But I think we have a lot more work to do in the college and career readiness.
I just want to make that clear.
Also on the English language learner indicator, I know there's going to be a work group that's going to be working on this and we'll be getting feedback and some recommendations to state board.
I feel like we will always, I believe, have an English learner indicator, but it's going to develop over time.
And I know we're going to be piloting our new test.
But if that pilot test is effective, we could speed up some of the transition to modifying that ELI indicator.
So I feel, and we'll probably talk a lot more about English Learner, but it's not where it needs to be, and I think that work group will have some big responsibility that CDE is convening to work on that.
And then as a practitioner you've heard me ask about plan alignment and Nancy showed a little bit because she had SARC on there on her on her mock-up.
But for local districts what we're trying to do is get this coordinated.
So you're not doing all these separate plans but in fact it's aligned.
So with your federal requirement with an LEA plan
and your local LCAP and the CONAP that you do and the SARC that's required under legislation.
And I know that Glenn there's been a CDE's been have a work group.
I know it's very complicated.
I know we're hoping to cross populate all that stuff.
But I'd like in the comments to clarify and come back with us maybe in November about so where are we in moving to aligning where we can because clearly you heard Sue talk about the fact that we want this aligned.
so that it's not just bureaucratic, but actually makes sense so that communities and staff can see, this is what we do in XYZ district that serve all kids, not in all separate compartments.
So I think that's a really clear issue.
The other thing we've not resolved, what does it mean for a broad course of study?
ADG is not the only thing.
First of all, broad course of study starts in elementary school, then it goes to middle school.
In high school, you can measure it in a data system when you input courses in high school,
but you ought to be able to tell an elementary here are some examples of what an effective broad course of study is.
We don't want you just working on math and literacy.
We want you working in arts and physical education and health and history and science and all the things that are important to you.
So that work on priority seven about what are indicators of a broad course of study is not only a high school issue and it's not clearly defined and my hope is that our statement of model practice and I just want to thank Nancy for her comments that
It's the most rubric-like, for those of us who live with rubrics, about how do you measure where you are against exemplars?
So in a normal exemplar, you might have four levels, and are you approaching, where are you in the progress?
And so as the statement of model practices comes in, I think that might be an area where we would say,
This is what exemplars are for a broad course of study in elementary school and middle school.
It's certainly our commitment to well develop broadly our next generation.
Certainly, I think that's what our priorities are.
But I think the model practices are our best hope for really giving exemplars.
And while it's voluntary, when you're doing a self-assessment about are you implementing things, those are where I think you get the exemplars to match to.
And so I'm looking forward to some of those how, but I'd like CD to clarify at some point, like how are we going to develop these model practices?
I know they're not done yet, but I think there's some draft forms.
When are we going to see those?
It is a part of the rubric of all, it's one of the components.
and I think we know there's still a lot of work to do this year but I think both the plan alignment, where the model practices are, what the work groups are going to do with the broad course of study, with the parent engagement surveys, with the school climate, all those pieces still some of those have to be developed where to get us where we need to be.
So I would like the CDE to help us understand where the work groups will fit in and
So in November we're likely, I know we're going to deal with the LCAP template finalizing that.
When do we think the EL learner, I think that's not even meeting till this fall.
When does that group come together?
Alternative education, which I know is an important piece.
There's a work group starting on that, so I think we need an update.
so that the board itself, as we interact with people and in our role as board members, know that where we are now and then how are all these technical pieces going to come together?
And as we work with our public and our constituencies, we can share with people we are working toward a fully integrated program.
So those are key areas.
I think I am expecting we're going to hear some comments on those areas and then we could maybe develop and discuss those as a board following the public comments.
Thank you.
OK, board member clarifying technical issues.
We want to hear the public testimony.
Board member Rucker.
Well, I do want to thank the staff for putting this work together because what we have here is I'm not comfortable with the idea that we still are not we're still just beginning because that's actually not quite accurate or to say that this is incomplete because that's actually not quite accurate either.
This has been a very long multi-year conversation that has dominated the agenda of this board for a long time.
But what we have today is something that we haven't had before, a mental model about how the rubric will look.
and an idea about how the reporting or how the interface on reporting can operate.
And I think that that was an important key step, because I read very carefully a lot of the feedback that we received from stakeholders and their letters, and the concerns really were more addressing this,
Then the technical issues about what's in the statute concerning the 8 state priorities, the 22 specific metrics and how the information is going to be reported on the 13 subgroups.
What they were really talking about was creating a model for what the reporting would look like.
So technically, I think today, with what was presented by the staff, we've kind of opened that door on that conversation.
And it doesn't mean we have started.
It doesn't even mean it's incomplete.
It means we have finally crafted something to present to the public that addresses the issue of the mental model, because we've still been thinking about and having conversations on multiple different ways about what this is supposed to look like.
But this is more than a start because I agree with both what Board Member Burr said and what President Kerr said.
Today what we're approving will implement the statute, will implement fully the intent of the statute, not as a beginning, not as an initial first step, not as some incomplete process.
I want to make very clear we are implementing the statute by the action we may take today.
The other thing, though, is in implementing the statute, whoever said getting there is half the fun never tried to construct a new accountability system.
because what we're also doing is turning the page.
We're going from what has been a very binary accountability system to what I have spent my entire career in education, even as a student, asking for, which was better information, and not just information about a test or a collection of tests, so that
Multiple measures have become more than just multiple assessments, and we are creating a system, or at least the goal on these metrics is to create a system that tells us more about the schools.
That's the technical piece that the conversation probably is going to have to continue with.
So, when we look at what's going on with the LPAC or with the assessments that still have to be developed, the question is not whether or not they will be included in the system.
That decision has been made.
They will be included.
The question is, what type of information will this new assessment that we haven't seen implemented yet, what type of information is our system asking this assessment to tell us, and then how will we use the data?
That's very different from whether or not the rubric and the accountability system we will try to adopt today is developed.
Because yes, the answer is yes, it's been developed.
We still have to do the work to understand what these new metrics will mean and what the system is asking these metrics to tell us.
about the performance of the students and therefore the performance of the schools and the programs they implement.
That's a different type of accountability issue beyond what the statutory requirement is that we're asked of today.
So, I want to make sure in taking this action that we're not conflating multiple types
of policy conversations, that we are clearly taking the step to implement the statute today, but the conversation about then what this means, how we understand it, or how we interpret or review and analyze what this new system is going to report, that's very different.
And yes, that may be a beginning conversation, but this completes and closes a circle on a very long and I think very broad
very inclusive and very transparent process to complete the development of this system.
Thank you, Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
Thank you.
I have a lot of questions and comments, but I thought we were just going to focus on this particular tool.
So I do want to thank everyone who has worked on this tool.
I see a lot of promise in the use of this dashboard, and I'm very excited to see how it evolves.
I did have a question, however, on the top-level display.
I saw the words red and orange.
not equity report.
And though it has the same purpose, I want to see the words equity report because the word equity reminds us of our commitment and obligation to narrow achievement gaps for the students that are identified the subgroups in that column, which happen to be the same subgroups that are generating additional funding.
So words matter.
And the message of putting equity in that top level display is a message that I don't want to see lost, though we have the purpose, which is identifying those that are red and orange.
So
Is there, can you write the last right column that says red-orange, not equity report?
Was there a reason behind that?
No, again, these were an opportunity to kind of build on some graphics that seemed to hold promise.
We had about
a week to work on this with San Joaquin.
So the details of the wording, all of that really still needs to be designed in a much more explicit way based on the feedback that we've gotten from the state board members.
So there was, it was on some earlier ones and then in the translation and working with folks trying to say, okay, what if we put it this way?
So there was no intent to leave that out.
It was just a matter of could we get something put together that would be usable at the meeting?
Okay, really good to know, because I definitely want to see those words, which are the words we also voted for.
The other thing, or the yellow, so I appreciate that we have green and blue, and then we have orange and red.
My concern has been what happens to the middle, which is the yellow.
Those are not, those subgroups will not be targeted through technical assistance.
We haven't seen anything that really shows how we're going to move those students.
And we're also now excluding them from
And I know it's obvious if you're not red or orange and you're not blue and green, you're yellow.
But I think it just gives it that prominence that we can't forget the middle because these students, through our technical assistance plan or as the way I'm reading it, will not be reached.
And so we want to make sure we're focusing on those yellow subgroups too.
Absolutely, and good point.
We did again the quick, let's do red, orange, blue, green for the purpose of here, but the assumption would be there would be ways to go in and look across all of the performance levels within a fully developed system.
Okay.
Are we going to have a more specific technical presentation, or is this the presentation?
Because it depends on what I would  my comments.
Well, this was to clarify and understand things, you know, and I thought, for example, what was on this report and what wasn't on as just a mock-up makes sense.
But we did want to hear the public testimony and then have the broader discussion.
So, you know, the idea was to have the public comment.
So if you have clarifications as we just heard, that's fine.
Okay, so, so far, really appreciate the comments of my fellow board members, Rucker and Burr and member Strauss.
In setting the context for this, understanding that we have more technical work to do and how we populate, but it really, it is about the concept and it is groundbreaking in what we're doing.
So, very, very pleased with all of this.
form follows function, and I think we now see how it functions through the form, and then I think now the form will also tell us and inform us about how we can refine the function within it.
So I am really, really pleased with all that we are working on.
Same concerns around the college career piece.
I want to make sure that we are going to be technically sound when we come out with specific school and LEA data.
I really want to make sure that it's technically sound so that we are as valid and reliable in the information that we present to the public about our LEAs and schools as possible.
Let's see.
Some of it is very specific, detailed, technical, but also something that you had said, too, and I think that we want to
think about down the road is getting to that blue, getting to that green and blue.
Right now, the way that we have structured on the technical level, it is that we're doing school
school to school or LEA to LEA comparison.
So our cut points are based on kind of the spectrum of that.
So we will, there will be some schools who may never be able to get to blue or green because we're putting them on a, on a range.
So, at some point, I know we need to start somewhere with where we are technically.
At some point, we may want to look at what is an absolute standard that we want all schools to reach and provide that support up to that standard.
So, that's something that long-term to think about over the next year.
I think that's what I have now.
Thank you.
Okay, just to clarify too, we'd be happy to answer more technical questions after the public comment if you have, and Carrick's team is prepared as well, so.
State Superintendent.
Just on a clarifying point, if you could go back to the slide on English learners, and just to walk us through what the numbers mean.
There are columns with percents, status, percents of what, and then there's, of course, change based on some base level.
So if you wouldn't mind walking us through what, and it's a little hard to see, but I can read the percentage numbers.
Graduation rate's 84.4%.
Right, so again, within the context of the methodology, right, we want to know, for example, in this student group of English learners, I'll take a look at the English Language Arts Assessment, for example, 30.2% of our English learners on their Smarter Balanced assessments are at or above standard.
So the percentage does depend on which of the indicators we're looking at.
Similarly in mathematics.
For our English learner group, 19.4% of them are at or above standard.
The change indicator, obviously because we're only in our second year of data, we don't have a way to measure yet.
We're getting to that point where the change, remember, looks at three years of data by comparison.
So I'll go to grad rates.
84.4% of English learners in West Chavez are graduating, but notice in the change, that is a decrease in the percentage of students in the English learner group who are graduating.
So while 84 may look
Pretty good, the fact that that is a declining number compared to the last few years.
Puts them into the yellow.
Puts them into the yellow in a way that says, what's going on here?
We as a district have to probe a little bit more.
So that's the sort of design of the methodology around both status and change.
I think that was helpful and also discussed the interface with the met or exceed standards with the smarter balance, so that helps.
And the chart I had handed out earlier today, if you look at the different subgroups, English learners are at the very bottom of improvement, only 1%, not anywhere close to 5 for math.
Keeps changing.
It keeps changing.
Yeah, you graduate out of that group.
So we should not, we've had many discussions about clarifying that English learner report because it's the students as they become more frequent.
fully competent in English, they move out of there, so you just have a pool that keeps rotating through.
But it's an indicator.
It's not a good overall measure of English learners.
But it indicates an issue or a challenge there, I think.
And in a fully developed system, as I mentioned, there could be rollovers here that I could put my cursor on here and a text will come up and tell me what this is, or what the color means in relationship.
So again, in a way that we need a simple system that people can access, but there needs to be much more information about what they're seeing here.
So that also would be a part of the fully developed system.
Okay, do we have anybody else over here on this?
Okay, board member Rucker.
And then, as it relates directly to, specifically to the English Learner Report, because as President Kirst talked about, this is a group that doesn't remain static.
I mean, if you're in the subgroup of African-American students, well, you're kind of stuck there.
But with the English Learner Group, that is a static... In a good way.
In a good way.
Yes, in a very good way.
I can witness that.
But the issue on this is,
Maybe we need to consider how to think about the English learner subgroup either as a cohort or that is defined as being a group that this data is about a group of students for a particular defined specified period of time because we know that this does change over time.
This may be one of the subgroups that we have to figure out
a technical way to treat or define differently for purposes of this reporting because based on this technical piece, this group may never see a change if the collection of students that we report on, we can't truly make year-to-year or over time or across time comparisons because we're not going to be talking about the same group of students
over time or over their career as K-12 students as a cohort like we do with the whole graduation rate.
Does that make sense?
Makes perfect sense.
Thank you, Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent, CDE.
So we'll have a lot to say about this tomorrow, item number one, when we will take a little time to look at those
very encouraging test results from last year's Smarter Balanced results, but also talk a little bit about moving forward, how to better explain to the public and to everyone actually, especially this group of English learners, which does change unlike almost any other student group there.
These students get reclassified and then they're out of the student group.
So we'll talk a little bit more about that
uh... tomorrow i think we have a deferral tomorrow on this issue if we could because we're gonna have a full conversation yeah yes yes yes any other board all right so before we take public comment i think the board will take a ten minute break and will uh... reconvene at ten twenty five
Board will reconvene and we'll begin the public comment.
If the audience would sit down, please.
So we will reconvene and open up with a public comment.
Before public comment, I wanted to clarify that the board has not decided to replace suspension with chronic absence.
I meant to say that was an example of something we might consider.
So I wanted to make that comment clear at this point.
So we will go with suspension until further notice.
So please have the board people in the comment people line up in the order they signed in.
Okay, we have 116 speakers, seven of which are groups of people, which one minute for a single, three minutes for a group.
I'm going to call the numbers.
Remember, we've moved to the numbering system, so if numbers one through 16 would please line up.
And it looks like Superintendent Mike Hanson is on the number one group.
Okay, yes, thank you.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Kirsch, Superintendent Torlakson, and members of the State Board.
Thank you for the opportunity to be here today.
My name is Mike Hanson.
I'm serving in my 12th year as the Superintendent of Fresno Unified School District, and I am president of the eight-member core districts.
I am here today with my fellow core district board member, Jose Vanda, Superintendent of Sac City Unified, as well as core staff and research partners from PACE.
We'd like to acknowledge the board's work to establish a coherent local, state, and federal accountability system.
Together, over the next several minutes, we'd like to talk about and present the State and locally driven measures that the core districts are using currently to support our improvement efforts and to explain why core districts serve as a research pilot.
We strongly believe that the experience and capacity within the eight core districts, Fresno, Garden Grove, Long Beach, Los Angeles, Oakland, Sacramento, San Francisco, and Santa Ana, can support the State Board with decision making on several indicators in the month ahead.
We operate under a public dollar public good header, meaning anything we develop and all lessons go free to all throughout the state.
I want to also take the opportunity to thank Board Member Rucker for her comments around trying to develop a more complete description of what goes on in schools.
We do believe what we're doing with the core district's locally driven measures on growth, high school readiness, and social emotional learning and school climate help to provide a more complete picture of school performance
and that should be counted in the new system.
The work we're doing at Fresno Unified helps to highlight this point and I have a visual from the core districts to share with the board.
In Fresno Unified, as in many districts across California, we're working incredibly hard to close and eliminate the disproportionality between all groups on all measures.
Despite strong growth in test scores for all of our students in all groups and in all grade levels and on both math and ELA this past year, we still have a lot of work to do.
For this reason, we're making achievement of these groups a priority.
Even though we have a graduation rate now of 83.8,
And our subgroup of African American and Hispanic are 82.1 and 82.3.
That is nowhere near where we want to be as a district and as a core set of districts.
In the core districts, we are also surveying all students to better understand their development of social emotional skills and how they are experiencing the culture.
of their schools and how their students are, and we find this very illuminating, and it gives us better information so that we can attack disproportionality results.
Using this data, our research partners at PACE have shown us that our African American students report a worse school culture climate than their peers.
In other words, they feel less safe, they feel like they belong less, and they feel the rules are unfair.
These gaps remain, and we must compare these students to their peers in their own schools.
Similarly, we see that our Black and Hispanic students report lower social and emotional skills, which include growth mindset, self-efficacy, self-management, and social awareness.
This data has pointed a flashlight on social and emotional learning in school culture and climate as a potential improvement area that may contribute to closing these gaps.
We don't have all the answers yet, but we know this data is taking us to a better place in the core districts, and we look forward to pursuing this research pilot.
Thank you.
Good morning President Gerst and Superintendent Torlakson, members of the State Board, I especially want to acknowledge Olivia Sisson, the student board member who also happens to be a student at C.K.
McClatchy and also part of Sacramento City Unified School District.
My name is Jose Banda and I serve as superintendent for Sacramento City Unified School District.
The core districts have been working collaboratively for six years to improve student outcomes and to bring innovative strategies to scale.
We believe that our experiences
locally can help inform the state's evolving accountability system, especially as it relates to academic growth, eighth-grade readiness, social-emotional skills, and school culture climate.
As a research pilot, the core districts want the state to hold us accountable for all the state indicators.
In addition, we are asking the state to count academic growth, eighth-grade readiness, social-emotional skills, and school climate for accountability, improvement, and research purposes in our districts.
We believe that to support one coherent accountability and improvement system, these local driven measures must be reported at the school level and they must be used to identify schools for support and intervention.
Thank you.
Good morning members of the board.
My name is Christopher Lund.
I'm the assistant superintendent for Long Beach Unified.
Long Beach prides itself on continuous improvement.
And as of late, through the LCAP process and through CORE's accountability system, that has continued to evolve.
CORE's unique accountability system has prompted an amazing evolution in our thinking around data.
We have changed from monitoring school-wide attendance to examining chronic absenteeism rates.
Our survey data no longer stands alone, but now connects key survey measures like growth mindset to achievement results.
In addition to SBAC achievement, we now examine a unique measure of SBAC growth year-to-year.
These new measures create a crucial sense of urgency, even at select high-achieving schools with less-than-average SBAC growth.
In addition, these new measures shine a celebratory light on some of our low-achieving schools with exceptional SBAC growth.
A state-approved pilot of CORE's accountability system creates this essential sense of urgency and a crucial means to celebrate the hard work of our teachers, students, and parents.
Good morning, President Kirsh, Superintendent Torlakson, and members of the board.
My name is Noah Bookman.
I'm the Chief Accountability Officer for the Core Districts.
It's great to be with you today.
I also want to highlight our growth measure.
Acknowledging that the state is working on a growth measure and plans to roll it out over time over the next three years, Core has actually already developed a growth measure.
And what we want to offer through our research pilot is the opportunity for the state to learn from our experience around measuring growth.
This is different than the way the LCAP looks at growth.
It's not about looking at a school at two points in time.
It's looking at students from point A to point B. We control for a series of really important factors like students' prior achievement, their socioeconomic status, disability status, and English learner status.
And that really helps us isolate the impact of schools.
The factors you put in your growth measure, those are policy decisions and we want to encourage the state board to see them as that and also to see the core district's use of this in a research pilot around accountability as an opportunity to learn from that experience for the state as the state works for the next several years to improve growth.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I am Heather Huff.
I'm the Executive Director of the Research Partnership between the Core Districts and Policy Analysis for California Education, or PACE.
Today I'll be sharing a summary of findings from our recent report, Identity Crisis, which uses CORE's innovative measurement system to explore the identification of schools for support and improvement using a multiple measures framework.
I've passed out for your reference a summary of our findings.
First, we find that different academic indicators measure very different aspects of school performance, which makes the use of a summative score for ranking schools highly problematic.
Across academic measures, most schools are high on some things and low on others.
Less than 1% of schools are in the bottom 5% on every indicator, every academic indicator.
If you combine these four measures into a summative score, it averages out this variation by definition.
For this reason, a summative score fails to identify many schools that are very low on specific indicators, even if they're below average on others.
We also show that the non-academic indicators measure different aspects of school performance than academic indicators, highlighting different aspects of school performance.
As an alternative to a summative score, we provide examples of a tiered approach, which provides a transparent method for identifying schools that leverages full information on each indicator
For example, the state could decide to identify only schools that have low academic outcomes and are not demonstrating growth, or of two schools with similar academic achievement, the state could choose to focus limited resources on a school with poor non-academic outcomes rather than a school with positive non-academic outcomes, since the latter may already be on a road to improvement.
Finally, our analysis shows that the vast majority of schools will be identified for targeted support and improvement under current federal regulations, which has major implications for the state.
Together, our analyses show that decisions about how to identify schools are highly sensitive to the specific definitions employed and that these technical decisions reflect value judgments.
This and our future research will help us all understand the unintended consequences of specific policy choices, including the quantitative and qualitative study of how new measures are actually being used by educators in schools and districts across the state.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson.
PACE has submitted a letter, which is in your packets, and I'm going to speak to that letter.
For more than 30 years, PACE has been committed to supporting continuous improvement in the performance of California's education system.
We're grateful to the board for their endorsement of that commitment.
But a commitment to continuous improvement requires a commitment to learning.
And that requires both the capacity to innovate and data that allow us to evaluate those innovations.
And the research that Heather Huff has presented is one example of the kind of learning that is coming out of the CORE PACE partnership.
But that partnership will be threatened unless the CORE's accountability system is allowed to continue.
The research partnership, I think, is good for CORE, it's good for the state, it's good for all California students.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Rick Miller, Executive Director of the Core Districts.
And let me sum up our presentation as saying that we appreciate the work that's gone on.
Actually, we're very impressed with the accountability model.
We're hoping to build our work on top of the work the state has done.
But to be very clear, under the current construct, we cannot continue to do our work because we would actually have two separate systems.
So unless the local accountability models matters count,
which is to say that when you identify schools from a state and federal perspective, it's what you're counting.
It creates two systems for us locally that is deeply concerning to our districts.
So as a result of our partnership, though, we have a unique data system that actually allows us to look across a million students.
And we believe by doing this partnership together with you, we can do a national model of what continuous learning really looks like.
So we have a state model of items.
then you actually use CORE to learn more about different items.
So we look at SEL, we test it, we find out.
We see does it work as an accountability model or not.
And we're then also with PACE researching.
We're doing quantitative and qualitative research in the schools to say when you add these measures into accountability model, what happens?
That is actually unique and we think it will help move the state and forward.
Thank you very much.
Will numbers 9 through 24 please make sure they're lined up.
Hannah Melnick from the Learning Policy Institute.
Thank you staff and board members for your work developing this accountability system.
California truly stands out as a leader among states.
We appreciate the developments laid out in the proposed timeline, including exploration of a high school readiness indicator, five-year graduation rates, and school climate surveys, including the ongoing use of suspension rates.
We also appreciate the improvements made to the college and career indicator.
We do have a few recommendations on how to make the system even stronger.
First, we recommend the board use scale scores rather than percent proficient as a measure of academic performance.
Second, when the well prepared category is added to the career and college indicator, we recommend that students completing both A to G and career technical education be considered well prepared.
Finally, we encourage you to convene a group of stakeholders to develop the college and career indicator going forward.
Thank you.
I'm hoping 9 through 24 are lining up somewhere, preferably here.
How about speakers 25 through 32?
Anyone?
Okay, go ahead.
All right.
Good morning, Sasha Horwitz with the Linked Learning Alliance.
First, the Alliance greatly appreciates the continuous attention you have given to measuring college and career readiness going back to the PSAA, and we think that you have arrived at the right starting place with this indicator.
While the Linked Learning Alliance preferred the initial CCI model with all four performance levels, given the lack of career data, we agree with the decision to delay the well-prepared level in the first year.
Over the next several years, we'll remain committed to tracking the implementation of the CCI.
We'll make every effort to ensure that the necessary data are available so the well-prepared performance level can be restored in 2017-18 as proposed.
This includes developing our own data validation system for integrated college and career pathways.
Is that one minute?
All right.
Time?
However.
Okay.
Come forward, please.
Please come forward.
Please come forward and present.
Good morning.
Good morning President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, and members of the board.
My name is Cynthia Glover Woods and I'm the chief academic officer for Riverside County Office of Education.
My colleagues have deferred their time to me this morning.
On behalf of the educational leaders of Riverside County and the over 425,000 students we serve, I offer our support of item number one.
Soon you'll be taking action that represents a historic moment for California's public education system, recognizing that as educational practitioners and leaders, we impart the necessary knowledge and skills that our youth need to become successful adults who serve our economy and become tomorrow's leaders.
We applaud your steadfast commitment to developing a meaningful multiple measures accountability system that more accurately reflects the totality of public education and implicitly supports local continuous improvement practices that should be the foundation of any accountability system.
And for this, we do thank you.
We firmly believe that the basic system architecture and its most fundamental components you will be approving today is the right first step in this journey.
We appreciate your commitment to remaining open to refinements that will help to better serve our students, families, and communities.
And it's in this spirit that we offer the following for your consideration.
First, we affirm the staff recommendation for relating to the development of a distinct state indicator that meaningfully addresses state priority seven.
A priority that at its core is intended to address impediments to equal educational access for all students.
A distinct indicator that assesses how well we provide equal opportunities for academic success is a necessary and rich companion to student achievement measures.
Second, we must emphasize that in order for the evaluation rubrics to be effective strategic planning instruments, their availability must align with the LCAP development processes and practices.
We urge you to consider investments that will address the possibility of any misalignment.
Lastly, we support the development and future inclusion of a high school readiness indicator as one way to address the dearth of early metrics.
This indicator cannot only tell us who among our students needs additional support in order to graduate on time with the necessary skills, but it will enable us to leverage the totality of their high school years and provide meaningful support.
For these reasons, we urge you to prioritize the development of this indicator as part of your immediate future workload.
As always, we thank you for the opportunity to comment, but mostly we thank you for your courageous action that you'll soon be taking on behalf of our students.
Thank you.
Good morning, Sarah Botches with the California Association of School Business Officials.
Thank you so much and to your staff for their hard work and efforts over the last three years to develop a multi-dimensional accountability system.
We understand that this initial phase of the evaluation rubrics will be pre-populated by the state and our request is that LEAs be given sufficient time to review and familiarize with the new setup and the new tool in order to ensure successful adoption and integration into generating the changes
strategies in their LCAP development.
We continue to support the state board's process to complete the web-based system developed in a manner that will lead to closing the achievements gap for all our students.
CASBO will continue to assist in the development of the standards for the local performance indicators and the data collection to ensure that the state creates a system that assists LEAs in assessing, analyzing, and modifying their LCAPs.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Rick Alanis, Jr.
I am the youth pastor, young adult pastor of the church San Bernardino.
I'm also a member of PICO California in the San Bernardino County or Inland Empire.
PICO California has 19 federations across the state of California.
We are multi-faith, multi-racial,
organization that strives to develop local leadership in our congregations, schools, and communities to work for racial, social, and economic justice.
Together we represent over 480 interfaith congregations and 450,000 families of diverse economic, racial, ethnic, and religious backgrounds rooted in our schools across the state of California.
Thank you for your time.
We're proud to represent the people of California here this morning.
If numbers 41 through 56 would please line up in the lobby.
My name is Carla Lizada Das.
I am a student in the city of San Bernardino and a board member with ICUCPICO.
PICO California would like to thank President Kirst
the State Board of Education and board staff for your hard work and commitment to the students of California.
We would also like to give special thanks to Board Member Bruce Holliday, Nicolasa Sandoval, and Eileen Strauss.
PICO California led the largest voter volunteer engagement effort in support of the passage of Prop 30 in the state, turning out 67,000 voters to support the passage of Prop 30.
Following its passage, PICO has participated in the effort to pass the local control funding formula.
to ensure that LCFF achieves the goal of creating improved outcomes for low-income students, English language learners, and foster youth.
As we speak, our federations are getting ready to launch our voter engagement work to pass Prop 55 to ensure we continue receiving LCF funding.
Finally, we just ask you to include a menu of evidence-based measures around parent involvement in the LCFF rubric to be adopted by October 2016.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Vernetta Woods, a mother of three and a PICO leader from Oakland, California.
I'm the president of the city site council at Fremont High School.
We want to thank the state board for listening to the students, parents, and advocates around the needs for multiple measures in the LCFF rubric.
I'm part of a team of parents who've been looking at a gap analysis focused on chronic absences, suspensions, and in relations to AG completions.
We saw that all the data was in the red.
Last night, we organized a meeting with parents and principals to go over the data and brainstorm solutions.
to support student success.
Time.
Parents suggested doing so we can make home visits to demonstrate that we care about our children.
Without multiple measures, we cannot create an effectiveness solution.
Thank you.
One minute of speaking time.
Go ahead.
This is a big group, and so they're each taking one minute.
Is that?
One minute for speakers.
OK, go ahead.
Good morning, State Board.
My name is Carlos Sanchez-Mata and I am a senior at Arroyo Valley High School in the City of San Bernardino Unified School District.
I've been involved with ICUC-PICO California for a year and a half.
As a student, working together with parents and other school board members helps me feel like our education system is moving ahead towards the right direction.
Since 2012, suspension rates have been reduced 50% in the course of four years.
It is evident that when parents and students are involved to improve school climate, clear positive change happens.
We ask you to include a menu of evidence-based measures around parent involvement
LCFF rubric to be adopted by October 2016.
Thank you.
We need an interpreter.
Excuse me, I'm about to destroy the room.
Good morning.
Good morning to all the supervisors.
My name is Maria Tapia, and I am a mother and a volunteer with Oco Pico.
I have four children that attend school in the District of Santa Ana, California.
We parents do not feel that we are respected when we bring up needs of our children at school.
We feel that we are not being listened to and that we are not welcome.
And when we do speak up, we feel reprisals from the workers at the schools and our children do as well.
I am coming here to specifically ask for the measures that are recommended by PICO to be adopted and be included in the plan, not only for training for the staff but also for the principals.
We're asking that you include in that menu regarding the parents being volunteers in that LCSF rubric.
And that this be adopted in, which is going to be adopted in October of 2016.
And we as parents are asking for a center for parents where we will be listened to and that the things that we request are listened to as well.
Thank you very much.
Good morning.
Thank you for listening to your parents.
My name is Maria Rosa Guzman and I'm here to ask you to include a menu in evidence-based and measure around parent engagement for all parents K-12 in each school district.
in the local control accountability plan rubric to be adopted by October 2016 and get us a knowledge how to work the education system
to work together to make a better decision for our students because not only School Site Council, DELAC PTA, SPAC has to make a decision for our students.
Each district and school had to engage party to close the student achievement gap.
Thank you so much.
Good morning.
My name is Gloria Rojas.
I attend Royal Valley High School as a sophomore right now.
I am currently a part of the UC PICO from San Bernardino.
In June 2015, PICO California, the California State PTA, Families in Schools, the Parent Organization Network, the Parent Teacher Home Visit Program conveyed a statewide meeting that included 17 parents slash community organizations.
The two districts engaged directly in schools and parent engagement metrics that the state could adopt and from which districts could choose from continuation assessments, accountabilities, and improvement.
We ask you to include a menu of the evidence-based measures around parent involvement in the LCFF rubric to be adopted by November 2016.
Hello, I'm Danielle Prince.
I am a member of Sacramento ACT, which is part of Pico, California.
As Pico, California, we continue to organize at the local and state level to close academic achievement gaps by supporting positive school climate and culture and well-being through engaging and powerful shared decision-making and collective action between parents, caregivers, students,
community members, and educators.
While we support the use of self-assessment tools, adopting locally developed self-assessment tools alone without including a menu of evidence-based measures will not ensure use of well-researched evidence-based data and will hinder the ability to compare experience across schools and districts that is needed to achieve continuous improvement.
We ask you to include a menu of evidence-based measures around parent involvement in the LCFF rubric to be adopted by November 2016.
Thank you.
Good morning, Sergio Luna with PICO California.
We believe that by adopting a menu of evidence-based measures from which schools and districts can choose from, along with an assessment test, as evidence for the standards that will provide the flexibility to schools and districts while maintaining high standards across the state with a focus on evidence-based practices, comparable data,
that informs continuous improvement and accountability in schools and districts across the state and the ability to correlate parent involvement to indicators in all state priority areas to ensure that we are creating an integrated statewide system to support student success.
We encourage the school, we encourage you members of the board to adopt the manual evidence-based rubrics that are going to be adopted in November 2016 that include parent engagement in school climate as key indicators as well.
Thank you very much.
Please come to the podium.
President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, Board of Education, pleasure to be here today.
It's good to be alive.
My name is Wes Smith.
I represent 18,000 educational leaders who want to thank you for your diligent work and that of the Department of Ed to develop a
a system that looks at continuous improvement, that highlights equity, that avoids summary judgments that tell our parents, our teachers, and our students absolutely nothing of significance, that looks at a discrete set of indicators that allow us to identify specific needs and then identify targeted intensive interventions to meet those needs.
Stay the course.
AXA is here to support you with the legislature, with the governor, and with the federal
Department of Education so that our plan can not only be realized in California but a model for students across America.
Thank you.
Good to see you, Wes.
Good morning, President Kurz, Superintendent Torlakson, and members of the board.
My name is Linda Kaminsky.
I'm superintendent of the Azusa Unified School District in Southern California.
I'm also the vice president for legislative action for AXA.
And I had two distinct honors in my life.
One was at Harvard.
I actually did my dissertation on status and change as a measure of student achievement.
So I had a long background in that statistically.
And then when I returned from Harvard, I was appointed to the technical design group.
as it developed the API.
I'm here today, first of all, to thank you for the work that you're doing, the thoughtful work that's gone into this, the opportunity to vet some of this and get stakeholder input has really been very helpful.
And I'm also here to talk to you about the upcoming academic indicator, particularly the growth aspects of it.
If we are continuing to follow the Alberta model, there is a challenge that we will be facing and that hopefully we can overcome.
I detailed that in a letter to you with some sample data that comes from statewide results to show how this plays out for us.
We are rightly very proud of ourselves in California for the API.
It was a beginning model of looking at growth, and it was not perfect, but it had certain advantages over the AYP under No Child Left Behind that we really prided ourselves on.
The AYP was a model that just looked at did you cross the proficiency bar, are you proficient or not, and set unreasonable targets for growth over time.
The model that is through Alberta, and if we adopt that model, will actually do the same thing.
It will pick a proficiency bar called met or exceeded standards, and it will look at growth over time.
Now, the growth targets are much more reasonable than No Child Left Behind, but the challenge in both of those models, in contrast to API, is that they only look at one point on the scale.
That is, are you over or under the bar?
API, however, actually looked at growth at all points on the scale.
This is important, particularly when you are talking about student achievement, because our challenge in California is how do we move kids from the lowest level to the next highest level, to the next highest level, until they are meeting or exceeding the standards.
But that is not part of that accountability model, the Alberta model.
It is like No Child Left Behind, only looking at did you meet or exceed the standards.
The letter that I sent you has a quick look at some of our statewide data, which shows two areas where we got a lot of growth last year.
One is kids who already met the standard and moved up to exceed the standard.
That's not captured in this kind of a model because they're already above the bar.
Also not captured are all the kids at the very lowest level who moved up one notch, who are now nearly meeting the standard but still not meeting the standard.
That also is not captured.
And that bottom growth, that is really essential for knowing how we're doing and particularly for the CCEE and for districts and schools to know where do I focus my energies.
And what we saw,
I hope you read the letter and I'd be happy to help out in any way.
Thank you.
Good morning President Kirsten, members of the board.
My name is Jason Nangle.
I'm Assistant Superintendent of Educational Services for the Coachella Valley Unified School District where we serve 96% unduplicated students.
I'm also here representing ACSA as President of the Curriculum, Instruction, and Accountability Council.
We appreciate the board's continuing commitment to utilize multiple measures in communicating school and district success and serving the very needs of students.
Districts are complex organizations, often managing hundreds of different programs in our ongoing efforts to meet all student needs.
Schools cannot be defined by a summative index any more than a single number could define the individual students they serve.
Measuring both status and change for each of the metrics is also much appreciated.
Schools and districts serving high-need students would be sunk if they were evaluated on status alone.
It is encouraging to see that growth is also recognized.
Likewise, high achieving schools and districts should not rest on their laurels, but should be incentivized to continue adding value to the educational experience of the students they serve.
The proposed matrices, such as this one here I'm holding up for the graduation rates, showing how schools and districts are doing in terms of status and change are fairly easy to comprehend and provide useful information to stakeholders.
However, trying to distill all metrics down to the top level display runs the danger of decreasing clarity and transparency.
We recommend that stakeholders be able to easily link to these matrices explaining the interplay of status and change resulting in a single color.
This past year, my district increased our graduation rate to 83.6%, the highest we've ever achieved.
This was a particular source of pride because it exceeded the state average of 82.3%.
However, in looking at the matrix for graduation rates, it appears that median rates are set at 85 to 90%.
So it seems counterintuitive that our graduation rate would be above average, yet still fall short of the median range.
So, my colleagues and I would like to recommend that the median range be set at 80 to 85 percent, and the high range be set at 85 to 90 percent, and very high be set at 90 percent or above.
My ex-colleagues also appreciate the thought the board has put into deciding where 11th grade CAS results should be placed in the multiple measures.
It is our belief that these test results should be placed with the academic measure of high schools, not in the college career indicator.
With that being said, we are pleased to see that these test results are not trumping all of the measures of college readiness, but are being considered as just one indicator.
We also feel that the CCI is heavily weighted with college readiness indicators and does not place enough value on career readiness indicators.
As the Board continues to seek and identify additional career readiness indicators, we would like to propose that for now, students would be considered prepared if they meet either a college-ready measure or a career-ready measure.
The as-yet-undefined well-prepared status could be defined as students that meet both college-ready measures and career-ready measures.
Finally, we understand there will be there may be adjustments made to the multiple measures in the future.
We just ask that these be kept to a minimum to keep the work manageable for practitioners such as myself who want to focus on educating kids not working full-time as statisticians and plan writers.
Okay, so accents school leaders across the state look forward to continued collaboration with the board to better serve our mutual students.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Dr. Laurel Ashlock, assistant superintendent from Central Unified School District and a member of the ACCCIA Council and CASCD board.
I would like to address three elements outlined in the system.
First, as mentioned earlier, the English learner progress measures are of concern.
Research tells us language acquisition between particular levels may not be a year's growth for a year's instruction, and this reality should be accounted for within the system.
Second, the proposed system appears to place emphasis on mastery of standards at a particular level, and we acknowledge the need for those mastery levels.
But we would like for growth at the lower levels of achievement to be recognized as well.
We do not want a repeat of a previous system in which growth was not recognized.
A technical provider came in only to affirm that action's being taken and the growth was occurring, yet the school district and the schools were marked as not achieving.
Third, we would like for the 11th grade SBAC to remain as an academic indicator and for the college career readiness indicator provide a more balanced reflection of readiness.
Readiness begins at the earliest levels and is contingent upon a broad course of study addressing the needs of the whole child.
Thank you.
Superintendent Torlakson, President Kirsten Board, I am Terry Rufert and I am a superintendent from Tulare County and it's one of the small schools and I would like to talk to you about a few things.
As Sue had asked some of our colleagues to look into how this would affect small schools, then I went out and kind of asked some questions of my colleagues.
I am just a superintendent, but I have colleagues that are superintendents, principals, bus drivers, teachers, all in one.
So I'm going to kind of touch on some of their issues and share some of their concerns, and I do appreciate you looking to that and asking us about that.
One is that for small schools, one or two kids can affect
the indicators where they're going to fall in that rubric either significantly positive or negative.
So I would like you to keep that in mind and one of our suggestions is you look over a three-year period instead of one or two years because it can affect greatly some small schools.
The other thing is that on the rubric itself and all the work that needs to be done, that we continue to remember that the focus is on implementation of the LCAP, not compliance.
And so we wanna keep it as simple as we can and be able to have them be able to focus on not just small schools, but large schools also.
But those are two of their concerns, is the capacity to be able to do all the things that may be asked.
And as things change over time, how they're gonna implement those.
including some of the small high schools with some of the career, college and career.
And so we highly suggest focusing on that and part of college and career.
The other thing is with the rubric itself, when we go out to all of our stakeholders and talk about it, our suggestion is that you, the front page, the very top sheet that they look at, that it gives a good picture of what that school, that district looks like.
So they don't have to keep drilling down and drilling down and drilling down to find the information.
It makes it look like we are being very transparent and not trying to hide anything.
So the suggestion is to keep the colors simple, not do a third, half, fourth.
Just keep the colors, have all the different subgroups on that top page with the colors.
And then if people want more information, they can drill down.
But that would give a very clear picture of what we're looking at.
And I think it wouldn't only be good for small schools, but also for big schools.
Just like we do at the LCAP, we have a one-page snapshot of what our LCAP is to share with everybody, so it's much easier.
And I know for my school district and those around, it really does promote that we are being transparent because it's easier to read instead of trying to think that we are reading something else into it.
I thank you for the work that you've done.
I know it's not an easy task, and I know there's a lot of work that needs to go into it.
So as we're subtracting and adding, and I'm glad that it's a living document,
adding, subtracting, please keep that in mind, that give us some time to implement that.
Okay, thank you very much.
Good morning, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, representing the California Association for Bilingual Education.
When I first saw this chart, I was a bit alarmed, but now I understand.
I understand it.
So, the combining of the two cohorts, I think, is appropriate in measuring the English language proficiency, but would not recommend combining the cohorts to measure status or change for the other indicators, such as math or English language arts.
My second comment is with respect to priority three, parent engagement, and priority six, school climate, in attachment three on page four, please require that translations be provided of the specified documents for parents because that's not specifically stated in those two priority areas.
As you know, the lack of translations of documents has been the number one complaint of parents in trying to become meaningfully
engaged and participate in the LCAP process.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Glenn Kenyon.
I am a math content specialist at San Francisco Unified, but I'm here today as a fellow of the English Learner Leadership and Legacy Institute, a project with California, California Together in collaboration with CABE.
The Institute is developing a new generation of leaders to sustain the movement for educational equity and excellence for English learners.
I support the development of an English learner proficiency metric that is a composite of several indicators.
I want this composite to include English proficiency as well as reclassification rates for all EL students, including long-term English learners.
Such a composite will paint a more accurate picture of how English learners are truly progressing over time.
I recommend that the state utilize the CELT data from 2016-17 for the 17-18 year and then use the LPAC status data for the 2018-19 year and as board member Strauss noted this will ensure that the state board will include EL proficiency data for until the adoption of a fully revised metric.
Thank you.
Shelley Spiegel Coleman from Californians Together, and just like all of you who are teachers are proud of your students, I'm so proud of having one of our fellows here with us and over the next year we're hoping that you'll meet all 18 of our fellows who will be the next generation of English learner leaders and advocates.
And so that took a part of my time, but I'm so proud of having these folks working with us.
One, we'd like to echo what Board Member Ortiz talked about, about the labeling of the column on equity.
We think that's essential.
The other piece is that I know there's an issue on how we're going to look at the cohort of English learners across indicators, but we need to maintain the group of English learners without the redesignated students for certain indicators to not mask where they presently are in our system.
And lastly, on the statement of model practices, I'm hoping, and we would love to work with you on it, that some of those statements of model practices are specific for the unduplicated students, because as shown by Nancy, if we look at some of the indicators, and they're orange, and then they're look at statements, they need to be specific to those groups.
So we hope that those model practices will be specific, and we'd love to work with you on it.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, and board members.
My name is Mary Lee and I'm a parent advocate in the Los Angeles Unified School District.
I'm here to speak to you on behalf of parents in regards to the parent engagement piece.
As part of this new accountability system, the parent engagement standard should ensure parent involvement that's meaningful, relevant, and engaging.
And what we find is that the Parent Involvement Indicator really needs, in order to do this, a menu of evidence-based measures that will give consistent, comparable data across the state so that we can hold accountable the districts across the state in terms of engaging parents adequately, and also to allow for the local level to be able to see the progress that they are making.
So, we do urge you to include a menu of evidence-based measures for comparable data.
Hello.
My name is Sandy Mendoza.
I'm with Families and Schools, and I wanted to congratulate you all because I think that the process that we've been working under has been very strenuous, sometimes strained.
I know in the press it might have looked like that, but I think conflict
is good because it puts the conversation out there in a transparent way.
And it also involves multiple stakeholders, which I don't think we've seen in a long time.
And because of this process that you've been promoting, I think we're starting to see that happen.
Change is constant, and change is not going to eliminate what we're seeing today.
So I hope that we're going to be good at doing this even further down the line.
And I also want to thank, and I'm using this time to do this, but I think it's worth it to thank people like Dave and Nancy and all the others
that have really worked hard to reach out to all of us, often taking a lot of time, being very, very patient to answer our questions, and then call back again and say, now, can you explain that again?
Because we're still confused.
Not that they didn't do a good job.
It's just that it is a complex process.
But I do want to say that we are supportive of the multidimensional metrics for parent engagement.
We hope that you'll adopt that, because we want to see
consistent indicators at the local level that parents and districts will refer to.
And just one last thing that we hope that you'll put a parent voice on the on the work group on the school climate and engagement because I think we don't have a local parent voice on that group.
Thank you so much.
And again parents everywhere if you're here in the building say hello.
Honorary members of the School Board of Education.
My name is Maria Rosales, and I will try in English.
Okay, my name is Maria Rosales, and I am a mother leader of three, and I represent a parent organization network, and we would like to thank you for your commitment
to work with parent and student groups and civil rights advocates to ensure that parent involvement and the school climate are prioritized in a multiple measure system for the local contract formula.
We know that the parent involvement is not an area where data has been collected systematically across the school and that there is wide variance of the practices used
and their effectiveness and engaging parents.
For this reason, we believe that providing a menu of evidence-based measures from which a district can choose is necessary to support them in tracking their progress moving forward.
Adopting a menu of evidence-based measure from which districts can choose, also using our self-assessment is necessary.
We look forward to continue to working with you to ensure that a strong measure of evidence are adopted in November.
Thank you.
Okay, we're going to take this last witness and then you come forward because you were the prior group and then we have Assemblywoman.
She's speaking after this person.
Yes, okay.
Good morning, Dr. Kirst, members of the board, Superintendent Torlakson, my name is Barbara Dinko, I'm a school psychologist and I represent California Association of School Psychologists.
California Association of School Psychologists wishes to thank the CDE for adding the California Healthy Kids Survey to the list of tools that LEAs may use to survey and guide improvements in important school climate factors that promote student resiliency and mitigate risk behaviors and that measure protective factors in school connectedness.
We encourage the board to adopt performance standards that also reflect school and community input, in addition to the student data.
In particular, we suggest California Healthy Kids Survey, two partner surveys, the California School Climate Survey that is completed by teachers and staff, and the California School Parents Survey.
These factors are important to school psychologists in the context of school, home, and community environments.
We are, as school psychologists, able to contribute to the development, selection, implementation, and evaluation of programs and services that lead to important outcomes related to students' social, emotional, and behavioral competence.
Thank you.
Okay, I'd like to- We have Assemblymember Weber with us this morning, and she's going to speak next.
Yes, Assemblyman, woman, Shirley Weber from San Diego.
Thank you for coming and we look forward to hearing from you.
My pleasure.
Good morning, President Kerse and Superintendent Torlakson and board members.
My name is Dr. Shirley Weber.
I'm the Assemblywoman from the 79th District in San Diego.
In 2013, I joined my colleagues of the California Legislative Black Caucus to work to pass the Local Control Funding Formula, LCFF, with the hope that local decision-making would provide a more comprehensive approach to improving student outcomes.
Since then, I've been engaged to uphold the promise of that policy to boost student success, especially for our most vulnerable and disadvantaged students.
The gravity of this is underscored by the state's recent release of the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium test.
While overall student achievement has improved, urgent needs remain.
Clearly the achievement gap remains stagnant, we're the second worst in the country according to the LAO, and in some cases is widening on the state's assessment test.
But taking the assessment test taken this spring, despite the millions or billions, I should say, of dollars that the state has invested in supplemental and concentration funding to specifically target these students.
In English language arts, fewer than half of Latino students and fewer than one in three African American students are meeting or exceeding standards.
While in math, fewer than one in four African American and Latino students meet this benchmark.
This isn't just about poverty, because overall in the state math test results, low-income white students are performing slightly better than non-low-income African-American students.
There are schools and districts where students are doing well, where gaps are significantly narrowing or nonexistent.
We need a comprehensive data dashboard to easily be able to compare data across schools and districts to identify their successes and then, through collaboration and support, help other schools and districts with similar types of progress.
Implementing an effective accountability system is one of, if not the most important element to ensure that LCFF actually meets the needs of students.
And some of you may remember that when we fought for LCFF, it was assured to us that there would be an effective accountability system, because simply returning monies to schools without an effective system would be dangerous.
I have been gravely concerned about the direction of the state board in heading with respect to accountability.
And for that reason, I authored this past year AB 2548.
And that concern was carried forth through the legislature, which has unanimously, in bipartisan support, sent the bill AB 2548 to the governor's desk this last week.
I appreciate the colossal task that this board has engaged in for over the last three years to implement LCFF, including the work to create a new accountability system.
I know it has not been easy.
I was especially pleased in May when the board member, with Mrs. Burr's motion, made a shift from a narrowly defined set of measures to a more holistic, multiple measure approach outlined in my bill.
That said, I believe that the action you have before you today, again, needs a mid-course correction to get back on the right track of heading toward a single integrated accountability system.
In the state's draft regulations, the board is being asked to adopt a framework for an accountability system that ignores key equity guardrails contained in ESSA.
I see major deficiencies in these regulations in at least three major areas.
One, how the standards are being set.
Closing the gap in achievement should be the core of this system.
The state board should set specific improvement standards that require greater improvement for students that are farthest behind.
To continue to have the same goal for all students would obviously continue to keep those students or keep the gap growing and not help them catch up, which was the intent of LCFF.
Two, that the academic indicators are elevated, how they're elevated.
The legislature strongly supports multiple measures, which is one of the reasons I introduced 2548.
The bill expanded the indicators far beyond those initially proposed by this board in January and March, and now mirrors the board's May action.
even recognizing that some progress has occurred regarding multiple measures.
I do believe that the accountability system needs to significantly focus on academic achievement, academic growth, and closing the achievement gap, which is found in AB 2548.
It is critical that we highlight access to opportunities and provide proper school environment that will help students thrive.
At the same time, we cannot lose sight of the fact that it is the knowledge and skills students develop that will set the trajectory for their lives once they leave school and transition into society.
If a school is not succeeding in at least one academic measure for all of its subgroups, the school should be identified for support and assistance.
By no means should this be a shame, punish, and takeover strategy that was sometimes recommended in No Child Left Behind, but rather the constructive technical assistance we all envision in moving forward LCFF.
The third thing is how schools and districts are meaningfully differentiated.
Using multiple measures is the right way to go in our accountability system, but at the end of the day, the taxpayers, parents, and policymakers have a right to know when schools and districts are fundamentally struggling and ensure something is being done about it.
Achieving this doesn't have to be reduced to a single number, but it does have to be crystal clear.
I know that it will be discussed more when the state adopts its ESSA plan, but for now, it is critical for the board to ensure that the multiple measures it includes in the online evaluation rubric actually are transparent and accessible, including allowing for easy comparison across schools, districts, and subgroups, and have a click-through access to greater data details, as AB 2548 calls for, and not just a simple summary report of two or how a school is doing.
Without these critical adjustments, it appears that the board will place California on a path of two disjointed systems.
A state system that demonstrates little regards for federal law, as well as one that will need to meet the federal statutory requirements.
This bifurcation will likely confuse district administrators, educators, and the public.
The governor's legacy of LCFF education reform and the success they promised for our students is very much at stake here.
The state board must reconcile the differences between state and federal accountability requirements and align them into one cohesive and straightforward system so that locals can implement it consistently and effectively to support educational improvement so that the public knows what to expect.
We have achieved this by integrating the best of LCFF, but not by the wholesale disregard for federal law.
As you know, AB 2548 has been sent to the governor, and as I pointed out, with bipartisan support and unanimous support in the Senate and the Assembly.
And in addition to that support, over 350 organizations and groups have called for its signature.
This includes business, civil rights, and community leaders across the state.
Even when my local paper, the City Union Tribune, which is sometimes been seen as the conservative paper, says that Weber has done her job, now it's time for the governor to do his, which is to sign AB 2548.
I hope the governor will sign this legislation and that simultaneously the board will make the necessary policy adjustments to integrate the key provisions that are outlined in the bill into California's new accountability system.
Lastly, I want to thank Dr. Kurz.
I want to understand what Dr. Kurz said earlier today, that is, the intent that suspension would only be used as an indicator for one year, and then the plan is to substitute it by including chronic absences.
AB 2548 and the legislature has weighed in our desire to specifically include chronic absences, which is a student engagement measure, and school climate, which includes suspensions.
We would be very troubled, the legislature would, for any efforts to remove suspensions in the future from the reporting.
That becomes important in terms of determining the climate of a school and how well students are being received.
Thank you this morning for allowing me to make these comments and words to you.
AB 2548 is on the governor's desk.
We are lobbying very hard and so are the organizations to have it passed.
I want this board to understand that it does align with many of your goals and objectives in terms of what you want to do.
It gives a structure and focus.
The legislature is very serious about the fact that they wanted to weigh in on it to provide the kind of guidance for the state board and the work that you're doing.
We hope once it is signed that we will be able to work together to make sure that we have a system that is one system, that is transparent, that really gives us the information we need to help schools to be successful for our children.
So once again, thank you for the opportunity to address you today.
Take care.
Thank you very much, Superintendent and Board, for your time.
I realize how busy the day is.
Hello, I'm Deacon John Wilson.
I'm the Education and Enrichment Director for West Angeles Church.
We run a community-based program for education of students from kindergarten all the way through college.
We're doing some intervention and doing things with over 700 lower and middle class families in Los Angeles and surrounding areas.
This means everything from helping parents with student issues of even selecting preschools and kindergartens and schools, all the way up to providing affordable college alternatives to eliminate these high loans and things students have.
Each year, over 100 families with over 220 children, I might add that this year we're way ahead of this pace, and I think you'll see the reason why in my comments.
Each year, over 100 families with over 220 children
ask us for advice on how to pick schools.
Previously, we've used a combination of factors, but mainly the API score, which is no longer available to us, and we realize that you're carefully considering what other information will be available in the area of school choice, and it's very essential that you actually do that, as was referenced by the Assemblywoman.
Yes, the API system was limited, but it was the only way for us to think about
how to help our parents.
However, we are now here to ask that you approve a new system that will provide families that have varying educational needs, a way of deciding which school is best for their students.
This is an issue of family educational values that as a responsible community educational leader, I can't really ignore that.
when they come and they're trying to find alternatives for their youth.
This is a request that will help to improve the performance of students in those targeted, underserved areas that you mentioned earlier today.
And we see them all in the inner city.
I know we focused today on two groups, but there are probably four different groups of students that we're deeply concerned about.
So I wanna really thank you for your time and considering this free choice of school issue, that's very, very important to us.
Good morning members of the board.
My name is Jose Godinez, father of three.
My daughter is in UC Davis.
My second child is in high school and the youngest is in elementary.
We're here with families that have traveled over 10 hours.
Personally, I took this day off so I could be here with you because we are interested in education.
We support the multiple measures that you are taking.
So that we have a rubric to identify the conditions of each school.
But this colored rubric gives us a confusing, a slightly confusing idea
We would like to see this rubric as an indicator for families to know exactly what is the status of the school.
And this would allow parents like me to become more involved in the education of our children and to know that we can give them a good education.
California has the opportunity of witnessing this change thanks to you.
We are convinced that you will take the steps necessary and you will give the due importance to our request.
I want to underscore that we want to see this rubric as a system of added grading.
Thank you.
Good morning members of the board.
My name is Karina Payne and I'm a mother of two boys in the Los Angeles Watts area.
Both of my sons have their own individual challenges when it comes to learning and I've had to be actively involved with their schools to get the support that they need.
So when I heard that there was a meeting to discuss school accountability
I had to come and represent for my family, other families in my community that share my same perspective.
As parents, we're thankful that you're including multi-measure, I mean, excuse me, we're glad that you're including measures to evaluate school quality.
As I prepare to explore different school options for middle school for my son, I'm going to look at the college readiness
indicator and focus on how strong the English and math preparation is at that school.
Parents like us want to also see an overall rating because it gives us a different perspective of the school.
We need and deserve to have access to clear information.
So please consider giving us both a multi-measured dashboard and an overall rating that we can make the best choices for our kids.
Thank you.
Good morning, members of the board.
My name is Alexandra Menjivar-Shamberger, and I have two kids currently at Wadsworth Elementary School in South LA.
I have taken an overnight bus to come here today with my kids because my main concern is the new dashboard.
Multiple measures are good because it gives parents like me more information, but when I look at it, it doesn't tell me how my school is doing overall.
what it's being proposed, it's not clear for us.
This worries us because at Wadsworth, every year we graduate fifth graders and many of them are not ready for middle school.
Parents like me want to work with teachers and staff to lift our school for our community.
To make this happen, we need clear information because it's our main tool to ask questions, hold school accountable, and get parents involved.
I am here today to ask the board to give us access to clear multiple measures and overall ratings and so that we can make the best decisions for our kids, our schools, and our communities.
Parents need to know how schools are doing.
Thank you very much.
Good morning.
My name is Dr. Carol Hedgepeth.
I am the Director of Research and Policy at Innovate Public Schools.
We believe every child deserves a world-class public education, and we work to empower parents, educators, and community leaders to make this a reality.
I'm also the mother of three girls attending traditional district public schools, and I see some schools in my community that are doing very well, and others that aren't.
As a parent, I think it's important to learn from what works,
and to hold schools accountable when things aren't.
In my experience, parents are moved to actively work to improve schools when we have clear and easy to understand data about how schools are doing.
Providing such data is part of Innovate's mission, and so I'm here to help.
The accountability measures that are being considered here are not clear, not accessible, and not aligned with strong accountability for academic outcomes.
Even with my two advanced degrees and years of experience with data, I find it difficult to make sense of the draft reports and prototypes that I've seen, and I don't think that I'm alone.
On behalf of Innovate and the thousands of voters that we work with, we ask that you opt for creating accountability tools that are clear and easy to use for parents and the community to advocate for high quality equitable education for all students.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Lori Ben.
I am here representing my husband and I's seven children that have attended Pasadena Unified School District schools.
I'm here to request and hope that you will oblige this request to allow us to have an overall summative report per school along with the multiple measure dashboard that is being proposed.
With all of our seven children, you can imagine that they were in different grades at different times.
And within the Pasadena Unified School District, you have high schools and then you have some schools that are elementary only.
And so I have used, in the past, the overall summative report.
However,
I love that you're including the dashboard because now it gives me an opportunity to decide, you know, what the strengths are, what the weaknesses are within the schools.
But I'm asking and petitioning that we include the overall summative rating system as well.
It gives, it would give me an idea of what school I would like to look at or what schools I would like to look at at the top.
And then with the
With the dashboard, I can look at the different situations that are within the school that are listed in the dashboard to see what strengths might meet my family's needs and to see what weaknesses there are.
Maybe my child is in one of the schools where there are weaknesses.
And my husband and I have been great proponents of helping our schools with those weaknesses as much as we possibly can.
And so I thank you for your consideration.
I would also like to add that we have over 500 parents, students, and community members that have signed petitions in support of inclusion of the overall summative into the dashboard.
Thank you for your time.
Buenos dias miembros de la mesa directiva.
Mi nombre es Angelita Godinez.
Good morning members of the board.
My name is Angelita Godinez.
Y vengo de parte de la red de empoderamiento de padres.
And I am here on behalf of the network of empowering parents.
Representando a las familias del valle de San Fernando.
In representation of the families of the San Fernando Valley.
I took a day off from work because I care about the education of my children and that of my community.
I am active.
I'm an active parent in the committees for all the schools of my children.
And I am here to fight for the improvement of the educational system for all children.
We would like to see more and clearer measures and we need more information that is easy to understand for the parents.
The current dashboard is confusing.
I want to see a dashboard with multiple measurements that are clearer.
and a summative grading system that allows me to evaluate and compare schools and as a parent make the best decision.
Because I believe that our children deserve a high quality education with great expectations.
Gracias.
Thank you.
Buenos dias.
Good morning.
My name is Fidelia Muralles.
I have come in from Los Angeles in South Central.
I have a son in sixth grade.
Thank you for all the work you're doing.
But we would like a clear and specific dashboard for each parent.
something that we can all understand and that possibly has been itemized for each school so that we as parents can make the best decisions for our children.
We left LA by bus yesterday.
We left our jobs because we are very interested in the education of our children.
And those who could not make it have sent their signatures, over 500 of them, requesting a clear measuring tool that all parents can read.
We're interested in our children's education and that's why we are here.
Thank you very much.
Hello, my name is Brenda Contreras.
I'm a third year student at Sacramento State University, and I'm also a member of Students for Education Reform.
I graduated from Richmond High School, one of the lowest performing school districts from the WCCUSD school district, one of the lowest performing districts in California.
And I'm here to speak on the California School Accountability System and Multiple Measure Dashboard proposal.
This proposal is too complex for regular citizens and family members to understand.
And although multiple indicator system is more likely to help in identifying where the problems lay, it is not better than a single indicator if it's just numbers and colored boxes.
Thus making it harder to close the achievement gap and holding our schools accountable for serving every student in California with a fair and quality education.
Please stand with students and families and consider a clearer school rating system that includes an overall assessment of school quality in addition to the currently proposed multiple measure.
Thank you.
Hello, good morning members of the State Board.
My name is Raquel Antolin and I am the California Program Coordinator for Students for Education Reform.
I'm also an alumni of the West Contra Costa Unified School District and a recent graduate from Sacramento State University.
At SFER and we believe that every child deserves and should receive a quality K through 12 education regardless of their background and socioeconomic status.
We also believe that every parent has a choice and a powerful voice which the system needs to listen to and comprehend.
I come from a failing district and due to great support from programs and resources I was able to navigate that broken system and make it into higher education.
But many of our students do not have that privilege and or support.
Therefore they deserve to be provided.
And after seeing such a current proposed system I was shocked.
So please listen to us.
Thank you.
If number 64 through 80 could please line up.
Good morning members of the state board.
My name is Daniela Ramirez and I am part of Students for Education Forum.
I am an alumni from West Contra Costa Unified School District and I am now currently attending UC Davis as my second year.
I am a dedicated advocate to better our schools and our education system in my community and California as a whole.
I was fortunate to attend Leadership Public High School in Richmond, which is known to be a top school in California.
However, when I graduated from high school, I rekindled my friendships with
past friends who did not have the ability to go to LPS, instead they went to Richmond High, which is a traditional public school in my community, and I realized that they did not have the same opportunities that I did.
They didn't have the same supports or resources.
Most of my friends didn't even know how to apply to college and had no guidance.
on how to do it.
Some friends told me that they tried applying to college on their own and calling universities for hours.
Please, I urge you to set up.
We need transparency in our parents and students and teachers deserve a summative multiple measure.
Good morning.
I'm Sung Bae with the Stanford Center for Opportunity Policy and Education.
We commend the board and the CDE for your hard work on developing a college and career readiness indicator and engaging diverse sets of voices and perspectives in this effort.
We also appreciate the board and CDE's commitment to continually improve the CCI over time, and in particular, to develop more robust measures of career readiness, which could include indicators that demonstrate authentic performances
such as completing a portfolio or capstone project or participating in a career technical student organization competition, as well as indicators of authentic experiences such as internships, work-based learning, and service learning experiences.
Finally, we urge the board to convene a working group to further develop these career measures.
Thank you for your time.
Good morning.
My name is Joy Wake and I'm joined by my colleagues representing the San Juan Unified School District High School Parent Engagement Group.
First of all, thank you for recognizing the need for parents to have a usable and understandable way to compare schools.
While the dashboard is impressive because it gives more data, we ask that you also provide something that is simpler for parents to use and clearly measures student success overall.
Please provide a summary rating that compiles and compares three things.
One, demonstrated student success.
Two, opportunities for student success.
And three, support for student success.
Thank you very much.
If we could make sure that number 64 through 80 are lined up.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Celia Jaffe from California State PTA.
I'm speaking specifically today about the removal of 11th grade assessments from the academic indicator.
Perhaps in the focus on a robust construction of the college career indicator, people did not fully explore the ramifications of removing 11th grade standardized assessments from the academic indicator.
If this stays in place, high schools and districts that are high school only will have no objective standard measure of student academic performance because graduation requirements vary by school district, EL reclassifications and other metrics don't apply to all students in that grade.
This high-quality, smarter, balanced assessment that we've made so much of will be taken by an entire 11th grade, but the only bearing the results will have on the school's accountability report will be as a kind of met, not met thing for the portion of students who don't qualify by other measures as college or career ready.
Please make use of the assessment results in the academic indicator.
Thank you.
Good morning, Patty Scripter, California State PTA.
Appreciate the work done to date and want to comment on some of the things that were said this morning.
We appreciate Dr. Kirst's comment on the need and commitment to a broader base of information for accountability.
For Member Burr, who talked about the so what, if we're doing more than operationalizing a statute, the so what is what matters to parents for accountability, so we appreciate that recognition.
We always appreciate member Ortiz-Rincon keeping that equity up there, and especially member Strauss for recognizing that a broad course of study is more than talking about high school.
Commitment to access to a full curriculum is core to what PTA believes the arts are critical for students, so we really appreciate that recognition.
And last, on the family engagement local indicator, met not met is not acceptable.
Looking to see if a light switch are on or off doesn't tell us if the room's well lit, if it's poorly lit, or if the bulb is burned out.
We need a better standard than that.
We need more levels.
It doesn't ask the districts to do real self-assessment and it doesn't meet the model of continuous improvement and a multidimensional assessment is called for in the statute.
We look forward to working with you on that.
Thank you.
Good morning, I'm Estelle Lemieux with the California Teachers Association.
On behalf of the California Teachers Association, I want to thank and commend the board, the department, and the staff for making such significant progress on this monumental project and for continuing to engage stakeholders throughout the process.
While important work remains, the initial evaluation rubrics before you should provide a foundation for a truly holistic accountability system that incorporates whole child and whole system factors and supports equity of access, opportunity, and outcomes for all of our students in California.
CTA strongly supports the board's overarching commitment to establishing a single integrated local, state, and federal accountability system that has the LCAP at its core and identifies specific strengths and weaknesses through a clear multiple measures dashboard.
CTA also strongly supports the staff recommendation to complete further development
on the college and career indicator, including student course taking information and options to measure access to an enrollment in a broad course of study as a state indicator for the next phase of the rubrics.
Looking forward, CTA respectfully asked the board to clarify and confirm that a comprehensive statewide survey of school climate and conditions of learning will be developed and implemented as soon as possible.
A rigorous, comprehensive, and annual assessment of climate and conditions of learning is a critical component of California's new holistic accountability system.
It must be developed in a manner that allows it to serve as a state indicator
In the meantime, it is important that the interim survey be administered annually to ensure alignment with other standards, indicators, and the LCAP annual update goal-setting and review process.
Finally, we urge the Board to clarify how LEAs select local indicators or measures and how stakeholders will be consulted and involved in the critical process.
CTA thanks you, thanks the board, everyone involved here for its consideration and looks forward to continuing to work together on this very historic California's accountability system.
Thank you so much.
Speakers 81 through 88 would please line up.
Good morning President Kirsten, members of the State Board, John Affelt from Public Advocates.
I too want to commend the Board on the direction it's taking and express our support for moving forward on a comprehensive multiple measure system.
We're supportive of the board not unduly limiting itself to a narrow set of academic indicators set forth in the federal regulations, but continuing to try to implement a holistic multiple measure system that pays attention to all of the state's priorities.
including parent engagement, including school climate, including standards implementation, including access to a broad course of study.
Because we know those are part of what make comprehensive education possible.
It's also important that in doing so you're not limiting intervention and technical assistance and support to simply a narrow set of academic test score indicators, but also to all of those measures, parent engagement, broad course of access, standards implementation, because those are worthy of attention too.
Our support should certainly be understood as contingent on the ultimate question of it's gotta work, right?
And this system is, we're not gonna NCLB our way out of underperformance by labeling all schools failures and imposing state required interventions.
And the promise of this system is that that big yellow in the middle and many of those oranges
are going to self-reflect and voluntarily see their weaknesses across the dimensions and improve without state assistance.
So we support that intention and really want to see that that piece of it works.
In line with that, we also want to note that we think a specific recommendation that you should direct the staff for the November framework to come back with at least one more tier of intervention in year one.
We know in year one, it's not enough that everyone just get a letter saying, here are your strengths and weaknesses, which is the proposal.
We want to see another tier of intervention that says,
You're failing on everything.
We know now.
We don't need to just send you a letter.
We should be doing stuff in year one, providing technical assistance and support.
So we would request that you give that additional direction to staff for the November framework.
And lastly, we support the notion of an integrated
because this is not like NCOB where API and EYP both applied to schools and gave conflicting messages.
You've got a system for schools with largely federal decision rules and a system for LEAs with largely LCFF decision rules, and they can fit together.
Thank you very much.
Hello, my name is Francisco Cortez.
I am a junior in the San Jose region, and I've been involved with California for Justice for the past two years now.
So we're here to thank you for including recommendations from students in the LCFF rubric, and we urge you to keep them in the final version as approved today.
Specifically, we are pleased to see an equity report in the rubric's top-level display of school climate and student engagement measures as state indicators, as well as college and career readiness and English learning proficiency.
So we're also happy with the progress that the state board has created like the school conditions and climate work group and including a CFJ representative and that you're getting feedback from students and parents on the display of the rubric so it can be accessible and community friendly.
It means a lot to me having you all listen to our recommendations because every decision being made here impacts the students the most.
So listening to what we have to say it's a huge step in the right direction.
Thank you.
If numbers 89 to 104 would please line up in the boardroom.
Nancy, we're going to break at 12, so.
Never mind.
Okay.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Michelle Cantar, and I'm a 10th grader in San Jose and a leader with Californians for Justice.
And I've also been involved in my district LCAP process throughout the year.
As my teachers say, there's always room for improvement, so I want to point out a few of them in the LCFF rubric.
We join with CTA, public advocates, ACLU, and the Riverside COE to request the commitment from the state board to create state indicator placeholders for course access and the recommendations that come from school conditions and climate work group.
There are also a number of issues raised by the LCFF equity coalition that we hope you'll address.
Overall, we're all really pleased with how far our state has come on the LCFF rubrics.
We especially appreciate the time and consideration you've given to student voices.
While being involved in Californians for Justice, I have learned what it means to be a student leader in my community.
And I hope that together we can continue to engage more students to be empowered in their education.
Thank you.
Right, okay, it's 12 o'clock, and I think what we need to do is have the board, we'll recess till 12.15, you get your lunch, bring it back, and we'll eat it here.
So 15 minute, we have the lunches there.
Okay, and then we'll start with number 80 when we- Yeah, whatever, who's ever first comes.
Yeah.
you
80 through 96 will please line up.
I thought it was wise to wait till after you had your lunch.
Good afternoon, LeAngela Reed on behalf of KROP, the Association of Career and College Readiness Organizations and the Small School Districts Association.
On behalf of KROP, I just wanna thank the board and the staff for the tremendous work on the college and career indicator.
We've come such a long way in recognizing the value of
of both types of programs and KROP has made a kind of a revised version of the CCI we've shared with staff and we look forward to continuing to work with them on the inclusion of more points of readiness and getting to the end, truly getting to the end.
On behalf of the Smalls, we want to thank you for recognizing their unique situation, the limitations that can sometimes be placed on them relative to size or geography, geographical location.
also with regard to access to both higher ed and to employment or career development.
So I want to say thank you very much.
Good afternoon.
I'm Doug McRae, a retired test publisher from Monterey.
I'd like to make three quick points.
First, there's been time slippage on the performance standards for several state indicators, most notably the academic indicators and the change aspect of other indicators.
Also, no simulation data to support approval of the attachment form material.
Second, there's widespread problems with data quality for the metrics needed to fulfill that multiple measures infrastructure.
And third, indication that metrics will evolve and improve in the future runs contrary to the real world truism.
That quote, if you want to measure change, then don't change the measure.
That tension needs to be managed.
A reasonable conclusion is that despite current statutory dates, the metrics needed for a new California multiple measures accountability system will not be ready for baseline status measures until spring 18 and spring 19, first year for change.
That's the reality for a valid and credible new state assessment system.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, my name is Christine Chu and I'm a third grade elementary teacher in the Los Angeles Unified School District and Teach Plus Policy Fellow.
While I agree with ESSA's new focus on multiple indicators and support for underserved populations, I do believe that there is still work that's needed to be done in the transparency and accessibility of the state report card.
The public needs a clear way to understand and differentiate the performance of schools.
Even through my lens as an educator, teacher leader and education policy fellow I still find it confusing to interpret particularly the equity report.
A composite rating and multiple measures do not have to be mutually exclusive and without a composite rating it will be difficult to differentiate the performance between schools.
The incorporation of both would be helpful to increase the accessibility and transparency of the state report card.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Thank you for giving me the opportunity to speak today.
My name is Faiza Makhani and I teach U.S.
History for LAUSD at Paul Revere Charter Middle School.
I'm currently a Teach Plus Policy Fellow.
The new state accountability proposal has some great aspects to it, but I wanted to propose some recommendations you may already be considering.
I urge the board to adopt a very clear reporting system that has numerical values attached to the color coding.
As an educator, I need to know exactly where my school stands and how much, whether it's based on points or percentages, I need to improve to meet or go above the expectations.
I also recommend the board to adopt an overall composite score so that there is a way to differentiate schools and a clear basis to identify struggling schools.
It becomes a matter of equity to quickly and efficiently identify schools that need intervention and immediate support.
A composite score and multiple measures do not have to be mutually exclusive.
The composite score can be a weighted average of the multiple indicators with an emphasis on student growth and achievement.
Thank you once again.
Hi, my name is Chris Hoffman and I'm a fourth grade teacher in East Los Angeles and an alumnus of the Teach Plus Policy Fellowship as well.
I could not be more excited to be here today on a day that the board votes to adopt the evaluation rubrics, a system that really honors the multiple dimensions that we value in a school.
As we adopt these evaluation rubrics, I ask the board to be both bold and aspirational in designing the systems of intervention and support.
As a classroom teacher at the beginning of each school year, I often feel overwhelmed by the task of me and the needs of all my students.
And sometimes I feel like I don't have the capacity to give each student what he or she needs to be successful.
But like countless other teachers, I keep trying.
I try my best to identify the supports my students need and to put those systems and supports into action.
Our state system needs to be based on the same principles of equity.
Let's not let concerns about our capacity to provide supports lead us to minimize the number of schools identified for support.
Focusing on the lowest 5% of schools is not enough, as ESSA requires.
Please ensure that all students get the help they need by making sure that all schools get the help they need.
Thank you.
Hi, Brian Lee on behalf of Mission Readiness, Ready Nation, and Fight Crime Invest in Kids.
A couple quick points, we're very excited about your adoption of a multiple measure accountability system, especially about including suspension rates.
And we look forward to the addition of school climate surveys, which is planned.
We're relieved by the clarification that school climate surveys are in for the, excuse me, that suspension rates are in for the foreseeable future, which is really important given the compelling research and the many and powerful voices you've heard about the need for that in the system.
On college and career readiness, we're excited that we have a system that recognizes both college and career readiness.
We appreciate what Board Member Strauss talking about problems with the 11th grade EAP.
CSU says level three conditionally ready alone is not enough to avoid remediation.
So this system should not say that it's enough.
And finally, you've heard from others, there should be a work group on college and career readiness as CDE staff mentioned at the July board meeting, but it's not in the materials now.
Thank you.
Hi, good afternoon.
Naina Gupta, staff attorney with the ACLU of California and member of the Equity Coalition.
First, I just want to commend the board for following through on an accountability system that looks at multiple meaningful measures of a student's education experience, one that honors the complex and intractable challenges facing especially our low-income students of color.
But if there's anything that we've learned these past two years, it's that a system that on paper honors our high-need students doesn't necessarily translate to better services for those high-need students.
We've been disappointed to see too many districts failing to use LCFF dollars to increase and improve services for low-income students of color, and we've been especially frustrated with the failure of many county offices of education to effectively and uniformly implement LCFF.
We believe that the success of the system you adopt today hinges in great part on the critical role that those county offices play in supporting districts and providing technical assistance, and that the obligation to ensure that they do that effectively lies not only in the hands of CCEE and county superintendents, but with the state as well.
Thank you.
I'm here representing the Coalition for Alternative Education Accountability.
We provided you with a letter that you should have gotten today, and in that letter, we delineate some of our concerns and proposals in general.
We recognize the fact that at this moment, you are not immediately considering an alternative assessment system, and that that is in the works.
but we would like to go on record as seeking an alternative accountability measure that provides valid information both for schools and teachers and the state that measures things that make sense in programs that don't have your run-of-the-mill students.
The schools that we're dealing with are dealing with a high level of transiency and a high level of students who are overage under credit.
It's not unusual for our schools to be looking at students who are 17 years old when they enter the school and have 30 or less credits.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you all for your hard work pushing us to college and career readiness and looking at multiple measures.
My name is Ama.
I taught in the prison and public school system and now serve as the Executive Director of Educators for Excellence Los Angeles.
I'm very proud to be standing with my teacher colleagues who are going to speak with you shortly.
But I'm actually here as a parent.
I'm here for my daughter, Asha, who is entering kindergarten next year.
And here's what I need as a public education parent and partner.
I want the conversation about school performance to be accessible and comprehensive.
I want a dashboard full of indicators and a streamlined snapshot.
More information will only help me be more empowered as a parent and a partner.
I also want an accountability system that prioritizes closing achievement gaps for black and brown children like my daughter.
And in 13 years when Asha graduates prepared for college, that has to mean she has met all the requirements for admission to CSU without remediation.
Thank you very much.
My name is Tunji Adebayo.
I'm a high school science teacher in LA.
And I had my students vote on whether I should come here today or whether I should stay and teach.
And they voted that their voices needed to be heard.
And those voices are calling for equity and clarity, like the voice of Marco's mom who currently doesn't have the high school education he's receiving, whose little sister had to translate the question, what high school should Marco go to?
I did not have an answer.
Equity is Marco's mom being able to read the evaluation rubrics and make an informed decision for herself.
Equity is my mentee, Jason, his mother knowing that he goes to a school that is in the bottom 20 to 30% and does not meet the state standard.
Equity is her being able to take action if she chooses to.
Equity is us not pretending that the bottom 5% are the only schools that need help, and us creating capacity to fit the need.
We have to have the courage to be honest about where we are and the tenacity and creativity to build a system where all stakeholders can understand and then fight to make that change.
Thank you.
If numbers 97 through 104 would please line up in the boardroom.
Good afternoon.
My name is Erica Silva, and I'm a sixth grade math teacher and doctoral candidate at USC.
As a daughter of immigrant parents, I know firsthand the value of education and its ability to transform the trajectory of a family and a community.
As a teacher, I urge you to consider the ease and readability of the plan rating system.
I encourage you to pilot the rating system across the state with multiple stakeholder groups to ensure that it will benefit all families, regardless of their background.
I make these recommendations because of my former student Christina and thousands like her who translated all school documents into Spanish for her mother.
I know that Christina's mom wants the best education for her daughter and it is up to us to break down barriers to access by providing easy to read and understand information so that all parents regardless of their background can make informed decisions regarding their child's educational future.
Thank you for your consideration.
Good afternoon.
My name is Freddy Guzman.
I teach seventh grade math and science in Los Angeles.
I'm a proud father and the president of the Salvadoran American Leadership and Educational Fund.
Today I want to tell you about Ms.
Mundell, my sixth grade teacher.
For the duration of sixth grade, Ms.
Mundell never let us go to the playground.
We only left our classwork when it was time to eat or go to the bathroom.
This teacher had the highest standard of any teacher at our school and maybe in all East LA.
Being in Ms.
Mandel's class was not easy, but we loved it because Ms.
Mandel did not focus on our obstacles.
She focused on our potential.
Just like Ms.
Mandel, our state needs to build a system of high expectations for all students.
I believe every student deserves a fighting chance at life.
But we don't give them that by lowering expectations or minimizing the number of schools we identify for supports.
As a teacher, I serve my students best by sharing optimal teaching practices with other teachers.
Similarly, the state could share valuable knowledge between those schools with persistent gaps in those that have shown great improvement.
Need to send a great message that we believe in them to our students.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Jessica Sacco representing the California Science Teachers Association.
I want to thank the State Board and California Department of Education staff for the excellent work that they have done over these last few years.
We've made a lot of progress and we're really pleased where we are today as well as completely honoring the process of continuous improvement that you're looking forward to putting in place as this progresses because we agree there is more work to be done and we stand ready to continue participating in this process.
I'd like to thank member Strauss for her acknowledgement about the need to address broad course of study at the elementary years.
We agree this is critical, this is when it begins, and this is what we need in order to have our students ready to prepare to fill the colleges, excuse me, the careers that California's gonna need in the future.
Finally, I ask that you consider our recommendation to allow for additional criterias for the local performance indicators in order to allow locals to demonstrate progress.
Currently, met, not met, not met for two years doesn't allow you to show progress.
Implementation of state standards takes more than two years, many years.
Please allow for progress to be demonstrated.
Thank you.
Elizabeth Robitaille on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
As we have referenced in the letters we've submitted to you in July and September, we remain concerned that without further clarity from the State Board, the many metrics in the LCAP rubric may devolve into many ways for an authorizer to justify closing a successful charter school or renewing a chronically underperforming one.
We therefore ask the state board to clarify how LCAP will intersect the charter renewal and will align with state law requiring academic achievement to be the most important factor in determining charter renewal.
Without this clarity, charter school authorizers are proceeding even now with charter renewal determinations
with highly varying interpretations.
This clarity on charter LCAP rubrics is also crucial because charter schools are afforded additional flexibility and statute to address only aspects of the eight state priorities that apply to the grade levels served or the nature of the program operated by the charter school.
We look forward to working with the state board and staff to clarify how the LCAP rubric and template will align with the laws guiding charter school accountability.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm Molly Dunn with the Alliance for Children's Rights and a member of a coalition of advocates who represent children in foster care.
Just a few notes.
First, we really commend you on all of the hard work over the last two years to get to this really historic moment that we're at today.
Secondly, we're pleased to see the inclusion of prompts that could be included in a self-assessment tool for Priority 10, which is, of course, the COE, Coordination of Services for Children in Foster Care.
And we look forward to continuing to work with the SBE and CDE staff to develop a Priority 10 self-assessment tool that can be used by districts throughout the state, or rather, county offices throughout the state.
We also appreciate discussions we've had with SBE staff around end size for foster youth and that we understand that there's an ongoing commitment to keep that at 15.
And finally, we continue to be concerned about a plan to have a separate accountability system for students attending alternative schools.
Foster youth are disproportionately in alternative schools.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Jackie Wong with the National Center for Youth Law.
I'm here on behalf of foster youth that we represent through our foster initiative.
I just want to underscore what my colleague Molly Dunn had spoken to really appreciate what the board staff has done and the board members who have spoken out over time in supporting the needs of students in foster care.
We look forward to continuing to collaborate with you all as well as the Department of Education to make sure that we fulfill the promise of LCFF for students in foster care.
Thank you so much.
Mr. President, I'm Brian Rivas speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
I'll just quickly bullet for you.
We have a few concerns.
One is with the schedule for delivery of assistance to LEAs identified as such.
I think one of my colleagues in the Equity Coalition, Mr. Affelt, may have commented that in year one, the schedule calls for a letter and then actual assistance wouldn't be provided until a subsequent year.
We think that may be too long.
We ask that you look at triaging the needs of some LEAs that may be not meeting standards for multiple subgroups.
And with regard to state standards and the cut points, we think that needs to be communicated a little more clearly.
We're worried that the fact that green is the goal may not come across clearly, that that can be remedied by noting that on the top level display.
And we want you to take note of the fact that we're worried that some may read that and think the standard is to avoid red.
Good afternoon, my name is Samantha Tran with Children Now.
We've submitted lengthy comments for your review and we're well aligned with Dr. Weber's statement as well.
We'd strongly encourage the board to delay action today.
I know there's time pressures, but we've been staunch advocates of multiple measures in multiple contexts in LCFF, AB 2548, and so we're well aligned with you on that front and in the goal to make sure we have true support and assistance to schools and districts.
What we are concerned with, and we have appreciated the comments today about creating an aligned system, but what you have before you isn't that.
There are key equity guardrails in ESSA in statute, not the regulations, that aren't being baked into the system.
That includes academics having substantial weight, differential improvement standards for students that are furthest behind.
meaningful differentiation.
These are really important key things that need to be baked into the system.
In addition, we're really concerned that the board is being asked to vote on something without clarity about the implications for those decisions.
The data runs we've seen so far don't show how many LEAs and schools are going to be identified.
We strongly encourage you to take a little bit more time, work with multiple groups, and see if we can move this forward.
Thank you.
Will the remaining speakers please line up in the boardroom?
Hi, my name is Elizabeth Frank and I'm here to speak a little bit about alternative schools and their needs.
I want to thank Dr. Strauss for keeping alternative schools in the dialogue and
We really want to stress the importance of considering alternative schools and their needs when considering these accountability measures.
Because alternative schools work with a unique set of students, the accountability measures traditionally used don't always best support student outcomes.
One of those is the four-year cohort graduation rate.
If you get kids in who are over age and behind on credits, they're not going to be able to graduate within four years of getting to these alternative schools and the schools need a chance to really show that what they're doing works beyond that four year rate.
One of the things we've looked at is retention because even one more day in school really helps these students.
So we just really want to stress the importance to us that these accountability measures support retention and student outcomes for all students, not just traditional school students.
Hi, my name is Lauren Cullen, and I'm here with Elizabeth Frank, the previous speaker, speaking on behalf of Alternative Educational Programs.
With our unique situation, we've also focused heavily on less tangible aspects of school performance, such as school climate and the social-emotional development of our students.
These are the strengths of our programs and they're vital to the success of our students.
For example, our schools offer specific curriculum for social-emotional development that very often re-engages our students in their education and gives them the opportunity to take ownership of what they're doing in school.
This in turn increases student performance, credit completion and progression, retention in our program, and ultimately graduation from high school.
This is an area that we would like for you to be considered in a unique way beyond simple surveys for alternative programs as they may be strength specific and separate from how we hold traditional schools accountable.
Thank you so much.
Hello, my name is Andrew Medina representing Asian Americans Advancing Justice California.
Advancing Justice California is a partner in the College for All Coalition, a multiracial and cross-sector coalition of community education, student, parent, labor, faith, and civil rights organizations that are united in our vision of renewed investment in California public higher education.
I formally submitted a letter today on College for All's recommendations regarding the need for transparent, effective,
and equitable implementation of 200 million K-12 college readiness block grant which has recently been established in the California state budget to serve students who are low-income English learners and foster youth.
This letter is signed by over 30 diverse organizations and alliances throughout the state that are members of the College for All coalition.
Our recommendation center and ensuring that the funds are used as intended to increase the college readiness and eligibility of students who are low income English learners and foster youth.
Some of the recommendations include defining LCFF plus schools as schools that have enrolled an average of 75% or more students who are LCFF over a three year rather than one year period, as well as just ensuring proper reporting.
So we look forward to working with the State Board of Education on this.
Good afternoon, State Board members.
My name is Doneshia Carlos.
I am the founder of Lifting Education, Activating Parents.
I'm a parent activist and I am the mother of three and the grandparent of one.
And I would like to stress today the importance of not just talking about equity and accountability, but also acting in an equitable fashion as it relates to the transparency and the accessibility of the LCFF.
While we can get caught in the weeds about what the new accountability system looks like, feels like, and how it works, that issue becomes moot if the most important, if not the most important group of people are not included, and that is parents.
Parents are the first educators of our children, but yet they are the most underrepresented when it comes to making decisions and implementing systems in education.
That is not an equitable process.
Creating, revamping and implementing systems without involvement is not an equitable process.
And I ask that the board take a good look at that when furthering their decisions on this system.
Thank you.
My name is Candace Forrester.
I'm a parent, an educator, and the co-founder of Project Equity.
Our schools and education systems are charged with the responsibility of providing all students with a quality education.
However, not all schooling is created equal, and that's evident by our alarming achievement, discipline, and access gaps.
I urge you today to do something honorable and radical.
I urge you to meet schools and districts where they are and offer students what they need to be successful.
Please make sure that our new accountability system is truly one that is aspirational.
Rather than focusing on the failing while ignoring those who are struggling does not work.
Rather, it's an example of limited problem solving skills and a limited capacity to think collaboratively and creatively.
So again, I ask that in our plans to develop a new system of accountability, we hold ourselves to the same standards that we hold our students and our teachers when we ask them to be creative, flexible, and 21st century problem solvers.
Good afternoon, my name is Carmen Perkins.
I'm a parent, educator, and co-founder of Project Equity with Candace Forrester.
As we think about implementing the new LCFF, I ask that you consider how equity will be addressed for school leaders, school board members, and administrators who are currently in the red to really consider how they will be held accountable and what the measures of getting them out of the red and into the blue will be.
I think too often we forget
while addressing just saying schools are failing, we need to actually hold those teachers, those administrators, and those board members accountable for our students not getting to where they need to be.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Maria Montes and I'm from Stockton.
I'm a part of the Stockton Schools Initiative and I'm here to talk about how I immigrated from Mexico originally.
My family's from Mexico and I
Coming here I struggled learning English, but fortunately I had a teacher who cared and I was able to excel and now I will be the first in my family to attend college.
But as the recent SBAC test results show us, there are many English learners who are struggling and the achievement gaps are widening.
This should be unacceptable to all of us as English learners make one in four students in California.
An accountability system is not equitable if a district or school can still be considered good even when English learners are not doing well.
I urge the board to do everything it can to ensure that English learners are not hidden in a dashboard and left behind.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Jasmine Delafoss and I'm with the South Stockton Schools Initiative as well.
And we are very active in our local control accountability plan back home in Stockton, and as you know, is very poor.
And I know that because I've seen it firsthand that the lack of accountability and that the
the lack of accountability have failed our students and families as well as our communities.
So while we're here today, it's time that we really pull up our bootstraps and time for us to be honest about transparency and time for us to be creative about how we are redesigning schools and accountability in our school systems, which means including parents and students in these conversations.
I invite you to come to Stockton and talk to our parents and our students because our district fails to do that.
And I kindly invite you and we will host you
if you really want to talk to parents and students so you can understand the issues we are facing in our communities.
The state shouldn't have, shouldn't limit or dictate the student achievement because of the capacity you have and so we hope that you prioritize equity and hold that truth to our students.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I really want to tell you first, I appreciate you enduring 150 comments.
That's a lot.
I can't even imagine what it's like to be a moment in your shoes.
I just, yeah, praying for you.
So my name is Dr. April Clay.
I'm a parent, first and foremost, of six wonderful children in San Bernardino, California, five of whom are in college.
and one remains in high school.
Yeah, that look, right.
I enjoy them and I love them, but more importantly, I advocate for them.
And I do that not just by myself, but among other parents and with schools and leaders.
And I'm here today with a group of parent leaders advocating on behalf of our students.
So let me share with you first that I am a licensed marriage and family therapist.
I am a researcher, an advocate, and a parent advocate as well.
In the schools, I've seen a lot of things over the 35 years as a student, as a parent, as a counselor in the schools as well.
And I will say that one thing that we want to make sure this matrix includes is teeth.
It's important to say that we want to have our kids succeed, but without being very transparent and having clear goals that the schools understand and having teeth to support it, I'm concerned that it won't be equitable for our kids.
We want to make sure that they truly do whatever it is that you're setting as the bar, all of our schools meet it, not just those in the red.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon.
My name is Jewel Patterson.
I'm a recent graduate from the University of Redlands and a youth organizer in San Bernardino.
I first want to thank you all for your work that you've been doing on the state's accountability system.
I'm here today as a voice for my community's youth and to ask you to prioritize equity in the accountability system decisions that are left to be made.
As a youth organizer who works hard to empower youth to get involved with their education, I can tell you firsthand that information that is accessible and understandable is key to getting youth, or anyone for that matter, engaged.
So as you contemplate decisions around the top level display, I ask you to ensure that the equity report be clear and prominent.
Additionally, some
kind of at-glance summary, along with the multiple measures, will be extremely helpful for everyone to quickly see how schools and districts are doing.
Because honestly, district administrators aren't the only ones that need the information about a district or school's performance.
Everyone does.
So that if there are problems, everyone, including youth, can be part of the solution.
And that's what equity looks like.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Mia Cooper.
I'm a parent of five kids from eight months to 21.
I'm from San Bernardino, and I'm a gay parent.
for a number of years and plan on remaining at the table to ensure that the state cannibal system works and consider parents like me who desire to be involved in the process.
This is why I'm here today.
First, thank you for all your hard work and secondly to ask you for equality.
Be front and center as you make these final decisions.
After all, parents
are the primary audience of the purpose-top-level display of an accountability system that prioritizes equality.
Consider me, because in short, I am a partner of the district or the school to help them continue improving, because after all, we're in this together.
While I can appreciate the multiple measures in the accountability system, but if I or the parents don't understand, how can we help our kids?
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Pastor Sam Casey, and I'm the Executive Director of Congregations Organized for Prophetic Engagement, or COPE.
As a pastor, and most importantly, as a parent of three daughters who have matriculated through the public school system, I want to thank this board for your hard work thus far, but ask you to make equity the order of the day in the decisions that are left to be made on today.
I fought for LCFF along with other parent advocates and faith leaders within San Bernardino County because it promotes equity and holds the promise of closing opportunity access and achievement gaps.
As the new SBAC test shows,
results show more must be done to close these gaps and it starts with strong accountability systems that truly prioritize equity by setting high expectations for all students and incentivize districts to reach ambitious yet achievable goals for student growth in closing all gaps.
A system that truly prioritizes equity is honest about the numbers of districts and schools who are identified as needing support and has equity reports that are easy and clear for parents and constituents to understand.
Thank you so much for your time today.
And in closing, President Kirst and Board, Superintendent, it's important, additionally,
that you include beyond one year measuring suspensions and expulsions.
Please reconsider that effort.
Thank you so much.
Good afternoon members.
My name is Charles Brown and I live in San Bernardino and I'm a parent of five and a grandparent of two.
I want to thank the board for his work on accountability systems and I especially
appreciate your work around multiple measures including a measure for school climate.
I'm here to ask you to improve upon what we what you have already done so that parents and the community can clearly easily and quickly make sense of a district school performance.
Specialty improvements can be made on the equity report section of the data display to make it more clear and prominent for everyone to understand how students subgroups
are performing.
Transparency and accessibility are cornerstones of an accountability system rooted in equity.
Your job is to minimize the confusion and take the guessing out of a system that is supposed to let the public, not just administrators, know how a district or school is performing.
We're counting on you.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Terry Burns on behalf of the California School Boards Association.
In adopting the system today, we believe you have given us a strong starting point with which to express, compare, and put in context data about our schools.
The conversation over the last years has already been helpful as districts focus on the priorities and measures that you've been talking about.
Boards have begun asking for and discussing data in new ways and changing their practices as a result.
Change is already happening in our schools.
We are implementing professional development, new materials, and new practices to address the individual needs of students.
As we have more experience with the better data and new efforts, we're confident that achievement gaps will continue to close more quickly.
We look forward to continuing to work with you for the continuous improvement of this accountability system in the ways indicated in our letter and many of the ways indicated by the public today.
Thank you for being so attentive.
Good afternoon, my name is Carl Pinkston.
I'm an operational director for the Black Parallel School Board.
We're a community-based organization located in Sacramento that parallels the Sacramento City Unified School District.
I want to thank you and acknowledge that this board moving in the right direction and looking at and proposing multiple measures of evaluating districts and schools as well.
Most particularly in the area of suspension and suspension rate, which is critical to closing the educational gap of kids of color.
Also, we want to make clear that two points.
One is, and I'll read real quick, parent participation or parent engagement.
We need to change it from participation to parent engagement.
Couple of things about parent engagement.
We really need to look at acceptance of a parent recommendation rate.
participation rates by ethnicity and gender.
A positive participation rate, how positive relationship that is.
And lastly, and most importantly, as it relates to suspension, a child cannot learn if they're not in the classroom.
So please keep that on the burner.
Good afternoon.
My name is Afrin Mercado from the County Superintendent's Association.
I just wanted to say thank you for all your hard work, and we are supportive of the adoption of the evaluation rubrics.
I think this is a key step forward for our state to have a single local, state, and federal accountability system that is coherent and aligned.
We do understand that there will be work moving forward to refine the system and the evaluation rubrics and we're happy to support the state board and CDE in that effort and we also feel it to be very important the messaging to the field regarding the evaluation rubrics and eventually the template in November and the nexus of those two documents are two tools that come together to impact the field and the better that we are with messaging and their implementation, the better job that we'll be able to do to close the achievement gap and boost student outcomes forward for our state.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Sarah Lillis with EdVoice.
You've received many letters from us over the last few years about how important we feel that the focus on academic outcomes and closing achievement and opportunity gaps are in these rubrics.
And as we reflect on the progress we've made, we really see that you've made significant gains from previous recommendations where we were only looking at two grade spans when you're talking about academic outcomes.
So we applaud the progress that has been made.
But as board members have said, as constituents have said, it's still a work in progress with some key issues needing explicit board direction.
And you've seen them in our letters, you've heard them from others, namely refining the college and career readiness indicator, the 11th grade assessment as an academic outcome, we still think is an important conversation.
And as Dr. Weber remembered, some of the additional questions that need to be answered to make sure that this truly is a unified local state federal system.
and the messages that are being sent by the rubrics and the top line interface, whether it's about equity or what our expectations are.
What is the green that we're going to?
And so I think that's an important conversation we hope you have, and we'd be happy to work with you on all those things.
Thank you.
Eric Premack with the Charter Schools Development Center.
We're here again to express our concern about the disconnect between charter law and the rubrics.
As I understand the motion before you now, it essentially would impose these indicators on charter schools, even though state law indicates that they're supposed to have flexibility with respect to whether to include these indicators in their LCAP.
We would ask if you're going to adopt this motion today that you amend it to specifically note that it only applies to charter schools to the extent that their LCAP reflects the state priorities related to those indicators.
And we would also ask that any state-level multicolored smiley face displays only show those indicators for charter schools that they have adopted in their LCAPs.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Castle Redmond, program manager with the California Endowment.
Thank you, Dr. Kirst.
Thank you, Superintendent Torlakson.
Thank you, board.
We want to congratulate you and thank you for the great work that you've done.
We appreciate including some of the multiple measures that we consider to be health-related in this broad system.
We understand that there is a
More discussion that is going to go on around ESSA and the state system and local measures.
But we want to hopefully make sure and hope that you will ensure that key health measures continue to be part of whatever system as a key indicators, including and most importantly,
suspension rates moving forward.
Personally, I worked in the Oakland Unified School District for nine years and other districts for over a decade, worked in many underperforming schools and many performing schools, and that is the most important indicator to equity in underperforming schools and academic achievement, ultimately.
Thank you.
Okay, that concludes the public testimony, so now we are ready for board member comments.
Carrick had a few clarifying comments.
A few clarifying comments, and then we'll have board comments on the motion and any other issue the board wants to discuss.
Just a few items.
Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent, CDE.
Just thought it might save a couple questions to clarify a few things.
First, it hasn't been talked about a lot, but we have made mention this time around of alternative schools and a system for alternative schools, which is coming.
The governor's budget did include two positions for the Department of Education to work on that, and so we're in the process of advertising those positions.
So, those discussions are coming, and we do appreciate the patience of those who probably could have come up and asked about it, but did not.
So, I wanted to mention that.
Two, the use of scores beyond just those who met standards or exceeded standards.
Just to reiterate, that is the intention of where we're moving forward.
We do want to move away from just looking at the kids on the bubble.
We do want to look at the progress of all kids.
Scale scores may be a good way of going about doing that.
When it comes to a growth model, one of the things we'll want to get from you fairly soon is what you want that growth model to do for you.
Right?
Because getting that information will determine what models we would want to bring back to you and show you some data on.
Because there are different ways of doing those models, and you may have heard in the 150 comments, the core districts early on talked a little bit about the system that they use, and they use a growth measure.
And one of the things that was mentioned in that testimony was the use of some factors like poverty and
English learner status and that sort of thing, which is one of the possibilities of doing that.
But there are positives and negatives to what you include in that growth measure, and it all comes down to what it is you want to come out of that growth.
So, we'll be bringing back to you, bringing to you, actually for the first time, for you to make, give us some comments and some, perhaps a recommendation from you as to what you want to see out of a growth measure so that we can bring back some models for you to consider.
The third thing is that this is a system, again, that we're working on.
There were some comments about the 5% of lowest-performing schools that ESSA requires us to identify.
So we're building a system here for the 100%, because all schools can improve.
This is a continuous improvement system for all schools to improve.
At some point in time,
uh... the first step here is to work on what the state wants to do with the state's local accountability system and these evaluation rubrics that apply to all and to apply to districts once we identify what it is we want to do as a state as we as we learn more about the federal law and the regulations that get approved we'll figure out in order to have a single system as as member uh... burr mentioned to have a single system will figure out how to use our system
in a single way, in a single system, to identify those schools.
But it's just a little premature to get into that conversation right now.
And then lastly, I did want to make a mention that the workgroup for the English Learner Indicator, the folks have been identified for that workgroup and they'll be meeting coming up soon here in October and then there'll be an info memo or perhaps part of a board item we'll bring back for you.
So hopefully maybe that answers a couple of questions and we can go from there.
Okay, that's all done?
All right, Bruce Holliday.
We're not following a specific order about... No, this is wide open.
I just have a short list of... All issues are on the table that we heard about the public comment and we heard before.
First of all, I'd like to thank the core districts for being here today and for all the work they're doing in
with evaluation and with data.
I certainly hope that that work continues among the core district and that we are the beneficiary and all students in California are the beneficiary of that good work that you're doing.
Many of the types of analyses that you're doing are really important and valuable and
Who knows, we may be able to adopt those in years to come.
So, stay the good course.
I also want to thank PICO for being here today as well.
I think there's a lot of great opportunity for organizations like PICO to disseminate information about how best to measure parent engagement, for example, or school climate.
In the current rubric and action pieces that we're looking at today, repeatedly in the local measures, it says suggested possible ways of measuring will be developed in a number of those categories.
Will we see examples of that by November in at least some of those categories?
Yes.
We have a couple that have started work already.
The goal is to move them along the school climate and broader piece, for example, but then bring forward as those work groups.
It'd be great to see at least some examples fairly soon on those.
I think that would help a lot of people.
But certainly, once again, groups like PICO could really be helpful in that regard as well.
In terms of the alternative schools,
hear very clearly that there is an alternative accountability system in the works or will be in the works soon.
But in the meantime, I do think it would be very helpful for all of those alternative schools to have some clarity as to how in the interim they are supposed to respond to all of this or work through all of these pieces or so that a lot of
needless worry and fear and consternation, it's not going to happen.
So some clarity for them I think would be very, very helpful.
In regards to the number of people who spoke today who talked about having a summary
number, I guess, of some kind that would make it very easy for parents to compare one school to another.
I just return to our roots again, where we came a long time ago, where it was pretty darn easy to hide a great deal of lack of performance behind one single number.
The, what's easy is not always good.
And in this case, I think easy can be really bad.
I think it is, I think we saw today a dashboard, a look that is moving in the right direction.
I apologize for my graphic artist comment last meeting.
But I do think that we're getting close to making it easy for parents.
I really do.
I feel much more confident that we're going to get there and that they will be able to distinguish this school from that school in very important ways.
what are children similar to my child accomplishing in this school versus that school?
To me, that is the heart of school choice as opposed to how all kids are doing in that school, you know, the big number kind of thing.
So once again, I caution us not to head back down that road because I do think that that can be very misleading.
The 11th grade test
question about having it be a part of the CCI, as we're calling it now, college and career readiness, and as well as a part of the academic indicator.
I don't, I still can't wrap my head around why it can't be in both.
I certainly understand how, certainly in the short run, maybe forever, having the 11th grade test be a part of the college and career indicator makes sense, makes a lot of sense.
But at the same time, I don't like that it doesn't also appear over here.
I don't see it as double counting.
I really don't.
But maybe somebody can explain that to me.
So that's one thing that I've been thinking about.
In regards to the encouragement to have first year interventions, more interventions early on, I do hope that the collaborative and the counties and even the state, if necessary, step up to helping aggressively, enthusiastically, right away, as soon as information.
And I think that's what's happening.
I think that that's the plan, even though it's not,
written out that you have to do this and this.
I think that's going to happen.
I think it's in the spirit.
And my last comment is along those lines.
The conversations that we're having now in this room and that people are bringing into this room are so far different from what they were four or five years ago when I first came into this room.
People are talking about data all the time.
People are talking about equity all the time.
People are talking about making sure that we see clearly what is happening in schools in all sorts of ways, and they are excited.
to make change for the best.
And that's huge.
That is absolutely huge.
And so I want to thank all the CDE staff, state board staff, the governor, the legislature, everyone who has, along with us, adhered not just to the law, but adhered to the spirit of LCFF.
And today we get to pull it together and say,
We stuck to our guns all the way through, and we believe that this is going to help close the achievement gap in the future.
And I think it's good.
Thank you.
Well, that's a number of inquiries you should respond.
Carrick's been taking a list, so.
Some are on my list, so.
Well, so a lot of those were comments more than questions.
Yeah, the questions about the 11th grade, first year intervention, others.
Do you want to just have everybody get their comments and then go back?
Oh, go around and then come back.
Feliza was next.
Yeah, Feliza was next.
So I also agree that I think we've come a long way from when I joined the the board last May.
There's a couple of things that I want to agree with board member Holiday.
One is the 11th grade making sure that it's part of the composite for college and career readiness but also standalone and we saw
wide spectrum of stakeholders who also echo that and I think it's important for us to to understand that this is where we're at now with the accountability system but if there's some reoccurring themes that are coming up in the letters and the comments we should also pause and see is there merit in those.
One of the things that since I started at the board have been one of my pretty much permanent talking points.
Who wants to guess?
Equity, achievement gaps, English learners.
Oh, science, yeah.
We'll leave that for my cousin.
So what I want to say about the achievement gap is that I am still disappointed with this accountability system as it relates to a focus in narrowing achievement gaps.
I understand that we have the growth and that's part of the methodology that we have.
One of the metaphors that I use is if we're all rotating one chair to the right, I'm never going to sit next to Bruce Holiday.
So yes, I may be moving, but I will never sit next to him.
And so when we're looking at narrowing achievement gaps and we're looking at equity, that has to be actionable.
It can't just be a word that we use to describe the lack of equity.
or moving, we have an acknowledgment of equity, but how do we act towards it?
When we look at the SBAC data, we see that there is growth, but we're not narrowing achievement gaps, right?
And so we could look at English learners, and I heard the argument they only made a one-point gain for math.
And so then the conversation kind of started with, well, this is a revolving door for students.
That could be true.
If you look at the group ELs, they're very heterogeneous.
It's not one group of EL students.
If you look at the long-term English learners, you will see that the majority are U.S.
born and have started their schooling system in the U.S.
in kinder.
Is it really just a language thing?
Could it be that we're not teaching to English learners?
Could it be that the system may not be designed for these students in terms of what they're receiving?
Are they receiving their designated EL time?
Look at African Americans, 2%.
Not much better than English learners.
These students are still performing in the 16 to 18%.
What's the reasoning there?
Same group of students.
They're not moving in and out of the category.
Latino students.
Let's look at Latino students not only because I'm Latina, but even if I wasn't Latina, Latinos are 53 percent of the state of California.
53 percent.
That's your future workforce.
Those are, this is the majority of the state.
53 in our public school system.
Shouldn't we care a little more about these students?
shouldn't we care if these students are actually making not only gains but accelerated gains because we our future as a state really depends on properly educating these students.
So I want to see that more intentionally embedded into our accountability system.
I think the LCAP template would be a good place for that because we're able to
acknowledge there what we're going to do as districts to narrow achievement gaps.
But it has to be a little bit more intentional than what we're doing right now.
And I know that it didn't make the methodology.
I thought that we would still be able to set targets that accelerated growth for some subgroups.
And then I realized that, oh, well, that's not embedded into the methodology.
It's just growth.
Right.
Which is still unclear to me how a subgroup in red, what is the goal to get to green?
Is it 20 points?
And
Under LCFF, we have no state determined timeline to get to that green.
And it's unclear to me if we're going to have targets that let the LEAs know, hey, you need 20 points for this subgroup, 15 points for this subgroup, and the clock starts now.
there is no state determined timeline which will be incompatible with ESSA and I think that it's important for us to see how those two systems will merge when you have a state determined timeline for schools and you have some growth that has to take place but you don't have it for LCFF.
So I know that we're moving toward one system but I think we really need to look at where are the points of misalignment because those will matter as well.
When we say we're moving it to that one system we have to then reconcile
where those points are not aligning.
And that conversation has to happen.
I know that the regulations are draft at this point.
But they're also, some of them are making their way, I saw them in the ESSA state plan.
Some of the regs that are still draft were cited there and decisions were made based on those draft regs.
So if we're going to say we're pausing on the regulations, then we really need to pause.
But we also need to consider, do we have a system with enough flexibility
to adhere by the regulations once those are finalized.
That may be at the end of the fall.
Sure, things could change with the new administration.
I could be deported even though I'm U.S.
born with the new administration that's coming up.
You know, knock on wood.
So you'll have to Skype me in for some of these decisions.
But again, I think it's important for us to really consider and have very honest conversations and push through the pain of saying, these are two systems that align very nicely in these ways, but do not align.
And if we're going to keep it as one system, then let's be honest and unpackage that and say, this is what we need to do.
Thank you.
Okay, who's next?
Trish.
Trish Williams.
I have a list, more like Bruce's, a shorter, longer list, but shorter.
I do want to pick up before I start my list on what you just said about ELs and whether or not they're all the same.
I understand the concept that they are learning English, and theoretically, when they are proficient, they go out.
But so my background when I was executive director of EdSource was more research and data analysis in education.
And so what your comments made me think of is the importance of even within a subgroup disaggregating
the kinds of students in the subgroup.
And I'm not like actually saying right now that we should be doing that, but I'm raising it as a question because if we're not seeing progress in subgroups, then we're probably not looking at them with as fine a grain as maybe we should.
And I'm wondering if the same thing is also true of African Americans, for example.
And if it's just that group, instead of, and I'm just raising this, okay?
If it's just that group, but we're not disaggregating out low income from non-low income or parent education level, or males from females, because we know that there's a difference in accomplishment.
there, then I'm just making the suggestion that maybe if to see progress and to accelerate progress in different groups, we probably might think about how we could look at them differently with a different look rather than just putting them all in a group.
Okay, that's just a comment on your comment.
I want to follow up on the career
technical education and academic indicators and agree with many of you in the room that have said we need more balance there.
I think it's really important that it not be all academic and A through G and test score that finding ways to have career technical education be a stronger part of that I think is really important.
I also want to follow up on the year one assistance.
I would like to hear the comment that we shouldn't, if we get numbers that show that there are schools or districts that are failing in many, many areas, we don't wait a year.
If if CB and the county offices could get the direction that they in addition to whatever else they're trying to plan for the first year if they could also be ready to spot and act on Schools that are severely look like they're in severe trouble rather than waiting I think it's hard for us to justify waiting other than the fact that we don't have the capacity But kind of morally it's hard to justify it another one is
school climate, in particular the woman that spoke on behalf of school psychologists.
And in her letter, she mentioned that they didn't know that there's supposed to be a working group on school climate.
And they don't see when that's posted and who's invited and they would like to be invited.
I would like to say that I personally think that they would be an important person or important group and have important expertise to be at that kind of a meeting.
And it's a different kind of expertise.
So often when we're talking about school climate, we're talking about whether or not the school itself is friendly and supportive and kids feel safe there.
But there's also an element of whether or not some of the students have backgrounds that are particularly troubling and struggling in their families or communities that cause them stress also at home.
There are a lot of documented studies on this called
adverse childhood experiences.
Psychologists know how to look out for that and to look out for those kids and provide interventions for those kids in particular.
I want to echo also member Holiday.
about CORE and PACE and the work they're doing and that I hope it continues and that I hope we support it and that we learn from it.
I think it's really important and it's a resource that we have here in California that probably few other states have and that we haven't had in the same way before.
I want to say that I'm inclined to want to keep the suspension data.
I understand that the research backs chronic absenteeism, and I think that chronic absenteeism is one kind of an indicator, but suspension data, I think, tends to
And I don't have a resource that I can cite right now, but I think it tends often to happen more with African-American males.
And that's a particular reason why we heard so many raise that as an issue.
And it's well known that it's a pipeline to jail and prison when that happens.
And so I do think it's important.
I think we ought to consider keeping it.
the issue about wanting a summary indicator in addition to the multiple indicators.
That's one of the changes I heard in the public comment, is that we want both.
We need some way to kind of know, to kind of more quickly figure things out.
I would like to encourage that, to hear that as not necessarily meaning we have to have a summary indicator, but we need to hear what those parents are saying to us about how important it is to them and their communities to be able to feel like they are understanding what's going on in that school and whether or not it's the right school for their kids.
I mean, the amount of parent commitment
to their kids.
I'm going to get a little stereotyped right now.
The kind of parent commitment I just heard to their kids is just extraordinary.
And they're asking to make sure that they have the kind of help they need.
And if we keep that as the North Star, not necessarily get kind of freaked out over API, then we might be able to find ways to make that easier for them.
The 11th grade test score, I agree.
I'd like to see it in both places, and especially for small districts that might not have another one.
Finally, my final one is with the charter schools and their request in both letters from Eric and from CCSA.
We've talked about this.
I don't think anything intentional has happened here.
It's just that this has been such a big challenge for two years now.
But we've talked repeatedly about the importance of indicating clearly in whatever reporting we're doing, whether that's directions on the LCAP or whether that's this kind of state reporting, in making it clear which indicators are not applicable
to charter schools, certainly the Williams ones, and saying that specifically, not just saying not applicable.
And, you know, the issue about what things are in the statute that apply to charters and which things are in LCFF that do or do not apply to charters.
I had a brief conversation with David Sapp about that, and I'd like to ask him if he would just speak to that to make sure that, because you have like the language down and I don't have that down.
And that's my, this is my last point.
Okay, good.
Who's next?
Hi, David Sapp, Deputy Policy Director and Assistant Legal Counsel with the State Board.
Just quickly on the question around charter schools, I think there have been several information memos that were posted earlier that sort of identified that there are certain indicators that don't apply by statute.
This is a legal issue that don't apply by statute to charters.
The one that was cited in the examples in the comment letters was priority one, the basics.
which really just incorporates the Williams Settlement Agreement, that that's an example that's been referenced in prior materials.
And so the recommended action before you today, the wording of the proposed standard for that local measure includes the word as applicable, and that was intended to capture that distinction.
We understand the concern that it may not be clear in terms of how this thing gets implemented.
And so that's something that at the staff level, we are committed to sort of meet with interested stakeholders, come back, provide an update to the board on this issue, and as appropriate, bring any recommended action to make it clearer.
If we come back in November, there also will be the revised LCAP template that'll be before the board at that time.
This same question about the instructions to the LCAP and greater clarity and specificity has been one that's come up several times.
So we hope to be able to address both of those at the November meeting and make sure the language aligns.
So you will be hearing more from us on this at the next board meeting.
And I appreciate the fact that you're going to re-engage both of the charter organizations and whoever else is appropriate so that you work together and they feel comfortable with what we've done.
Mike, may I add to this?
The accountability system does not change the statute specifically about renewal of charters and authorizers renewal process.
It does, the statute still places
the most significant emphasis on academic achievement.
And so authorizers need to understand that the renewal process has not changed because of this accountability system.
Which means that it's not the other indicators.
If there are problems with those other indicators, but the school is doing well academically, it's the academics that drive the renewal decision.
Okay, Nikki.
Board Member Sandoval.
Thank you very much for your your excellent work and thank you to members of the public for just sticking with us through this process.
I really appreciate all of your input.
Yeah and I just have two questions and the first is really just I would appreciate a little bit more clarity about the content of the letter.
that was referenced, year one, this idea of identifying strengths and weaknesses, and specifically, is it just going to focus on identifying strengths and weaknesses, or is it going to take it any further than that, requesting a response, or what are the action steps to address these shortcomings?
And then the second question I have is just,
I would also appreciate more clarity around the workgroups, the ones that are happening simultaneously through this process.
Specifically, clarity about composition of the workgroups and then transparency of the process for members of the public.
I heard questions about that, and I had questions myself about that.
So those are the two areas that I'd appreciate more information on.
Thank you.
So the general theme as I'm listening to the public comments and comments from my fellow board members is that while we were generally very pleased with the architecture of this new accountability system under LCFF rubrics, that we are all recognizing that the instruments
with which we are populating that architecture is still quite blunt.
And it gets it to a lot of the equity issues.
Are you really measuring what we really want to measure?
Does it align with what we intend?
And so my question is more around, you don't have to answer right now, you can save it till the end.
While one of our items that we'll be approving is this annual update process, I feel like we need more, as we're designing this, we need more information rather than just an annual update type of where we're going.
I just know that I remember, and whether the methodologies that we may be initially approving, at what point do we get enough information where we might decide that we're going to change it?
And someone else had pointed out that we do have several groups who have been very invested in it, have done a lot of work on their own in trying to come up with some different models for us to consider.
And it would, I think, behoove us to take a look at some of those things.
And I remember in the development of the API, even, that when we first started with the API, we started with one methodology of developing the API.
And then, when we started adding additional items into it, and then there were different grade level tests, that we decided to totally switch to a completely different methodology, which made much more sense.
So I think this, I sense this iterative piece of how do we continue to refine these instruments that we have?
And I do agree there's one where I am, I am concerned with the college and career readiness index right now.
And are we ready for that?
And if we're not technically sound with that, I would like to see the 11th grade pulled out as well.
Because while conceptually it's great,
if we can't really, if we're not really, if we don't have the information to appropriately, if that's appropriate for that, what we intend for that index, then the 11th grade scores, I do feel like also need to be pulled out.
So those are just some of the things that I think we need to continue looking at.
Okay.
Suver?
Thank you.
I want to make a couple of comments and then I have some questions.
The first is just with respect to how much, how soon about assistance, et cetera.
One thing I forgot to mention in my opening comments is we still have not fully funded LCFF.
We sort of lost track of this.
Remember, the funding and the accountability are supposed to go together.
Now, we are darn close, thanks to a very strong economy and tax revenues from Prop 30, but we are still not there yet.
I don't want our expectations to get ahead of the resources we are providing the LEAs to actually do the work.
I just want us to kind of keep that in mind.
I also think that it's fair to give LEAs advance notice of what we're going to judge them on.
And we're just now getting there.
Today's the day, really, we hope, where we're going to say, here's where we start.
We're going to be refining it over time.
So, I, for one, don't have one bit of concern about the first year being, I'm going to send you a letter.
Because if you look at, this is my big sort of bugaboo, the table that was in the memo I think Jenny put together for us about graduation requirements.
UC requirements, CSU, there's a mismatch there.
The state statutory requirements for graduation are much lower than what the admission requirements are.
So there are districts out there that are going, hey, we're completely compliant with state statute, we're offering graduation courses, our kids are graduating, but guess what?
They're not meeting those admissions.
So, I think it's very fair and actually absolutely essential that we give LEAs the advance notice of saying, here's what your expectations are, and we're going to give you time to work up to it.
It doesn't mean that if in the first year, you know, on a lot of the other indicators, everybody's in the red.
Believe me, the counties, and I'll be happy to tell the counties this, they better be in there saying, you guys have got a problem.
And we're going to have to help you.
We're going to work right alongside you.
I know that I, for one, and I'm guessing the superintendent as well, will be telling the CCEE the same message.
Get on it.
But again, let's just keep it in context.
Have we fully funded them?
Have we given them the appropriate advance notice of what we expect for them?
I'm probably also going to be the one naysayer on grade 11, but I'm going to pose this as a question to Kerry because I think this is why we made the decision in the first place to pull it out.
Grade 11, because there is no growth information, because there's no additional testing in high school, doesn't fit in a growth model.
when you start to think about how do test scores, how do we use a growth model for test scores?
So I just, I think maybe we need a fuller discussion about grade 11 and why we decided not to do double counting and also why it doesn't fit in a growth model as an academic indicator and why we thought it landed in the college and career indicator.
So just want to talk a little bit about that.
The two other things I want to mention is I think a lot of what we heard today, and I appreciate your comments, Member Williams, about being, you know, really trying to listen to what the parents were saying about a summative rating.
To me, when I unpack that, there are many, many programs on the books, meaning the statutes, that are aligned to our old accountability system, such as the parent trigger legislation, that said if you are in decile, pick whatever the decile was, or your API score is such and such, you are subject to takeover.
I mean, it was like an automatic trigger.
And so folks are worried that if we don't align this new system with that, there won't be a way to have kind of the ultimate parent choice or the ultimate parent empowerment, if you will.
So I think what I want to have a conversation about as we go along is what will be the work that we go forward to align our new system with those kinds of safeguards, if you will.
And the question is, will we or won't we?
If we do, what does it look like?
So I just wanted to kind of also put those comments in context, because they weren't entirely clear about.
what the underlying motivation was there.
The last thing, and it sort of goes to the conversation about the achievement gap.
I think the way I look at it, and this is where I want to, I emphasized at the beginning was this technical assistance piece.
The way we're trying to get at equity, in addition to the transparency, is to say no subgroup can fail.
Because any time a subgroup is failing on an academic achievement, they're gonna be kicked into technical assistance.
and ultimately into intervention.
And that's the piece that today we've really sort of started to talk about.
So at least for me, that's a way to get at it.
And in a way, to me, to be a lot more intentional about closing the achievement gap.
It's just not acceptable to have the subgroups that we've identified not be successful.
And so whoever is in there working alongside the LEAs is going to be focused on that.
So, I just wanted you to comment a little bit on that and without getting into a big technical conversation about the way the distribution system works and how you use the lookup tables and, you know, when you're going to get to green, because all of that is in there.
But, again, I think just the very simple definitions and the technical assistance about the conditions under which there will be support and assistance provided directly related to subgroup performance
is like the neon light to me about equity.
Okay, are we done?
I have some comments, and Eileen.
Yeah, she's on the list.
Eileen and Pat.
Yeah, we'll get to her.
I want to share.
OK, well, first of all, I want to echo my colleagues on the board and thanking everyone for taking the bus overnight up here, for coming, for all the ongoing work in the local communities, in the districts that really help inform our practice and really, in the end, are improving.
support for kids in school so they get what they need so their future is bright and their opportunities are great.
So I just want to thank everyone.
I appreciate the information of the research groups, the PACE, the Learning Policy Institute, the CORE, all the people that are helping inform the reality of you have this theory but this is what it means for practice.
So I hope that that will be an ongoing part of our work and that they
will help inform, I appreciated their handouts, that they'll help inform our workgroups as well.
So I have some asks actually for CDE, no surprise, about upcoming memos and work as you bring these workgroups together.
So I know there's going to be the school conditions and climate workgroup and there's going to be work on the statements of model practices, which Nancy talked about and I did a little bit in the before.
But as the timing works out, and I'm not sure
once they meet, if they'll resolve, but an updated information memo, if we can get it before the November meeting or as they're ready, I think those information memos help front load for the community, for stakeholders, and for us, the work that they're thinking about.
So that's one ask.
Secondly, I think the technical design group is the one that advises CDE, but
the CPAC is the one that's advising state board and they're very strong representation of practitioners who help think about how does this really work and what we heard from parents today and even practitioners we want so this is really interesting and these I didn't know about the Consumer Reports icons I thought that was actually oh this kind of looked interesting but basically is this working for districts?
Are parents able to understand it?
Does this help to inform
So I would really like that as the work goes along with technical design, that we include the CPAG before our meetings to help, and I know you've got some meetings coming up with them, to help inform.
I know, like, with the mock-up, the plan is to take it out to stakeholder groups and to ask, is this good?
Are we getting there?
I know the last one from the last meeting is gone now.
Now we're on to the new one.
But as Nancy kept saying, this is a mock-up to help you see it.
So I would like us to be informed, what are stakeholders saying?
Does this really work?
Is it still too confusing?
Because that's been, we've heard plus that we're moving along in the right direction, but minus that it's still a little too complicated to really be user-friendly.
So as possible, if you could include
the CPAG in this, this would be really helpful.
Also, I really would like to look at the Smarter Balanced 11th grade and understand kind of real-time data because I think, and I'm not sure if I, and so maybe staff could clarify this, that the options of using it has to do with also a cohort data as far as when the kids finally graduate from high school
if I'm clarifying that right.
So I actually understand from measurement specialists that there is a way over time to do a growth measure from 8 to 11.
And if that's true, I'd like for us to look at that as an option.
I think it's not in the short term, but I think in the longer term that is an option and growth is an important issue for us.
And then as you work on the broad course of study, which I think all of us share together, that that's really important that you bring us with the draft timeline, sort of information items as you're able to, because it does impact and help give messages to the field as well about what we think about as far as elementary, middle, and high school on.
on broad courses study.
And then an update on the plan alignment, which I know CD's been working really hard on and which I know is really complicated, but if we could have an update on that.
And maybe that's a good CPAC thing as well, because they're the ones that actually live having to fill out all those forms and reports with their board.
Maybe you could bring that to CPAC as well and have them kind of work some of that through and see if the alignment where we're going is making sense.
So, with that, I'll end those comments and pass it to Michael.
I'm wondering if we could have Deputy Superintendent Glenn Price talk a little bit about the work group.
There were several questions about that and you want to wait?
Okay.
All right.
Board Member Rucker.
Well, first of all, I want to begin by thanking all of the stakeholders who took the time, whether they drove here for 15 minutes or they were on a bus for multiple hours to come here today to participate as stakeholders in this conversation.
And I've appreciated every single time that we've heard from parents.
that we've heard from teachers, school counselors, school administrators about the work that's being done in this process to create this accountability system.
And even though you may individually be frustrated by the one minute of time that you personally had to speak, you use those single minutes very well to create an aggregate picture
for the board about where your concerns were.
And as a stakeholder group, we heard a great deal of consensus around a number of items.
And you heard many of my colleagues on the board attempt to try to address some of those points that were repeatedly mentioned in your comments.
So even though a minute may not seem like a lot of time, it was a powerful unit of time for giving the kind of feedback you gave because you were heard.
I do want to turn the attention to some of the comments that have been made, and I always appreciate following the comments that were made by Board Member Burr, because she usually says many of the things that I want to say, and she says it better.
But in talking about the growth model itself, I think the question that Carrick Ashley asked is very important.
What is it that we want the growth model to do?
Because some of the things that we are being asked to consider are incompatible with some of the desires that you have asked to be baked in to the design of the growth model.
So I think that, Kerrick, in asking us about the growth model, it may be a good idea, but in order for us to give you an informed answer, to understand how growth models work.
and how they use the different factors that can be developed in a growth model, weighting the academic factors and the other factors that are considered, you know, whether regression model or any of those other types of ways that data is actually analyzed in a growth model, how it would work.
Because if we actually are looking at a growth model, then the grade 11 Smarter Balanced assessment being included in the way that's being suggested is incompatible with any current type of growth model that I'm aware of.
And so if there is a desire to include that single data point that doesn't work in current growth models, then we need to understand
What in what way it could work because those two things are kind of incompatible with what the intent of a growth model is The second point again concerning the growth model is to understand not just what it is we how it is we want the growth model to operate to analyze the data and
and to weight all of those factors to create the single system.
But then for the parents and the teachers and the other stakeholders who came here to say, we want it to give us data about our schools, then it's not just how we want the growth model to do the analysis, but what kind of information the model then turns around and tells schools.
And I'll give a very concrete example because I heard this very clearly from a number of parents.
It's one thing to be in a flagship school district where a number of students are doing very, very well.
But if my child who is African-American is still not doing well, we still have an achievement gap.
So how do you, in a single school district, hold the district accountable for the fact that you have a flagship school that offers the A to G curriculum for every single student in the school who wants it, that has multiple AP courses, that teaches six or seven different foreign languages, yet in the same district, you have a school that is failing
How do you hold the district accountable for the failure of that school in isolation if you are not providing some way for schools to be compared and so that parents can understand not just whether or not my school is making gains or whether the students in the school my child is attending is making gains,
but is the district being held accountable for the difference of the performance of that school when you compare it just with schools within the district?
Because let me be real clear, in districts where that kind of glaring achievement is happening, it is because the district has made a conscious decision to spend money differently for one school program than they do for another school program, and to do planning for improving in that school differently.
So, they want to understand how is the data going to hold the district accountable to do something different for the school that's not doing well relative just to the performance of other schools in their district, let alone if we figure out some way to compare schools in other districts.
So, that's what I heard.
But then, when we talk about the fact that equity is on the table,
Putting equity on the table is not the same as discussing race.
And we have to be very careful that we start not trying to quantify in this accountability system other cultural factors, those things that I heard the school psychologists say are protective and resilient factors that we currently don't quantify.
Whether the parents had the level of education of the parents,
the engagement of parents, gender and ethnicity.
Those don't become racial issues.
Those become racist issues.
So we have to be very careful how we talk about that kind of data and how we choose to quantify or weight it in this system because that's not what we asked the growth model to do.
That's not currently what the statute has tasked us to do.
And even though this may be a conversation of merit, it's also rife with peril because we don't have the current expertise or the statistical models to build into a state accountability system to make a conversation like that work.
So equity and racial issues and race issues are several different factors that were not intended
for us, that's a rabbit hole we really weren't intended to go down.
But in looking at that, I do want to say that there is a particular group that even though they are, according to the data, one of the best performing subgroups, we do have within that community many different communities that are saying we do need to disaggregate data about them.
And I'm talking particularly about Asian students.
We have a lot of communities that represent many different subcultures and subgroups of Asian students who are saying their students disappear in this statewide data when Asian students are clustered as a monolith into one subgroup and into one category.
So if we're going to have a conversation not about whether it's income level or not about whether it's race
or whether the parents have attained a certain high school education or a certain education level, we do need to think about how the growth model serves that particular community or does a disservice to that community by painting all the students we place into that subgroup with one broad stroke, because they have raised some issues that are very valid,
about the differences in performance among those students and it's not about ethnicity or even culture, it's even down to the language that those students speak and the differences in the language development needs that those students have in that subgroup.
But again, we're not tasked to do that and we're not asked to do that.
So I think it's great that we have come to a point
where we are creating a mental model about how this system can work because it's been two years in the making and every single time I come to the board meeting, I leave with a different idea about what we're going to attempt to do.
But today, I actually have and I heard among all the stakeholders some very concrete concerns, not about just the construction of what's reported and what the public sees as a consumer, but what the outcome or what the information
that the report should give.
So I'm hoping, rather than getting into the weeds about how we develop the colors and how the report finally looks from the graphic artist standard, but that we think about when the public begins to use and see this, that we have some ways of differentiating
the kind of data outcomes or the kind of data information they're asking the system to report.
So to recap, we have, we're at the cusp of creating this growth model, and I think it is important for us to be clear on what we're asking the growth model to do, and that we can form our recommendations for adding new data points to that growth model based on that.
And so at this point, I also have to concur with Board Member Burr, based on what we have currently said the growth model is supposed to do, I do not believe adding back in the grade 11-S back in the way that you've asked for it is compatible with the growth model that we said we wanted to develop.
So if there's something different we need to do, then we actually need to have some people explain to us what a growth model is and how it can operate.
Second point, it's not just creating the report.
It's not just building the engine.
It's looking at what the output is going to be.
So now that you're done building the engine and now that you've identified what the component parts are, what's it going to look like?
So what do I get to enjoy about it?
That's what parents came here today and really said.
They weren't just saying, the reason why they asked for a single composite number is because they don't trust that the information that's being presented to them will be given back to them in a consumable way.
So it's not just enough to have a growth model that works, to have a perfect design that works, but to give it to them in a consumable way.
And then finally, in talking about the charter schools and the Williams piece, I seem to recall when we first started looking at how to incorporate the Williams elements, my specific question was, well, why are we calling them the Williams elements?
Because there are some things that would be common in the intent of what we're trying to do with the LCAP rubric.
that clearly should be a requirement for all schools.
So why are we going to list them in the group of eight state priorities as the Williams elements knowing clearly there's a subset of schools that are not required to meet those requirements?
Why are we not parsing out and identifying all of those common elements?
So I understand you took the step of adding the parenthetical if applicable, but that was not the motion I voted for.
And so I want to be real clear that it is a change from the motion that was originally adopted.
If that's what the motion is today, that's not the motion I originally voted for.
So I need some clarification about what that parenthetical, if applicable, means.
Because I'm very concerned now that it is different from what I thought I was voting for when we originally had this conversation.
OK, so I'll make two brief comments.
Olivia.
Oh, Olivia.
First of all I just want to say thank you to everyone who voiced their opinions today.
It really means a lot as a student to hear so many people from all over the state come and voice their opinions about how to make my education and all the other students education in California better so I really appreciate that.
Speaking about the 11th grade testing, because I personally have taken those tests and I feel sort of hesitant about wanting to place so much importance on it and putting it, definitely putting it into two indexes if that's what we decide to do.
Because the test is unlike any other test that I've ever had to take during school.
By placing so much importance on the single test and by ranking high schools a large majority of the, or not a majority, but a large percentage of the accountability index would be based off of this, there's really no practice that I was able to have or that any student was able to have in order to take the test.
The first time that we saw it was the first time that we actually took it.
So I believe that if it's so important, we should be placing more preparation into it.
And also, in addition to letting the students know how important it is, when we came in to take the test, it felt just like, like any other thing.
And our teachers were even sort of
hesitant that it was taking so much time away from the education that they were trying to teach us.
So if this is so important, we should be allowing, we should be telling students exactly how important it is and the fact that they need to take this very seriously if it's going to be such a large component of how their schools are going to be graded.
Okay, good point.
So I just have two comments and nothing for your list, but tomorrow we will hear more about the CAS scores.
We had testimony from Linda Kaminsky, who is superintendent in San Gabriel Valley.
Pardon?
Azusa in the San Gabriel Valley.
And I agree with virtually every word she said.
Now that we're getting more years of data, we need to get beyond the NCLB trap of everything is what level you're at.
And that it's all about how many are over level three and no interest at all in how people are doing at lower levels and making gains.
So we need to move beyond NCLB thinking, and the scale scores are one possible way to do that.
The CDE has been working on this.
Carrick and Michelle have been working on this.
So I think that's something we need to really keep in mind, that we need a much more robust use of these assessments.
I mean, we paid, the U.S.
government paid $180 million to formulate them,
They're very, very good and what are we getting?
Four levels.
I mean, you know, so we need to move beyond this and we're on the same page with CDE on that.
Again, my biggest comment is and I think we'll be able to take up some of this in later on or in the federal aid.
A very brilliant Harvard professor who I worked with over the years was Richard Elmore and he had a law
which I agree with.
Elmore's law is as you ratchet up accountability, you have to ratchet up the capacity of schools and districts to meet that accountability.
The theory of action today in this discussion on change is it's all about accountability.
That's the only way we're going to help schools and somehow Carl Cohn's going to be a magician and be able to prepare teachers that are struggling with math overnight.
So this is one
a thing in your arsenal, accountability.
We have never talked on this board, just because we're overwhelmed with accountability, about our strategy for building capacity.
We laid out 1.2 million or 4 million
for Common Core.
We talked about the need for teachers now.
I think our results clearly show we have some major problems in mathematics.
I don't think tough-edged accountability is going to transform overnight the account of the ability of elementary teachers to teach mathematics.
So the board, at some point, has to move from the back end of its education policy to the front end in capacity.
And so you have in... that, I think, is something we need to... because our agenda, to me, is imbalanced, really.
And it's not our fault and it isn't the fault of... it's just the way we have had to schedule things.
But I don't want to lose track of this balance.
The federal law, I think, gives us some opportunities to work again on this capacity building.
And I think that's one of the strategic issues we'll want to take up in that.
So those are comments, not questions.
So I don't know how you're going to organize your response, but here it is.
So here's your list, yeah.
We have some answers and some additional questions, but we'll start with Glenn.
Good afternoon board members, Glenn Price, Chief Deputy.
I wanted to briefly comment on three of the items that came up in comments and your questions.
One is the school conditions and climate work group, two would be the statements of model practice, and three being the issue of plan alignment.
First of all, on the school conditions and climate work group, I want to really thank you for charging the department with forming this group and let you know that I have the honor of being the lead facilitator for the group.
And it's been really exciting work so far as we've worked with our department staff, with state board staff, and we've been supported by WestEd as well.
And we've been able to bring together a lot of great resources to support the work.
As you can imagine, there's been a tremendous amount of interest from people around the state wanting to get involved in the work of the School Conditions and Climate Work Group.
And we're working hard to maximize engagement and speed and product at the same time.
So we're looking at kind of three levels of engagement in the work group.
One level is a small working group of 11 people that we're putting together to do some of the heavy lifting on analyzing the research that you've charged us with.
At a second tier, we're going to be putting together a list of all the people that have contacted us and responded to be a resource team for the work that we can go out to with requests for support going forward for the work group.
And then thirdly, we're going to be doing a series of in-person stakeholder meetings, which will be basically an open invitation for anyone in the state who would like to come in and help support this work.
different tiers of work going forward and very exciting so far.
And I think we're working towards the deadline of wanting to come back to you in January 2017.
So for your January meeting, we want to be able to come back to you with some recommendations around school conditions and climate, which clearly is a really critical part of the accountability and continuous improvement system going forward.
So that's school conditions and climate work group.
On the statements of model practice, you may recall that I've spoken a couple times about this LCAP support team that we put together inside of the Department of Education, which is a horizontal team that draws from all of our divisions to think about how we can best be reorganizing to support the work in LCFF and the development, implementation, and evaluation of local control and accountability plans.
The members of that team, as one of their tasks, have been tasked with the curation of high quality resources in relationship to the priority where they have expertise in.
So they've been putting that together, reviewing those resources, and we want to make them available in relationship to the statements of model practice.
The other work that they're doing, and this will transform, obviously, as we move forward with the critical work of transforming and bringing to you the new LCAP template,
in November is looking around the state and finding samples of excellence in practice within existing LCAPs in relationship to priorities.
So we'll be able to, as part of the statements of model practice, articulate what is the model practice that we're shooting for, what are some curated resources that we can make available that would help support the realization of that model practice, and how are some people around the state doing that would be some of the key resources that we're
we're working on to be making available there as part of the statement.
So Board Member Strauss and everyone, we anticipate very quickly being able to come back with a memo to you about how that work is progressing and make that so you can provide input and guidance to us as we move along.
On plan integration, we've talked about that quite a bit, and I'm glad Brooks is in the room because I know he's promised to throw us a ticker tape parade if we are successful in integrating the LEA plan and the LCAP.
People around the state are very excited about that possibility, and I just wanted to recall for all of us that when the Christmas miracle occurred and ESSA was adopted and signed by the President, and then the Department of Education asked for states that didn't currently have waivers
to come in with a transition plan about how to move beyond the implementation of SES.
California responded, and as part of that transition plan, we indicated that moving forward, the LEA plan would be our existing LCAP, the State of California's LCAP, plus the consolidated application.
So we're already having
a level of integration happening in the state.
Meanwhile, staff is working hard on the details of how we can move that forward in a more comprehensive and elegant way as we think about this new LCAP template that we're working on and how that can then become and serve the purposes of a vibrant LEA plan for the state.
So that's kind of a little status report on those three areas, school conditions and climate work group.
plan alignment, and statements of model practice.
I don't know if there's further questions or comments or guidance.
Okay.
So let me start with just a comment on the summative rating.
I think what we clearly heard this morning to this afternoon is that there needs to be some clarity.
It needs to be a system that is easily read and understood.
The one concern that I heard in those comments
was the use of that summative rating for comparison purposes, which pulled it right back to I want a single indicator, number, color, whatever it is, so that I can compare it to another one
school that has a single composite number or again kind of simplifying the whole process and simple is not necessarily good as member holiday said so um but i think the takeaway is we need to make it clear and understandable and um and usable for parents and i think that that can be done with or without a summative rating
When it comes to 11th grade test scores, let me start by saying that the comments that Member Burr and Member Rucker both said are accurate in terms of growth models and how we're going to use it in the future, what we're going to do with our grades three through eight.
It's not that a growth model is not possible to do with 11th grade.
but the most recent score is from 8th grade.
So the students who took it for the first time in 8th grade then just took it for a second time in 9th grade.
So they'll still have to take it as 10th graders and then as 11th graders before we can compare their scores from 8th grade to 11th grade in terms of a cohort growth model.
But I have brought with me today
Tony Alpert from Smarter Balanced.
I thought it might be helpful to bring him up and have him talk just a little bit about what states in general are doing about these growth models specifically and maybe specifically what they're doing between eighth grade and 11th grade or what their plans are in the future just to give you a comparison of where we are versus some other states and what we should be doing and what we should be thinking about
between now and implementing a growth model.
So, Tony Albert.
Hello.
For the record, Tony Albert, Executive Director of Smarter Balanced.
So, every state is struggling with this issue.
They're struggling with how to create an accountability system that meets their policy objectives,
describes these complex systems, educational systems, in an easy-to-understand manner for something that isn't easy to understand, and trying to incorporate a lot of different data elements around status as well as growth.
And so, California is not unique in that regard.
What the consortium has tried to do is provide some comprehensive technical assistance in assisting the departments of education in having conversations with boards such as your own so that they can start chipping away at some of the core decisions.
So for instance, a critical decision regarding a growth model is what growth is expected for students who have already met or exceeded the achievement standard.
That's pretty significant.
That is a very significant policy decision about the role of the state in setting expectations for students who are already high achieving and it has implications for accountability systems and the emphasis of instruction and it's a very goal driven
critical issue, a core issue around a growth model, and that's something that a policy board really needs to establish.
And there's lots of different ways that growth models can address a core issue like that, and there isn't, as far as we know, there isn't a right answer, that there's some answers that may be more preferable than others.
There may be some wrong answers, but we don't know of any right answers yet.
Helping the departments of education across the nation understand some of those critical levers, and I believe ETS in their presentation talked about some of those different levers that the board might use to achieve their policy objectives.
And, as Mike described, states are trying to broaden their use of these assessment scores to include scale scores in addition to achievement levels, and that can be part of the measurement properties.
It can also be part of the reporting properties.
So those are some different decisions that I think you're also struggling with, is that you can have a model that uses some different metrics.
You can also report that in tabular form, in graphical form.
So very complex issues that everyone is struggling with.
So I can answer any specific questions that you have about that, but at least wanted to give you that context, and hopefully you find it helpful.
Yeah, go ahead.
So the actual decision about standards or performance cut points for test scores really has been deferred to November, as I recall.
I'm looking at Dave, right?
So we're going to have this conversation in a lot more detail when we make that decision in November.
So I appreciate the initial information, but I think we're going to kind of, we're sort of on overload, I'm guessing, at the moment.
So we can have that conversation in more detail.
But I think that what I heard a lot of other people concerned with is if we were to move forward with our motion, the motion would have grade 11 be counted in the college and career indicator right now.
So that's just for people who raised concerns before.
My personal feeling is we could take action on it the way it is now, then in November if we come back and go, no, there really is a way and it makes sense to do it both ways, we could modify going forward.
But we would satisfy needing to adopt the standards that we need to and the evaluation rubrics today in order to meet our deadline.
So just for clarification.
Yeah, go ahead.
The current motion does include cut scores though for progress of English learners, high school graduation and college and career readiness.
The only ones for November would be test scores, right?
But in the motion we don't have anything about when to revisit the cut scores.
I think that again theoretically as people get more comfortable with the indicators and they start aligning their resources, perhaps some of these cut scores will see them change a bit.
And so at what point do we come back
for this and for the SBAC cut scores and revisit those and see is this still an appropriate cut score that's not included in this motion.
We're part of a consortium so I think a consortium should answer.
As part of the direction to staff let's see if I can
Yeah on the motion number six here that says approve the proposed annual process for state board to review the evaluation rubrics this sort of goes to member Ting's comment earlier that needs to be more elaborated
But the idea on that is that came up really at a prior meeting, the capacity for the board, particularly in these first years of implementation, as more data comes in, as there's a sense from the field, particularly this first year, as they're using the rubrics, the design of determining, for example, a growth model,
I mean that would be on an annual basis that would need to be more elaborated as to what the process would be.
That's a perfect example of how that needs to occur initially because we know chronic absenteeism will be coming online.
So it's those sorts of ways from the board's perspective this first few years and then ongoing
And I think there was a clarification needed from even some of the earlier discussion.
It doesn't necessarily mean things will change every year.
That would not be productive for anyone.
But the capacity, particularly initially and as we're learning, to try to really map that out in a more deliberate way and that we will have much more data.
So I hope that.
Yes.
And as far as the cut scores for Smarter Balanced, the review of those, the level scores, because that's part of a consortium, really.
Go ahead.
Right.
So in a year, university systems like CSU will have the first comprehensive set of data regarding the relationship between students' performance in high school and their performance in the first year in college.
That's going to be critical data that we'll use to evaluate the degree to which the achievement levels that educators set going from grade three up set a consistent and monotonic relationship towards college and career readiness, that they're valid, that they meet the objectives of predicting who is ready.
Thank you, Member Rucker.
That they do represent what we believe they represent.
That students are ready or on track to be ready for college and career readiness.
So, the consortium will be releasing an RFP for a contractor to help us develop criteria for that decision-making, identify the data elements that would go into that, and then the consortium, the group of states together, will make the decision about to what extent do we want to revisit any of the achievement levels.
And then members individually have the choice of what to do with the consortium's recommended cut scores.
So the state board in many states have the responsibility for adopting cut scores within each state.
Other issues now that people want to, did you run down your list?
Do you have more on the list?
I'd like them to get through there.
They're done with their list?
okay go ahead i'm just trying to finish off the list but as it relates to california's decision or autonomy to adjust accept or reject the consortium scores it is in our statute that we are accepting the consortium's recommendation we do not have that autonomy to make that adjustment it's in our statute when ab484
was signed into law, it was made very clear in the statute California does not have the autonomy that other consortium states have to adjust or to change the recommendation from the consortium.
I'll take a couple specifically related to the inclusion of grade 11 scores in the college and career indicator.
While that's part of the measure for college and career readiness in the system, a reminder, those 11th grade scores are public information.
Districts will be reporting those, using those to help guide what's happening in their communities.
while the discussion you brought up still needs to be explored a little further, it's not as if, as a standalone measure for 11th grade progress, that that's not information that will be just missing in action, so to speak.
Secondly, I wanted to help clarify I think what member Strauss was saying on the consideration for developing the initial look at the cut points for the college and career indicator, the use of the graduation cohort
as the measure for looking at the 13-14 year CST and EAP scores that are included in the packet both at the July meeting and here as to how to think about the career and college readiness indicator.
The
point of looking at the test scores a little bit differently and discussing this with the department staff is to come back in November with the smarter to kind of decouple this notion that it only can be cohort graduation
element to determine the CCI.
While that has been the pattern in the past, the hope would be that moving forward there could be some exploration of the data around smarter balance scores
run for grade 11 and take a look at what happens with students in the picture of whether they're college and career ready across the dimensions that we've included.
So we've had several discussions with Carrick's team to think about that a little bit differently in preparation for looking at the data a little bit differently.
because graduation rate is already a single indicator and the need to look a little differently at grade 11 in the context of CCI would be helpful moving forward.
I wanted to talk a little bit about the technical assistance.
Just a real quick question on the 11th grade score.
So it could be that it's in the second page.
So in the web version of it, if you clicked on College Career Indicator, it would also give you what the 11th grade scores would and all that, right?
So it's easily, quickly accessible from that page, okay.
The technical assistance, I know we've had several conversations with CSESA, some of the county teams that were even here earlier, and I think the reminder about this being a local, state, and federal system, as again, board members in the local context,
Looking at a large number of red indicators in the context of our local communities, that part of the requirement is to share this information in community forums and to incorporate into the annual updates at the local level.
counties also in their support to districts.
While we have a chance this year to really work and learn from the data analysis, the degree to which there are still going to be some very hard questions that are going to need to be asked at the local level, along with counties who this provides them then with another context to be saying, well, gee, we see these are your actions and services in the context of your LCAP.
You have five red indicators here, and we're wondering how that's going to impact your revisions.
How is this data being shared?
I mean, even in this first year, however people are looking at this initial phase, the data is there, the information is there.
The importance of really taking a look at what that data is telling everyone, the counties are already gearing up for how they're thinking about that.
The California Collaborative as well, remember, is tasked also with providing the professional development and learning opportunities for using the rubrics.
Those are scheduled for early November across the state.
There are seven dates that will be notified for people.
So this also is an opportunity to help both understand how the rubrics work,
but their role really in communicating with your public and in trying to fold that information then into the annual update.
So I think we have a lot of opportunities this year, particularly for areas where there's large areas that indicate students are not reaching the level of success that they need to.
So did you want to take on a couple more?
Just a last comment on the growth models.
As I mentioned, we'll be bringing back to you something for your consideration as far as what you want to do, the reason for it, what we want out of those growth models.
We'll continue to communicate with our Smarter Balanced states in the consortium, as many of them who have an 11th grade assessment.
They will also be looking at this idea of comparing 8th grade to 11th grade and what kind of results that will give us.
Of course, we're two years away from that, but we'll be continuing to communicate with them on that, as well as we'll want to take these things to our technical design group and our practitioner's advisory group before coming to you with this idea of what we want out of a growth model.
I think the comment from Member Rucker and Member Williams about the disaggregation of data is a good reminder.
I think as a board, we have to feel comfortable about what level of that disaggregation is our responsibility, because I can tell you it goes way beyond just race.
It goes beyond language.
You know, when I was a school principal, I bused kids from three different communities and then had a group of kids that walked to school.
So I disaggregated the data.
by each of the communities, just to find out if there was something there that would make a difference in how we address students' needs.
So we just have to find our comfort level as to what is our responsibility versus what is a local responsibility for disaggregating that data.
And then I think, lastly, to circle back to the Williams discussion with charter schools, I think David Sapp has a comment.
So David Sapp, State Board staff.
I'm going to stand up if that's okay.
Just two quick legal clarifications on the student groups.
Those are also defined in statute that the board is implementing.
So Education Code 52052 defines the student groups that have to be addressed through the LCAP and also then reflected in the rubric.
So that's the sort of legislative framework the board's operating in on this question.
Specifically to Board Member Rucker's question about the Williams Settlement and Priority One,
This, again, is something that is spelled out in statute.
The actual priority area itself that the legislature adopted in 2013 defines the elements of that priority by cross-reference to the underlying Ed Code that implemented the Williams Settlement.
Those sections apply only to school districts, so charters are exempt from the operation of those statutes.
And that's been reflected in the LCAP instructions, so the actual wording of the proposed standard that's in the item for this meeting reflects the wording in the current LCAP instructions.
It's actually the reason why that wording was used here, to try to track.
But as I said earlier in responding to Board Member Williams' question, this is something I think in terms of the clarification around
how the level of detail in the LCAP instructions and in the rubrics, that's something that we want to take a closer look at and come back to the board in November with an update and any recommended additional action as appropriate.
So I'm not sure we answered all the questions, but, oh, did you have a further question?
All right, but we've taken notes and that was what I was hoping to say.
So I do have it on the screen.
You have it on the first page of your item as well.
I'm ready.
Before I make the motion, I neglected to acknowledge all of the hard work that WestEd has contributed to this effort.
So I didn't want to let that go by.
But with that, I would move the staff recommendation.
Okay, any further board discussion on the motion?
None.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, it is unanimous.
Yeah.
Ten large hands, one small.
Okay, before we take a break, the good news is we passed something that took three years to do.
And now we're through with item one.
But here's the bad news.
It is with great regret that I announce that Nancy Brownell will be leaving the State Board of Education office.
She'll leave in the end of September.
She has been a key staff working as a senior fellow since 2012.
She worked with CDE and SBE jointly on the Common Core implementation.
Whatever success we've had with that, she's been a significant factor in.
And as you know, she was transferred over to accountability by the executive director.
I wouldn't wish that on anybody.
So she went there, and we've seen the result of that today.
Nancy has accepted a new position as the Director for the Accrediting Commission for Schools, Western Association of Schools and Colleges, known as WASC, which accredits secondary schools and some elementary.
She worked there at WASC in 1994.
And one thing we hope and she will aspire to accomplish is integrating our accountability and LCAP systems with accreditation.
This has been a goal for a long time.
We're really picking up momentum.
This was one of the things in the governor's list in 2010, as he underwent accreditation, could we somehow consolidate this?
And so I think she'll bring that off.
So her last day will be September 30th.
Let's give Nancy a hand.
Thank you.
It's been an honor and a pleasure to work for you and our colleagues at WestEd, at the counties, at the department.
It's been a really interesting sort of end of my career almost.
And as I mentioned to my family and colleagues, as Frodo said to Samwise Gamgee's, I might have room for a little bit more before my professional journey.
And so my commendations to the board for the excellent work and the department in West Staten counties.
And it's been a terrific opportunity.
I know you'll carry on in great ways.
Nancy, what I love is that you're leaving to get away from this and Mike gives you an assignment to do when you're gone.
I also have a certificate for you.
The board will recess till 20 of 3.
which is the state ESSA plan.
This is the beginning, formal beginning of another long journey for the board on a major and complex and multifaceted issue.
So Chief Deputy Glenn Price will open up and give us some initial comments
to orient you on what we'll be hearing.
And I see this as an initial conversation by the board members.
We haven't really focused on this.
And so I think everything's on the table in terms of what you're interested in.
So Glenn, why don't you open up?
And then Barbara Murchison, who is leading the department's effort on putting the plan together, will also speak.
Well, thank you, President Kirsten.
And let me just first offer my congratulations as the first one back up here at the podium on the momentous decision that you just took.
It's really exciting for all of us and for the state of California.
We thank you so much.
And it feels like we're just going back to back with exciting items as we think about
this opportunity now to engage and think about our new ESSA state plan.
And as we're kind of reflecting on this a little bit, I wanted to just refresh our memories that actually it's been about 14 years since the Board of Education of the State of California, 2002, did a complete new state plan.
And when you think about that, and one of the reasons that I wanted to point it out is that
The ramifications of that plan adopted by that board in 2002 is going to play out over a period of 14 years.
So it's just to say that it's something that I think that we really want to be deliberate about.
reflective about, and just as you were very careful with the development and eventually the adoption of the first phase of the LCFF evaluation rubrics, that we take the same kind of deep approach with the ESSA state plan.
I want to really thank Barbara Murchison and her team for the amazing stakeholder engagement work that's gone on so far, and that work will continue.
And as we move forward, speaking of really wanting to be deliberate, getting out and continuing that kind of authentic stakeholder engagement work will be really important.
One of the things that I wanted to highlight, and I touched on it a little bit in my comments around the LCFF evaluation rubrics item that we just went through, it's just again to remind us and really to remind those people who are in LEAs and school districts around our state,
that with the adoption of the ESSA transition plan that this board did is that you basically said to districts that their LCAP plus their consolidated application really is meeting the requirements now of their LEA plan.
So the plan that they need to be doing in relationship to their ESSA requirements and
and funding is covered by those two elements and I would ask you to maybe as you're thinking about the future to be continuing to think about how we would be continuing to consolidate and integrate those two plans.
In addition to the possibility of looking at the single plan for student achievement and how that could possibly be rolled together again as part of a
consolidated integrated plan so we don't and aren't asking our our LEAs around the state to be working on a bunch of different plans with the same people covering some of the same topics but in in different formats.
The other this quick technical item that I wanted to point out for the board before I pose a couple of focus questions to you and and bring up Barbara is really going to present the majority of the material here is that
the board will have a critical decision coming up around when to submit the the ESSA state plan and just to highlight that the United States Department of Education has provided two dates that that could happen by.
The first would be in March and the second would be in July of 2017 so just for you to keep that in mind as you as you move forward here.
So let me just
As you think about and listen to Barbara, and she's got a great amount of information to present, building on a huge amount of work that's been done to date, I would like to ask you, I know it'll be a temptation to really get down into some kind of weedy technical questions, and we definitely at some point want to get into those.
But as President Kirst indicated, we're at a point right now where we really need some pretty deep thinking from the board around the ESSA State Plan, and we'd like you to keep these three focus questions in mind as you're listening to the information today.
First of all, what overall policy directions do you feel should drive ESSA planning?
What are the policies that you'd like to see really furthered by ESSA?
Are we moving with this in terms of the policy objectives that we'd like to achieve as the state of California?
So thinking about those policy objectives.
And then some deep thinking if possible around what are some of the significant statewide programmatic opportunities and priorities that should drive the ESSA plan.
And some of those I think were emerged from our previous discussion around the kinds of capacity building that we need in the state of California.
And then, as we think about the policy and then the programs that will help to drive that policy and realize those policy objectives, how should we be proceeding with the planning and approval process?
And we obviously talked about that a little bit in terms of aligning our LEA planning and LCAP work.
But what are the kinds of planning and approval processes that you'd like to see that would really help to defer to those priorities?
So policy directions, if you could keep that in mind, key programmatic opportunities, and mechanically, how is this going to work going forward?
So with that in mind, I'd like to turn the mic over to Barbara Murchison.
And as she's coming up, just really on behalf of all of us, just thank her and Joy and her team for all the tremendous work that's gone on so far.
You've seen it in the item that's before you, but as deep as that is, that's just the tip of the iceberg on the great work that's been accomplished to date.
So, Barbara?
Thank you, Chief Deputy Price.
Good afternoon, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, board members.
I am Barbara Murchison, S.S.
State lead here at the department.
The purpose of this item is to provide you and the public with an update regarding the progress and the development of the Every Student Succeeds Act, or S.S.
State Plan.
This is an information item, and the CDE recommends that the board take action as necessary and appropriate.
Before we talk about the plan, I want to spend a few minutes providing you with a brief update around the status of the ESSA proposed regulations.
The proposed regulations for accountability, data reporting, and state plans were published in the Federal Register back May 31st, and the public had until August 1st to comment on those.
President Kirsten, Superintendent Torlakson submitted a joint letter in response to those regs.
The letter has been made available as an August memorandum.
So that is available to both you and the public.
EDU has received more than 21,000 comments in response to those proposed regulations.
The proposed regulations for assessment and innovative assessment pilots were published in the Federal Register on July 11th, and the 60-day public comment period closes tomorrow, September 9th.
We anticipate that a joint response regarding the assessment regulations will be submitted tomorrow, and Director Senter will be able to provide information regarding the letter during her presentation tomorrow morning.
Earlier this week, I think they're timing the release of these proposed regulations with your board meetings.
Earlier this week, the proposed regulations for supplement not supplant were published in the Federal Register.
Recall that the negotiated rulemaking process for these regs was not successful, so there may be quite a few comments in response to those as well.
The public comment period for the supplement not-to-plant proposed regulations closes on November 7th.
So CDE staff is in the early stages of analyzing this new set of regulations to understand the potential impacts to California, and we expect to bring more information to you at the November meeting.
Anyone who's interested in all of those sets of regs, we have information and links available on our CDE SO webpage.
So we're not going to be able to finalize our ESSA state plan unless we have final regulations.
Given that our colleagues in Washington, D.C.
are going to need to address those 21,000 comments on the first set, and given that the public comment period for supplement not supplant doesn't even close until November 7th, we've updated our draft plan development timeline.
And here we have it before you.
Recall, every time I show this timeline, I usually put a draft in the front and an asterisk in the back.
I've removed the draft in the front just to feel a little more like we're getting to where we might be, but there's still an asterisk that says that this timeline is subject to change pending board feedback and regulations from ED.
We think this new timeline will provide more time for our friends back in Washington, D.C.
to finish the work of preparing final regulations, and also will provide us with some good time to engage stakeholders, including the Practitioners Advisory Group, in our plan development process.
So you can see we actually have
It mapped out so that we can systematically go to the CPAG, bring them information to provide feedback back to you.
It works out pretty nicely.
You can see on March 6th, Chief Deputy Price mentioned there were two days for submission of state plans in the proposed regulations.
That also could change.
The first opportunity to submit plans to the U.S.
Department of Education is March 6th, and then there's another opportunity on March 9th.
I mean, sorry, July 3rd.
March 9th, what's happening then?
Must be a special day somewhere.
So, as I said, the submission of state plan deadlines are in the proposed recs.
We have quarterly calls with our colleagues back at the Department of Education.
We had one last week.
And we said, hey, given that we don't even have final regs and are not likely to have them for a while, and given that we really want to have some authentic stakeholder engagement with our final plan, which has to be at least 30 days, how are you thinking that states are going to submit things in March 6?
NED, whenever we talk to them, they're very careful about not
really definitively answering anything.
But they did say, they acknowledged that they'd received many, many comments on the timelines associated with their proposed regs, and they know that states are grappling with this question about how are we going to submit a plan based on final regs if we don't have final regs.
They're also going to build out a template
based on final regs that we'll need to.
So there are a lot of pieces still in the air.
And they acknowledged that one of the things that they are looking at very closely as they review the comments and think about what changes to make in the final regulations is the timeline for submission of state plans.
So again, as I've been saying every time I've been up here in the last few months,
We're just going to move forward doing the best we can with the information that we have.
But here's our new timeline that's looking at a March provisional approval.
Do you know of any other states that are going to go in March?
Did the call reveal what states are feeling ready and having enough time and what states aren't?
So yeah, ED didn't talk to us about other states.
We are going to a big ESSA planning meeting that's being facilitated by CCSSO next week.
So we'll learn more just this morning on Twitter.
I noticed that Arizona on Twitter, I noticed that Arizona had made its draft plan available for its public review just yesterday.
So I think every state is trying to figure out, I think,
I don't knowyou know, California is in a very different place than a lot of other states.
A lot of states are just now trying to figure out a new accountability system that they're going to have to do onbased on proposed regs.
We've been working on our accountability system for years, so we'rebut I think part of the California way is taking the time to engage stakeholders and move forward thoughtfully and carefully, so other states may be doing what's right for them, but I think we'll just need to do what's right for us.
We'll know more next week about what all the other states are doing.
Let's shift from the regulations and the timelines and move on to ESSA and the Consolidated State Plan.
First of all, I want you to be assured that it is not my intention to cover every detail included in that 91-page item.
Okay.
Just so you know.
Our goal in constructing the item was to respond to the board's request for more detailed information regarding ESSA consolidated plan requirements and where the state stands relative to those requirements.
We also really wanted to provide you with some starting points for a conversation around the use of funds and how ESSA can supplement the work that's already underway in California.
But most importantly, we really want to hear from you your thoughts about overall policy directions that will guide our next steps and make sure that our plan development work is consistent with your collective vision for how the federal pieces work with the state pieces.
So I'm going to go way back because we found this picture and we really like this picture.
That is a picture of Lyndon B. Johnson signing the original Elementary and Secondary Education Act back in April of 1965.
He is sitting in front of his very first school with his very first teacher.
Come on, how do you?
And, you know, there's a quote from President Johnson there, no measure I have signed or will ever sign means more to the future of America.
So the ESEA has always been focused on equity.
Among other things, the original ESEA provided funds to districts serving low-income students, funds for students with disabilities, funds for bilingual education, and funds to provide technical assistance to rural schools.
The ESEA has been reauthorized a number of times since 1965 with new requirements and programs being added as the law has evolved.
As you can see from the slide, the last reauthorization was No Child Left Behind in 2001.
Many in the education community were starting to wonder if the law would ever be reauthorized and then
President Obama signed the ESSA on December 10, 2015.
As you can see by his quote, ESSA remains, first and foremost, a law designed to promote equity.
And President Obama said, with this bill, we reaffirm that fundamentally, American ideal, that every child, regardless of race, income, background, zip code where they live, deserves the chance to make of their lives what they will.
So I won't go into much detail about what is new in ESSA because we've talked about this, but the new reauthorization provides much more authority and responsibility to states.
We have the opportunity to create that integrated local, state, and federal accountability and continuous improvement system.
And we also have the opportunity, after 14 years of No Child Left Behind, to examine our current practice and leverage the law to support current state priorities.
So there are many programs within the ESSA.
All of them are provided in attachment one of the item.
A subset of the ESSA programs may be included in the consolidated state plan.
These programs are indicated with an asterisk in the document and are listed on this slide.
Many of the programs not included in the Consolidated State Plan are competitive grant programs, like Title II, Part B, and Title IV, Part C. Others, like several Title IV programs and the Title VI, are programs for which the state educational agency is not eligible.
Although we could choose to develop separate plans for each of the ESSA programs, given the state's work to build a single coherent system that serves all students, it makes sense for California to develop and submit a consolidated state plan that describes our intentions across programs.
Unless the board would prefer to take a different direction, all future references to the ESSA state plan really refer to the consolidated state plan.
So when we talk about the ESSA state plan, we're talking about all of these programs.
So since the item posted last week, we received some feedback that many of the programs included in the consolidated state plan may not have been previously brought to the board for approval.
So we went on a little bit of a detective investigation hunt.
Some of you may remember, you may even have the consolidated application from 2002.
So we went and found this.
You can find it in the internet archives, the CDE webpage archives.
It's not really posted anymore, but if you have friends in the technology services division, they will make it available to you.
And on page five of this document, which we cross-checked just last week to make sure, you can see that the board-approved consolidated application contains
Information regarding all the programs listed on this slide, with just a couple of exceptions, the Education for Homeless Children and Youth Program Plan was approved as a standalone NCLB plan, also in 2002, and then Title IV, Part A, used to focus on safe and drug-free schools and communities, and many of these elements have been folded into the new Title IV Student Support and Academic Enrichment Grants.
So, even though you may not have seen them, predecessors 14 years ago did see plans for each of these programs.
For the most part, many of the programs listed on this slide have been administered successfully by the department in accordance with federal expectations, so they haven't really needed to come to the state board.
They haven't had problems that caused them to come here.
The development of the ESSA state plan provides us with an opportunity to take a look at how those programs are being administered and make any adjustments as appropriate.
So, part 299 subpart G of the proposed regulations outlines state plan requirements.
Attachment 2 of the item goes into quite a bit of detail regarding these requirements.
Now, the requirements that are in Attachment 2 are the ones that are available to us as part of the proposed regulations.
So everything in Attachment 2 is not a final requirement.
It is just the best we know at this time around what the expectations are for the plan.
The document was informed by a large number of staff working in program offices all across the department and reflects our current understanding of where the state stands in relation to these various proposed requirements.
I want to be very, very clear about the color coding and our intentions.
None of the contents, green, yellow,
any color, have been definitively decided.
Nothing's definitively decided.
We won't have a final plan until March, and we anticipate that that plan will be informed by your feedback today and at future board meetings, will be informed by a variety of stakeholder input, and will be informed by additional information from ED.
But some of the elements are more clearly ready
for inclusion in the draft plan than others.
Many of the elements shaded green and Mark decided were approved well before ESSA was signed.
For example, over the years, many decisions have been made around California's new system of standards and assessments.
So those are marked green.
We've had a lot of conversations.
If we want to open that up again and talk more about standards and assessments, we can, but the green just gives us a sense that we've spent a lot of time on that and feel pretty solid on California's direction with that.
Others were made in the context of California's Educator Equity Plan, which was approved by the board last July.
So the document is color-coded to provide a general sense of where we are relative to the requirements.
It is not comprehensive and does not provide precise information regarding the status of each requirement.
And as you can imagine, in process means a lot of different things to different people.
There can be a very fine line between in process and not yet decided.
So really it was just color coded to provide the board and the general public a sense of where we think we stand in relation to those proposed requirements.
Many of the elements shaded yellow are evolving through the development of the LCFF evaluation rubrics.
And in general, for elements shaded green or yellow, what will be included in the plan that we are bringing to you in November is relatively clear.
Elements shaded orange are underway, which means some deliberation has occurred, but these will really require additional discussion and direction.
And then there are a few elements that are shaded red.
And those will really require final regulations before being decided.
So for most of those, like the summative rating, the weighting of indicators, the reporting of per-pupil expenditures, the state knows how it would prefer to proceed, but our preference is not necessarily consistent with the proposed regulations.
Since the item posted, we did receive some feedback that it is missing a certain grain size or level of detail.
or that something that is green should really be yellow.
And again, this is a document that's intended to provide a general overview of plan requirements.
The draft plan that is coming to you in November will include much more detail.
It will not be color coded.
Don't get attached to the colors.
And I don't really recommend that board members spend a lot of time discussing the specific elements in this 30-page chart.
However, if there are elements that are inconsistent with your understanding, or you would really like to be provided more information regarding a specific requirement or program,
We would really appreciate that feedback today.
Again, we'll be bringing you successive iterations of the plan in November, January, and March.
All plan content are subject to change at your discretion at any time.
So, attachment three provides some starting points for board discussion regarding opportunities in the ESSA to supplement work already underway in California.
Before we look more specifically at these opportunities, there are a couple of fundamentals that we want to consider.
First of all, federal funds are supplemental.
I think it's really important if the state is already funding something with state funds or local funds, it's not appropriate use of federal funds to spend the money in the same way, as the funds are intended to improve outcomes for disadvantaged students in addition to not in place of state investments.
Per board member request, we have provided a great deal of fiscal information in this item.
It's important to keep in mind that these are preliminary estimates.
Although we don't anticipate any significant departures from these estimates, we do not yet have a federal budget, and we don't anticipate that we will have one until after the election in November.
The estimates in the item and in this presentation are provided for planning purposes and are subject to change.
So if you look at the graphic on this slide, you can see the vast majority of California education funding comes from state and local funds.
The little green band of supplemental money up at the top represents federal funds, about $8 billion per year, of which approximately $2 billion is ESSA funding.
So another really important consideration as we think about use of federal funds is that that's to provide states with the opportunity to think kind of big across programs and use resources to support the larger state vision.
So with the transition to LCFF, California LEAs have been asked to identify needs, set goals in collaboration with their communities, and then allocate resources to support attainment of those goals.
With ESSA, states now have kind of a similar opportunity to think about our vision and goals first and then dedicate our federal resources across programs to achieving those goals.
Our first responsibility is to administer the funds to LEAs and provide the technical assistance and support as needed to ensure appropriate use, but we do have an opportunity to look beyond the silos
and create a set of supplemental programs that's more holistic and coherent.
As you can see from this slide, ED has been very explicit about this opportunity.
The proposed regulation cite, we seek to improve teaching and learning by encouraging greater cross-program coordination, planning, and service delivery, provide greater flexibility to state and local authorities through consolidated plans and reporting,
and enhance the integration of programs under the ESEA as amended by the ESSA with state and local programs.
So that's kind of exciting.
It gives us the opportunity to think beyond, here's what we do for Title I, here's what we do for Title II, and think about how could we creatively use all of those resources in ways to achieve our goals.
So this will require states to consult with diverse stakeholders at multiple points during the design, development, and implementation of our plan.
This spring, CDE staff, in partnership with our colleagues at the Comprehensive Center and five county offices of education, conducted six weeks of concerted stakeholder outreach activities.
During this time, we conducted two webinars, six regional meetings, and a survey.
400 people participated in the two ESSA webinars, and you can see in the little green chart
who was engaged in that webinar, where they are from, who they affiliate themselves with, county offices, curriculum coordinators, district administrators, school administrators, teachers, et cetera.
We hosted or co-hosted six ESSA regional stakeholder meetings.
More than 300 people participated in those.
And again, a cross-section of folks from across various stakeholder groups.
And there's a little map that shows we've traveled the state far and wide.
And then for our SS stakeholder survey, we had 276 people participate.
So some of those stakeholders may have participated in a couple of different opportunities, but overall, that's nearly 1,000 points of contact with diverse stakeholders.
Member Strauss joined us for the Los Angeles regional meeting and can attest to the fact that stakeholders had a lot of suggestions and requests.
Our colleagues at the Comprehensive Center took on the heroic task of analyzing and organizing all of those points of feedback.
For each of those people, there were multiple points of feedback.
In general, we got a lot of different kinds of feedback, but the top five things we heard about
which I think are interesting, we received 209 comments regarding best practices, resources, guidance, and definitions.
Stakeholders really want access to vetted resources of all kinds.
They want curricular resources to support instruction.
They want resources such as the Standards for Model Practice, the ones that would be associated with how do we improve our schools.
They want all kinds of resources, but they don't want just any resources.
They want vetted resources, because I think they know they can find all kinds of resources.
So that was what we heard the most about.
We received 206 comments about the accountability system.
There's good news there.
Stakeholders were generally very supportive of this new accountability system, supportive of the multiple measures, and very supportive of the state's intention to align state and federal requirements and plans.
So that's good.
We received a lot of comments around professional learning and technical assistance and a lot of comments around educator excellence.
Stakeholders really would like to see more state-supported professional learning opportunities.
And then we received another 144 comments about the importance of a well-rounded curriculum.
I think a lot of people are concerned or actually see ESSA as an opportunity to broaden the curriculum again after the unintended consequence of No Child Left Behind kind of narrowing the curriculum to people focusing on math and reading.
We heard from a lot of different folks.
The physical education community was out in force, school librarians,
the arts community, history civics folks, after-school providers, a really nice cross-section of people who really wanted to be a part of this public process and talk about the things that were important to them.
So the complete summary report, including about 75 pages of just raw data because we thought it'd be fun for folks to go find their comments, is available as an August information memorandum.
If you go, if you make the time to go to a meeting and share your comments or do a survey and share, it's nice to be able to see that they're actually there.
I think that's nice.
All of this feedback can be helpful to the board when we're thinking about overall direction of the plan.
So CDE staff has identified several opportunities within MIASA to leverage the priorities that you will establish.
First of all, there's a school improvement opportunity in Title I. There's a direct student services opportunity in Title I.
There's an opportunity to support principals and other school leaders in Title II.
There are state-level activity funds associated with Titles II, III, and IV.
We have the opportunity, everyone will need to submit a new LEA plan.
That's an opportunity for the state to reinforce state priorities.
And then, of course, the guidance that the department puts forth to help LEAs implement ESSA in their own local plans is another opportunity.
I'm going to go through them pretty quickly.
Section 6303 of the ESSA describes the 7% required set aside.
That money is to be used to provide technical assistance and supports to schools that have been identified for comprehensive and targeted support and improvement activities.
So 95% of that 7% must be subgranted to LEAs, either by a formula or on a competitive basis.
The formula grant would ensure that all the LEAs who are eligible for additional supports would receive additional resources, but a competitive grant would allow the state to target LEAs determined most likely to be successful based on their grant applications.
If the state decides to pursue the competitive grant option, it has the opportunity to design an RFA that would be aligned to the state priorities.
Section 6303B gives states the option to set aside an additional 3% of the LEA subgrant allocation for direct student services.
Allowable activities include credit recovery in support of advanced placement and international baccalaureate programs.
Although these activities are consistent with state priorities, the CDE would need to review and approve various programs and create a list of programs for which LEAs can choose.
But still, this is an opportunity for the state to let folks know these are state priorities.
Title II has a 3% allowable set-aside.
It would come to about $7 million a year.
The state could establish programs designed to improve the skills of principals and other leaders.
They could be used in a variety of ways, including recruitment and retention of school leaders.
new career paths to school leadership, development of high-quality professional learning programs, and the use of these funds, should the board decide to make use of this allowable set-aside, could also be used in a way to support state priorities.
And as I mentioned for Titles II, III, and IV, each one of those programs does come with some funding for state-level activities.
It's important to remember that for each of these programs, the administration of the funds, the distribution, monitoring, and providing technical assistance around appropriate use requires a significant part of the funds.
And attachment three provides some information around how these funds are currently used.
So Title II has the most discretionary state-level funding.
We currently use state-level funds to support the work of the California Subject Matter Project, provide statewide professional development for private school educators, and collect data and provide technical assistance to meet the educator equity requirements of the law.
There's also a little bit of funding in Title III right now.
The majority of this funding is used to monitor and provide technical assistance, but these funds are also used to support the Title III regional leads who provide more local technical assistance.
Title IV is not currently funded until we have a budget.
We won't know how much the state will receive or how much will be available after the funds are administered.
As you can see, this is a relatively small amount of funding.
We have yet to see how that will all shake out, but again, supporting LEAs to use those funds in the ways prescribed by law is probably would be the first priority, and there may be some left over for state-level activities.
And then, as I mentioned earlier, all California LEAs
who receive funds are required to develop and implement an LEA plan.
And within our state plan, we're required to describe how we will support the development, review, and approval of LEA plans.
So the submission of these new ESSA LEA plans represents an opportunity for the state to support LEAs to be reflective about their planning and align their local planning with state priorities.
So the next few slides provide the board with a few starting points for discussion around some ways we might leverage ESSA resources across programs to support state priorities.
One of those ideas that's come up is establishing the California Support Network.
California's county offices of education are uniquely positioned to provide supports tailored to meet local needs.
California could use Title I school improvement funds and Title III state-level activity funds to develop the California Support Network, a new network that would be designed to build county office capacity to support LEAs and schools.
Staff supported with these funds would work with the CDE, the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence, and other existing regional networks to provide integrated support to LEAs and schools based on local needs with a focus on state priorities.
Many stakeholders expressed the belief that school leadership is key to the success of the school community and were supportive of additional professional learning for principals and school leaders.
California could use the Title II Part A Optional 3% Set-Aside to establish the California Leadership Initiative, a statewide infrastructure that would build on the successes of the California School Leadership Academy.
with a renewed focus on equity, standards implementation, and instructional leadership.
The initiative could focus on leaders in schools identified for targeted and comprehensive supports first, and then expand to serve leaders statewide once established.
Are you seeing nothing?
All right, we're going to paper.
Sorry, audience.
Unless someone can come out quickly and
Thank you.
While she's getting ready, I should say that since we haven't done anything since 2002 on this, all of the applications for all of the titles that all of the local school districts are now holding are defunct.
So they will have to reapply.
And so leverage point for us, potentially, is what do we put in those applications?
Because they applied for NCLB, not for this.
So we also have a leverage point in the applications and the criteria we would use.
And as Barbara's slide showed,
The federal requirements are really pretty open, which we could add to or whatever.
So this will spring a whole lot of local activity.
And some of the, I think the local programs, I don't know what the impressions are around the board, have not changed a lot in a very long time.
and maybe don't reflect the Common Core, everything else we've been doing here.
So this is a chance for us to shake the tree in federal aid, which has been running somewhat on autopilot for quite a while.
Since we did not get a waiver,
We were running under NCLB.
Every item I can think of on federal aid here was put on consent, mostly.
And so this board has not dealt with the interstices of federal aid in the five years I've been on it.
So...
Anything that's been going on the same track for 14 years, which was an older track, NCLB, is probably not, whatever they were doing, is probably not fully what we would aspire to under the new law.
So that's just some thinking on the leverage that we have here.
in regard to this.
Board Member Williams.
While we're still waiting for that to come on, I just wanted to share for those of you who might not know, I thought it was very interesting the photo you had of President Johnson, given in particular that President Kirst worked in that administration, did you not, in the Department of Education?
Yeah, while we're setting this up, I should...
I should say, I'll tell my story.
That was 1965.
I was, and this is part of my vision for what we should do.
I was the second person hired in the Title I office in Washington.
And I was sent out to California to review Title I for the US Department of Education in 1965.
And I met the director of compensatory education, Wilson C. Riles, that some people may remember, and his very peppy young assistant named Marion Joseph.
And I was dazzled by what they were doing.
They had taken federal aid and just put a California vision on what they wanted and added dramatically to what the federal base was on applications.
And I thought, wow, this is really something.
So I flew back to Washington and said, you should see what they're doing out there with everything else we've seen in other states.
So anyway, that's a story on my first part with Title I and what California was doing.
And I would aspire now in some later years that we could approach some of that of what Riles did in that period.
So my takeaway from that story is we've been through so much together and most of it was your fault.
Yes.
We helped set up a system.
The second trip I had was to the Director of Negro Education in South Carolina, which was a very different experience than California.
I went from California to South Carolina.
And so there was a lot of distrust of the states at that time.
Segregated systems, for example, were still running.
And so
The federal administrators, including me, we set up Title I so that the Title I coordinators and the Title I leaders saw Washington as a reference point, not the states.
So we set up this silo, and that is something I think we're dealing with to this day in that regard.
So I'm even more compounding the felony.
But if you were there in 1965, you might have done what we did, too.
Now, it's probably just a twinkle in your eye in 1965.
So in my career as a student and as an educator, I've gone from being born in a state that put colored on my birth certificate to being Negro, to being black, to being African-American.
So even though I can't graduate out of that particular subgroup, things have changed considerably.
But again, still, most of it was your fault.
Yeah, I don't know if I can follow these stories.
So getting back to the presentation, many stakeholders indicated that they wanted more access to resources and additional professional learning opportunities for educators.
The state could choose to dedicate state-level activity funds towards the development and implementation of Collaboration in Common, an online tool that will support professional learning community practices and facilitate online sharing of resources.
We heard a strong message from stakeholders that they would like to see a broadening of curriculum under ESSA.
In keeping with this feedback and building upon the successes of the ELA-ELD framework rollouts, the state might also choose to invest state-level activity funds in similar professional learning opportunities for each of the updated frameworks.
The state could also use these funds to identify and disseminate high-quality resources and evidence-based practices across the curriculum via conferences, webpages, Collaboration in Common, and My Digital Chalkboard.
And similarly, many stakeholders would like to see California focus on the whole child a little bit more.
The state might use state-level activity funds to provide professional learning opportunities and identify and disseminate resources on the non-academic needs of students and families.
So these are just a few preliminary ideas just to give you a sense that we could use resources from across programs to support whatever it is you believe the state priorities should be.
So recall during the July meeting, the board suggested that the CDE consult with CCESA and the collaborative regarding opportunities in the ESSA.
We have arranged to meet with representatives from those organizations on September 19th, and have also expanded that meeting to include representatives from both the Commission on Teacher Credentialing and the California Subject Matter Project.
This group will use the starting points in Attachment 3 and your input today to develop a set of options for review by the CPAG, who is meeting on September 29th, and for inclusion in a draft as a state plan that we will bring to you for consideration in November.
So at this point, I'd be happy to address any questions you may have regarding the item and the plan development process, but I also have some questions for you posed by Chief Deputy Price earlier regarding what you would like to see in the plan.
What overall policy directions should drive ESSA planning?
What significant statewide programmatic opportunities and priorities should the ESSA plan drive?
As we think about how to leverage ESSA resources to support state priorities, are there particular priorities that you would like to see in the plan?
Are there particular program areas or plan requirements that you would like to know more about?
And finally, what specific input from the CPAG would be most helpful to you in November?
We are planning to bring them some options as described in Attachment 3 and further developed during the September 19th meeting, but would it be helpful for them to review and provide feedback on the entire draft plan?
So with that, thank you.
Okay, board members.
Pat.
Okay, so I do have some questions, particularly on, first, I'll thank you for this very comprehensive report and all the materials that you prepared and put in print for us.
I went through the outline you gave in attachment, I think it's attachment two, that is an outline
on each of the decision points that are required for both Title I and Title II and then all the successive titles that have to be addressed in the state's comprehensive plan.
So my question is, for the areas that have been shaded, identified as yellow as in process and the ones that are more orange as in not decided,
I want to make sure I understand what I just heard you say.
So on September 19th, there's going to be this joint meeting from a lot of state level agencies.
And is that where some of these decisions or some of these conversations about what's in this grid that's not yet decided or in process will be?
Or where will those decisions be made?
Where's that decision point at?
Right, thank you for that question.
So the meeting on September 19th is to look more specifically at use of funds, and there are a number of orange shaded boxes in here which are specifically like how are you planning to use your Title II and associated funds to support
educator excellence or whatever you're going to support.
So that meeting, it's the first of probably several meetings, is designed to have folks talk more about what are the possibilities, what are some other options the state could consider around using ESSA funds, ESSA resources to support state priorities.
And these are starting points.
The other pieces, there are a lot of orange pieces in here around
Performance management and LEA plans and other, you know, President Kirst talked about that.
We haven't really had that conversation, right?
So the September 19th meeting won't go into that so much as sort of trying to put some meat on the bones.
If we do want to do a California leadership initiative, what might that look like?
Who would be involved?
Who would we target and come forth with some proposals that we could then take to the CPAG and then back to you?
There wouldn't be everything orange or everything yellow.
The reason why I was asking in particular about the September 19th meeting and then afterwards, the September 29th meeting, I realized when I was giving my thanks to all the different stakeholder groups and the different types of stakeholder representatives who came to weigh in on the LCAP decision,
One group that I forgot to speak to was school boards.
I am quite certain that school boards as a stakeholder have a great concern about some of these decision points because some of this work on crafting that consolidated plan will impact
some of the work that they have to do in the timeline that they have to address it.
So probably while you're looking at those statewide policy groups and regulatory agencies that will be doing this work, you might want to look at some of those statewide stakeholder organizations that probably
should be at some point considered how to engage them in this conversation as well.
That is my suggestion, more because of the work that is going to be passed on to them at some point, but also the work that the CPAG will also be doing.
My other question was, as it relates to the work of the CPAG, the
The impression I had from some of my colleagues who were able to attend the study session in June, the joint study session with the board and the CPAG as the conversation began, is that people felt that that was a very successful opportunity.
So is there a plan to consider that and to have another one of those types of study sessions again?
Yes.
So just yesterday, as we were doing some briefings with the superintendent and CDE leadership around the content, you know, there's a lot in here.
And not even if we extend our submission by additional time, which is a possibility, depending on what ED does or how the board feels we should proceed, there's still a lot to cover.
And you all meet every two months.
So just yesterday I was talking with board staff about the possibility of perhaps joint study sessions with CPAG and or separate study sessions with the board.
Because there really is a lot and even if we have a longer period of time, there's still a lot.
And then my final question and this goes really more to a request really to President Kirst.
My frustration when I came on the board and we were doing on the consent agenda approval of these consolidated applications that really weren't keeping up with the work and the change in direction the state was taking in the same way that we are
using our flexibility concerning the LCAP to update the three-year template and to make sure that we're continually improving not just how we hold schools accountable but how we help schools do planning.
I'm hoping that we can look at a way to use a lot of the flexibility we have
under this new statute for how we monitor revise and continue to evaluate and update this plan also so that there's something built in so that we're holding ourselves accountable not for a plan we wrote 15 years ago but the ways that we monitor and continue to improve the implementation of that plan over time as well so I'm I'd like to see that as something a consideration that's baked in because I think there is some flexibility to consider that as well.
I'm glad to see that we're going to consider this and not submit until after March, only because I think that it merits a lot of conversations.
It took me three days to go over the 93 pages because I was trying to really be thoughtful and make sure that I understood everything that was going into this.
So in that process I did get the idea that some things have been decided mainly because it said decided in some of these categories.
And I personally almost choked on my cookie when I was reading this when I read the part on about ELs.
So attachment to page 7 of 30 that states former ELs included an EL subgroup for four years after re-designation in academic indicator.
That is something that is currently in the draft regs that reclassified students can be included up to four years.
I think this merits a really big discussion.
This is the first time that I see this and I would never support it because for me under Title III in order, we should monitor, absolutely let's monitor there and see if after four years they still have access to the core curriculum and they're performing at a
you know, a level apart with their colleagues.
But to include it for accountability purposes, that could really mask the performance of current ELs.
And so we have a work group right now that's getting together for the composite.
They should be helping inform this, as well as the reclassification, which is something that was also noted as decided.
ESSA calls for a standard reclassification criteria.
and the one we cited is the same criteria that we currently have, which is the same criteria that everyone pretty much agrees gives you a fragmented reclassification process across the state.
So how can that be our criteria that standardizes the practice of reclassification?
Then if we take component four of the criteria, also per ESSA,
we're left with assessment or proficiency rates of the assessment, which will eventually be LPAC, teacher evaluation, and parent opinion.
We don't have an LPAC assessment.
How do we know what proficiency would look like?
Again, I think that some of these decisions that have been decided, I'm not sure
who decided and, you know, I think we have a great opportunity right now to really rethink what is a solid reclassification process.
And citing the same criteria that has created so many different systems of reclassification across the state is probably not the best starting point.
maybe eliminating one of those will be.
I don't know.
I think that we should ask.
And then the last one is they asked about assessment in a language other than English.
We do have the Spanish assessment.
We don't know if it's going to be used for accountability purposes.
We have to wait for the assessment regulations.
But we are, we do have something.
So why not note it in this, in this section.
piece about the language assessment other than English.
I think we're not really sure how we're going to go, just as you just said, until we have the final assessment regulations.
So it's one of those things where we think we know where we're going to go, but we're not entirely sure until we have the final regs.
Getting back to the academic indicator that you pointed out on page seven, we actually had a conversation about this last week with Director Aguila from English Learner Support and Jenny and I sat down and we tried to figure out where are we with this because someone said, what is this?
And we thought about reposting the entire item to rephrase it and then thought, oh, that would be bad to have 91 pages times two.
So if we move for purposes of the academic indicator,
to the front of that phrase?
For purposes of the academic indicator, former ELs included in the EL subgroup for four years after redesignation.
Does that then make feel more decided to you?
Because it felt decided to, no?
It wasn't about the English learner.
indicator, it's about the academic indicator.
Right, but you're saying that we would include somebody, a student who reclassified, four years later will still be included in the EL subgroup for ELA and math.
It's still the same problem, we still are masking what do the current ELs, where are they performing in terms of math and EL?
No, for Title III, there's no accountability.
Title III is reporting, now it's in Title I. And so that is, you know, a huge conversation that needs to take place.
Monitoring, yes, for Title III, for the purposes of monitoring these students one year after reclassification, two, three, four, we do want to know that.
We want to see where did these students go?
Did we reclassify them prematurely?
Were they ready to access the core curriculum?
But for accountability purposes, I think that it would completely mask the performance of current ELs if we're also including reclassified students in that subgroup.
All right.
Well, thank you for that input.
And I will continue the conversation both between board meetings and at the next board meeting.
On the CPAG, I have a request for the local people who are in local school districts.
that you ask them to come prepared, what are they now spending their money on in Title I, and how effective do they think it is?
I need to get a better handle on what is out there."
Get them to look inwardly and say, what are we doing here in our own district and how effective is it?
Ask them if anybody has firsthand information of that by local districts.
I would appreciate just, you know, I need to get more information on what is before I get to what ought.
You know, I have imagined what is, but I can't, I don't have any real data.
Board member Holliday.
I was trying to stay at the 30,000 foot level as you asked us to do.
I wanted to just indicate that, as President Kerr said earlier, there is a tremendous need for capacity building in order to address this achievement gap that is so stubborn.
And I think we're hearing from a lot of people the same question.
What works?
Can I do?
I'm ready to do it.
I got money now to do it.
What's going to work?
So if there were a way that each of these titles, and I know it's impossible to do all of them, but if we could somehow think about how each one of these title monies could build upon each other in that same capacity building goal, I think we might get a lot better idea how effective this money
When you look at tossing, say, 4 million or 5 million, billion, sorry, at one issue, capacity building, right?
You might actually move the rock a little ways as opposed to a little here and a little here and a little.
So that would just be sort of my 30,000 foot look at it.
Actually, we are actually in alignment on our conversation is that so much of categorical is siloed.
So when you're managing it, you're like, okay, I got money for this program.
I have nutrition over here.
I have tech.
So what we're trying to do is make a coherent system.
And what member holiday was saying, I just want to build on which is we're trying to improve capacity and practice to improve outcomes for kids.
And so we got, we have LCFF money and there's obviously districts are identifying, they're identifying gaps and they're focusing on what to do.
We put additional $1,400 in educator one time to improve practice for PD.
Title II I know was my favorite use of money when I had a local budget because I had opportunities to improve practice.
But I think at some point along the way we need to look holistically
how are we improving practice and how do different pieces, obviously, Migrant Ed needs a target, different, there are different titles that have particular focus, but when you think about the core teacher in the classroom who now has first core instruction for Yale students, for special needs students, for diverse learners, it's changed from siloed where you just sent kids out to get treatment and you in the core just did,
We're asking that every one of our frameworks to support English learners with extra strategies and helping build capacity.
But teachers take time to learn some of this and leaders as well.
So I would like in the process and one of our board updates and in some of our working groups,
to take a holistic look at improving capacity of districts, of leaders, and of classroom teachers, and how all the pieces.
I mean, I think I loved your graphic, which supports what Member Bersman's saying about the small percentage is federal money and how much we are
targeting and our state responsibility.
So I just think as we talk about professional practice, which is how you improve outcome, I think we ought to look at the whole picture.
So I think that's just an ongoing project as we take a look at the funds and our goals.
Thank you.
Other board member comments.
Board member Ortiz-Lacon mentioned the reports on Title III.
So we've been getting these, just using that as an example.
So the local districts file these, so there's the application process, that's a leverage point, then they file these reports on these various titles and they're going somewhere in CDE, I'm not quite sure where, but we, and under NCLB it wasn't, you know, any particular need to
do much about them.
But seems to me we could also think about reviewing the various reports that there come in.
So some listing at some point of not just of what what's on the what kind of reports do they make on this and just let's say a title three report looks really bad.
We could say we don't accept this.
We want you to you know we want to talk about this or we want you to see
think about reprogramming your funds or something of that sort.
So that the reporting is not just a passive compliance document.
It can be used as, are they on track in that regard?
So that's another thing I think to think about is what are they required to do?
The big issue that is somewhat stumping me, a big issue, is how does all this relate to the LCAP?
We want to have a unified federal state local system.
Now, we have to approve these Title I applications as a state board.
We're the state education agency.
We want to make it congruent with the LCAP.
the statute, and I don't think the board or the department, want to get into approving all the local LCAPs.
So how do you have an integrated system where, you know, the responsibility is somewhat bifurcated?
I'm sure we can work it out.
And then if we try and tack the federal aid stuff
On to the LCAP, it's going to get starting to get real large again.
And, you know, we'll approach, you know, even higher numbers of hundreds of pages.
And so that is a problem.
I mean, you can overburden the LCAP.
The LCAP is not categorical funds in its thinking.
This is categorical funds.
These are categorical funds.
So I'm a bit muddled on this and I think it's a real dicey question.
Now, the local plans that we've been talking about, the local education plans, those are required through federal, those are required, those are complying with federal aid, right?
So, okay, you got a local education plan for categorical money, which is an application process,
And then you want it to be integrated with the LCAP.
So this is something for the board to figure out.
I'm not smart enough to figure it out.
So somebody has to think this through.
But I'm a little, I'm just laying out some of the bigger issues that we have thought about.
The local education plans are just on the federal funding.
So I'm back to.
He's shaking his head yes for the audience.
Yeah.
Glenn is saying yes.
Chief Deputy is saying yes.
I'm sort of back on this notion of this is an awful lot of work for a little tiny bit of money for an LEA.
I mean, if you break down, it's 10% statewide, you break it down at the district level, I would be going, I don't want the money.
It's not worth the headache, honestly.
What was really helpful about showing the 1965 activity, at that time it was big money and it was the only money that supported the kind of equity considerations that we have been working on now for several years.
I appreciate the conundrum, President Kirst, but I think we have to think about it again in the context of how much LEAs are really getting out of it and how much we want to demand of them or how much time our staff should be spending, our collective staff, on sort of chasing their tail a little bit here.
Right.
That's one to consider.
On the other hand, you have an objective of, well, this needs to be rethought at the local level because they were operating under an entirely different system.
So if you don't have some
state policy, it'll probably just go on the way it's been going on.
I interviewed a local administrator in two large systems and asked him about federal aid, and he said, well, we just sort of put that aside, you know, it's sort of running on autopilot.
But there may be one way in, and I think this is what Glenn is trying to keep reinforcing for us.
I'm sure I'm trying to get it through my head.
In this transition plan, we told the Feds we are going to use the LCAP as the LEA plan because that is what we believe in and what we think is the most important.
I would suggest we want to continue that so there is no duplication.
Whatever the locals have to submit to us, there is a box that says I certify that this is aligned with my LCAP or this is my LCAP.
and it represents all the funding that I'm getting through LCFF and whatever you have to do for federal money.
It's not a dual process that we're approving some federal plan.
Anyway, that's just a thought.
I think Glenn and Barbara could probably shed some light on this as the process goes forward, but I am quite certain there are some elements that are common in the template for our LCAP that are also common
in what would be required or asked of the locals to submit for their consolidated application.
And so that maybe, and I hear what Board Member Burr is saying, is that in asking the LEAs to do this work, we're not asking them to do something else, something more, or something different.
if there's a way to create a style guide or a template that populates the consolidated application template from what's developed in the LCAP since we've already said in our state transition plan that our LCAP is going to be our guiding document, if there's a way for us to craft the consolidated application template so it's populated
from what is written into the LCAP.
Maybe that can simplify some portions of this process.
And if there's some work that the state can also do for common planning requirements or common requests that all the LEAs have to submit in the consolidated application, are there things that the state can populate into that application or that template?
If we can think about building that out and designing it in that way, that might satisfy or at least resolve the complication of the something more, something else, something different.
I would definitely say there are some key strategic questions that are going to need to come to the board, but they're not insurmountable and we're going to need to think really creatively.
Number one, just recognize and remember that the board is already approving the LEA plans that are coming in.
and it's coming periodically and you approve them on your agenda.
We could look at a situation where we devolve or push out that approval responsibility to the counties together with the LCAPs.
Could be one pathway for the board to think about.
We'd have to talk to the Department of Education about that and gain their approval, but that could be a way to go.
You know, while the funds in Barbara's chart is really instructive, you know, look small.
They also are, for a lot of people, very significant in that these are resources that can be used very strategically for specific purposes, and I think it's also important to remember that
They're targeted at the same population that's a priority for the state and unduplicated pupils in terms of our low-income children in the state of California.
So we have two plans that are directed at a similar population.
It would really behoove us to be able to integrate and align the work that's going on so that we're getting and leveraging as much as possible of those resources.
So I agree with you, President Curtis.
It's going to require some real creative thinking, and it's going to require us putting some real sharp pencils to paper or bytes to keyboards.
But I think we can do it using the same creativity that we've been using to solve these problems as we've been going along.
Ortiz, I'll come.
Yeah, I think I just wanted to make the same point that even though in terms of the money that California has invested, this might look like budget dust, I believe is what board member Burr calls it.
One, it has the spirit of civil rights for these students.
Before LCFF, this was the money that helped some of the students that it was meant to.
You know, LCFF has been in place for not that many years.
This has been in place since the 60s.
So it's a reminder that this is an obligation to help these students.
Now if it was to, and I do think that we need to streamline it, but if it ended up in the LCAP template then we really need to make sure that that we show how the money is being used to improve and increase outcomes.
There has to be a very clear, this is the money,
This is the subgroups.
These are the outcomes.
Because even under LCFF that has been a consistent complaint that we're not clearly showing how the money is truly benefiting the students that generate it.
So I can't imagine trying to scale that to federal funds and not be accountable or have a direct way of showing how the money is being used.
Which is, as you all know, precisely one of the challenges that we're confronting with the LCAP template as well.
So we can confront this together, and it's a wonderful opportunity to be having it at the same time, because it will allow LEAs to leverage all these resources together.
In the SAS accounting codes, maybe Member Burr or the department knows this, are the federal funds separate, what do you call them, separate resources, separate codes?
This goes back to your point, Feliza, that they are coded in the accounting.
So you have more
Transparency on them because they're separate codes in the SAS code So, you know, okay.
I just want to check that in my thinking.
Yeah Because we got rid a lot of the categorical codes with LCFF But of course we did not and should not get rid of the federal codes.
Yeah Other any other board comments on this do we have public testimony on this item?
If the following people would please come to the podium.
We don't have numbers for this one, I don't think, right?
Hannah Midnick, Matthew Diaz, Shelly Spiegel-Coleman, Patty Scripter, Lee Angela Reed, Mary Stiers, Doug McCray, and one name I can't read, PTA, everybody come forward, Brad Strong, Eric Premack.
Please line up everyone who signed up.
You have one minute of time.
Hannah Melnick from the Learning Policy Institute.
Good afternoon.
We'd like to thank the board for your commitment to a multiple measure system and share three comments.
First, we'd like to recommend that California take advantage of the optional Title II set aside to support school leadership.
California has had no statewide infrastructure to support principal training since 2003.
Research shows that strong school leaders are critical for retaining teachers.
This investment could help California reduce its teacher shortage.
Second, we fully support the board and CDE's position that ESSA does not and should not require states to issue a single summative score to each school.
Our letter and comments to the U.S.
Department of Ed explain why.
Third, we explain  we agree that the final regulation should ensure that non-academic indicators are meaningful in the components of the accountability system.
Research from CORE shows that the proposed regulations would result in these measures being weighted close to zero.
Stakeholders have made it clear that these measures, such as suspension rates, surveys, and the CCI, should count.
Thank you.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, representing California Association for Bilingual Education.
I have three comments.
The first one is with regards to Title III, Part A, page 25, the third block where it says California will seek legislation to amend Criterion 4.
the status that that's been decided.
I would like for you all to consider revisiting that.
I don't recall the State Board of Education approving legislation to amend Criterion 4 and I would like to know what that looks like and so I think that needs to be revisited.
The other action is with regards to the
English learners statewide uniform procedures for former ELs, page 7 of attachment 2.
Again, we don't believe that combining the two cohorts, ELs and RFEPs,
into one for academic indicators is a good idea.
It will mask the actual performance of English learners that are not our FEPs.
And my last comment is in regards to the assessment in languages other than English.
Page five, we would like for you to please consider including the California Spanish assessment in the accountability system.
We believe that the intent of ESSA allows for native language assessments.
They currently in the proposed reg state that ELs who are not proficient in English can be exempted from the English only assessment for up to five years and they can use a native language assessment.
So we would like your consideration for inclusion of CSA in the accountability system.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Shelly Spiegel Coleman, Californians Together.
Just in terms of this previous conversation that you have, I think we need to make it clear that for Title III, written into Title III of ESSA is supplement, not supplant.
I know there are regs out for the whole issue of supplement for supplant, but for Title III, it's written into the language.
And so including them in the LCAP would be a good idea, but districts would have to actually write to the four
the four purposes of Title III in their LCAPs and then show that these funds are supplementing what the districts are already doing in those four areas.
And so in the redesign of the LCAP, we really think that needs to be taken into consideration.
The other thing is the state's doing some wonderful things for English learners that we think need to be in this plan.
When we talked about opportunities, Glenn, that one is our superintendent talked about the EL roadmap.
And I think that roadmap has a definite place in the ESSA plan.
The other thing is using Title III funds, which really means it should be in the plan, is the new video series on integrated versus designated ELD and the updated document on research-based promising practices for English learners, a new publication the department is doing.
All of that should be in the title, should be in the ESSA plan.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon.
I'm Mary Stiers, the Director of School Support for the Stanislaus County Office of Education.
My role is to support our 25 districts state and federal program directors.
I myself was a state and federal program director.
I also periodically meet with my county colleagues who also support state and federal program directors.
A couple of things that we have some questions on and some concerns about is the optional 3% for direct student services that is optional for the state to reserve.
I'm not sure districts are very widely informed as to the meaning of this and that it is for direct student support services that the
state board would need to determine providers.
And I'm fearful that we are going to go down the path of supplemental educational services providers, which we know was not effective.
So I would request that that money not be reserved off the top and that we honor our local control with our districts making those decisions.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Doug McRae, a retired test specialist from Monterey.
Given the current developmental state for metrics needed for assessment and accountability portions of ESSA, it would seem wise to lobby for delay in implementation of the plan until the 18-19 school year with status information based on spring 18 data and change on spring 19.
To rush implementation before necessary assessment and accountability metrics are ready for prime time is not a wise choice.
With the increasing speculation that ESSA regulations will be pushed over to the new administration, with the usual six-month delay to fill chairs at ED in Washington, D.C., and then for the new staff to find the bathrooms, a delay to the 18-19 school years, the first implementation year of ESSA,
is more than possible.
Finally, I'd note the same kinds of delays took place for NCLB back in implementation.
It's not for about three years after the legislation.
Thank you.
Patty Scripter, California State PTA.
I just want to take this opportunity during the ESSA update to thank you again for your letter to the
Federal Department of Education clearly stating that California is going to continue on the path to a multiple measure system.
That's something we've supported from the very beginning.
Accountability based on multiple measures more clearly reflects what's happening in our schools and your letter and vote today recognizes that a single rating system can mask strengths, areas of need, and gaps in opportunity and achievement.
Once a school's degree of success is reduced to a single number or descriptor, that becomes the label and identity of the school.
within the education community and the public.
I think back to the student council presentation at a previous meeting where the student rep on accountability implored the SBE not to do a ranking system because it was very negative to student culture and school climate.
So we really want to thank you for continuing on the path of what's right for California students.
President Kirsch, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board, Brad Strong with Children Now.
At the start of the presentation, I was nice to see President Obama's statement about the purpose of ESSA.
And it really comes down to, it's about the educational rights and inequities and ensuring that those are monitored and addressed and that those
Those inequities, regardless of whether it's academic, discipline, those inequities are identified and addressed.
On behalf of 26 organizations, we submitted a letter related to the educator equity plan.
So in 2015, the state had adopted an educator equity plan.
The No Child Left Behind only dealt with highly qualified teachers, different definition, no longer a requirement.
every student succeeds, changes the definition.
And so what this letter is really asking, it's really about ensuring that there is some local monitoring approach, not just addressing the entire pipeline, but really driving into equitable plan for quality educators.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter School Center.
While I can't hang with Grandpa Kirsten Channel all the way back to 64, because you would measure my age in months back then, not years, I can remember back to 2002 when Richard Whitmore and Ray Belisle were furiously trying to put the state plan together back then.
And we tried to get them, work with them on the charter fit into it.
We weren't able to do it because they were just overwhelmed with the whole process.
I'm kind of feeling like
We may be putting a needle back into that groove, hoping that we can avoid some of the conflicts that have been with us now for 14 years that have been very messy, offer any assistance we can provide in terms of smoothing that out.
I think about 99.9% of my clients would say we would rather have off-the-top money go to us rather than to the usual suspects, some of who are helpful, some of whom are not, and rather have a few thousand bucks here than somebody else deciding for me somewhere else.
Thank you.
Good afternoon President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members.
LeAngela Reed on behalf of the California Association for the Gifted.
We're very excited about about some parts of ESSA in that they actually it actually recognizes gifted students for the first time in kind of the
in the federal law, certainly it wasn't in NCLB.
So we think it's an opportunity.
In Title I, there's some opportunities for reporting disaggregated data for students, including gifted students.
In Title II, there's some requirements relative to teachers.
We think it will help us to expand our informal identification and we look forward to working with Barb and the CDE staff on moving forward and trying to provide a resource so we can make sure all students are getting the services they need.
Thanks.
Good afternoon, Marta Alvarez on behalf of ACCSA, the Association of California School Administrators.
We really appreciate the staff's comprehensive overview of the decision-making points for the State Board regarding the ESSA State Plan, 96 pages that we will be continuing to review over the next several weeks.
But I think that will be an opportunity for our members to really be able to provide feedback to you about the decision points regarding the funding that set aside the California we're putting aside for different programs.
We have a history at AXA providing professional opportunities for our administrators.
And so we want to be part of that conversation and thinking about how to utilize that money and how to leverage it at the local level.
We will be having a webinar with our members on October 18th.
So to the extent that you have questions you want us to ask the administrators, let us know.
We have more than 120 so far registered to be part of that conversation.
I really want to thank you and want to be part of the conversation moving forward.
Thanks.
Okay, I think that concludes the public testimony, and so we're on to SBE priorities.
So let's have the rundown there.
I have the list.
First we have to approve the minutes, right?
Yes, okay.
So do I have a motion to approve the minutes?
I move adoption of the minutes.
Second?
All right, any public comment on our minutes?
Okay, if not, everybody ready?
If it approves, raise your hand.
Okay, they are approved.
Okay, so updates here.
Mathematics, Rucker Strauss.
mathematics.
So I think the best way if it's okay I'll start is that I'm to to share what's going on collaboratively between the Department of Education, the State Board, and SESSA and coordinated by Rafa Mercado and Brett Mallicott and our team in
And I'm just coordinating all the work around standards implementation and continuing the works.
I think that really shares the broad look at we have a lot more work to do.
So if it's okay I'll be the one that kind of shares that and you can add.
There's been collaborative groups going working together.
The math collaboration committees met I believe four times and so science.
They've set goals to build communities of practice.
And we've had history meet and now ELA, ELD.
And so there's a coordinated effort to bring and to roll out capacity building in the counties and in teams so that we can continue the work.
And in addition, there's a structure of a standard steering committee that meets about every other month.
that is trying to coordinate all the pieces in the state level.
So just to assure people that we realize that we have lots more work to do in implementing once we write the framework and adopt it and adopt materials, that's just the beginning.
And so with coordination, there's a grant, 1.6 million, I think, from Bechtel.
Did I get that right?
For science and math and they're looking for funding for the other areas to continue to build the communities of practice.
I think it's really exciting.
And in those meetings, it's just so stimulating and exciting thinking about what people are doing out in districts and in counties.
So that's sort of a general overview of what's happening with the standards implementation, math, science, history, and now ELA, ELD.
Let me add to that.
From the beginning, there was some work that was undertaken by Stanford University in a collaborative effort with the California Teachers Association and some assistance now that has come from the Department of Education staff.
to create an instructional leadership core and the idea behind this was to identify a collection of expert teachers to provide professional development support directly at the LEA level both in English language arts and mathematics.
That program has grown in scope and aspect to at this point there is some work being done now with the collaborative
to look at ways to create professional development opportunities using this instructional leadership core, particularly in math and English language arts and science, to provide additional types of professional development collaboration with work that's being done by the collaborative.
The program is being funded by a grant that's being overseen by the Kress Center at Stanford and collaboratively with work that has been done with the association.
The department staff has worked very closely with the association and Stanford, both for professional development to develop the craft for these folks as trainers, but also with the summer institutes.
And the goal has been to create multiple professional learning opportunities
for implementing the Common Core and using the curriculum in appropriate ways and grow the expertise of classroom teachers over time.
So that work has continued and they're looking for ways now to expand that work going forward.
One other thing is that Common Core stakeholders meet several times a year, which is a group of instructional leaders and advocates looking at the best practices.
So the WestEd research, some of the best practices of districts and counties to help inform.
And there's another meeting coming up the first week of October that'll be here.
I think it's at CTA as well.
And so that's a way to help inform our continued rollout.
So I hadn't shared that as well.
And finally, IQC does have a meeting coming up the 22nd and 23rd of this month and in November on the 17th and 18th, I think that's the date.
Okay, IQC, ELA, ELD, Strauss.
Okay, you covered that.
Okay, IQC History, Social Science, Sandoval.
All right, well, the application process for review panelists to participate in the 2017 History of Social Science Adoption of Instructional Materials is open until Wednesday, October 19th.
And the responsibilities of the panelists include evaluating instructional materials for use in kindergarten through grade eight that are aligned with the standards for History of Social Science content.
in our public schools.
And each panel will consist of multiple instructional materials reviewers, and according to the regulations, the majority must be teachers, and at least one shall have experience instructing English learners, and at least one shall have experience instructing students with disabilities.
Other reviewers may be administrators, parents, local school board members, and members of the public.
At least one content review expert will serve on the panel and is required to hold a Ph.D.
in history or related discipline.
Stay tuned for more developments there.
Okay.
We're having a meeting a little bit later in September, September 20th, where the IQC will be finishing going over the comments from the last second and final public review of the NGSS curriculum framework.
And I will be on a phone call to hear that.
I'm not quite sure how they're going to assign the rest of the liaisons on that.
But that will be the end then of NGSS related to standards curriculum framework and it but the work on the NGSS assessment of course is a different division and Pulling it into the accountability system won't will is years off a couple years off And so it'll shift over to a different set of players at that point Computer science Williams
Okay, first of all, I want to say that I'm really happy that I had no travel in August for the State Board.
Absolutely none.
So I worked on a lot of personal projects, started a genealogy chart, you know, just said, okay, I'm going to focus on the pool and my own personal projects.
That said, I spent a lot of time in e-mails and phone calls and texts and things like that, including on computer science.
I know we haven't taken computer science up as a full board yet.
Believe me, I know that.
I ask at every meeting.
But as you can tell, the accountability stuff, which is a bigger issue and a more important issue and much more complex, has rightfully taken up our time.
I'm hoping we'll be able to do that in early 2017, have a presentation board discussion.
In the meantime, I have had President Kirst's authorization to help support any LEAs that would like to know more about computer science education and
and to start taking it up.
I think I mentioned to you last time that we had a presentation before the EdTech Committee of the IQC in May, and they were really excited about it.
I work primarily, although I work with state leaders on this, I work behind the scenes primarily with Code.org, who actually launched this campaign three years ago, and they are a nonprofit organization.
And I, in October, on October 10th at the CDE STEM Symposium, October 10th, mark your calendars, 3 to 4.15, I organized a presentation with Alice Steinglass, the Vice President of Code.org, who will give a presentation on how the importance of computer science in K-12 and why that momentum is growing, and there will be three
computer science education leads, one from San Francisco Unified, one from Los Altos Elementary, and one from Granada Hills Public Charter School talking about how they are now bringing it into their schools.
There will be also information at that meeting about
for districts or LEAs that want to apply to partner with Code.org this fall, to apply this fall for free professional development and curriculum for the summer of 2017.
In addition, I have reached out to the California School Boards Association to see if they would like to have any speakers on computer science at their December meeting, but I thought of that too late.
and they already had everything booked up.
However, I reached out also to AXA to see if they might be interested.
There's Alicia sitting at the back of the room.
I was connected to her by Julie White to see if they might be interested at their superintendent's symposium.
So she has forwarded that information, the possibilities.
The actual CEO and founder of Code.org, Hadi Partovi, has offered to come out and be a plenary speaker for them.
and also to bring others if, depending on their own level of interest, bring others to talk about the new national K-12 CS framework that's going to be released in October and the brand new computer science principles AP course that has been piloted the past two years and now has an AP exam approved by the college board.
They'll be getting a lot of PR on both of those things this fall.
So, I'm waiting to hear from Alicia on whether or not their committee is interested in having Hathi and having more information.
So, Advisory Council on Special Ed.
The advisory commission on special education met on August 10th and 11th and this group always has a really full schedule and one of the highlights was on August 11th and Michelle center, the director of assessment development and administration division offered an assessment update focusing on the conceptual design for the California alternate assessment for science.
And the members who were in attendance really expressed a deep appreciation for the work that's happening there.
And it's, I think, a way to better serve students with disabilities through purposeful collaboration between state board and department staff throughout the various divisions.
So I think there was a consensus, just that there's a lot of excitement and good energy around the alternate assessment for science.
And then we also had a representative from San Francisco State University who talked about the vision for implementation of the FAIR Act, specifically as it relates to curriculum that's inclusive of students with disabilities.
So that was a good discussion.
And then a representative from the Commission on the Teacher Credentialing addressed their implementation of the task force recommendations.
and also talked about their use of the disability equity rubric that was part of the work of the Advisory Commission on Special Education as a frame for redesigning the credential structure and preparation requirements in different areas.
So it's nice to see the task force continuing to be used in significant ways.
And then,
Another highlight was the honoring of Camino Nuevo Charter Academy and the Cane Sea Art Campus in L.A.'
's MacArthur Park neighborhood of L.A.
Educators at this school are the recipients of this year's Goal Award, and this celebrates innovation and exemplary practices.
And this school implements a dynamic blended inclusion model, and this ensures that each adult on campus is responsible for the education of every child.
So, co-teaching happens at this site, and continuous job-embedded learning supports teachers.
And the school supports students pre-K through 16.
95% of students qualify for free or reduced lunch, and 76% of students have been designated at one time as an English language learner.
So, they have a lot to shout about and it was very inspiring to hear from representatives of how that's serving our students.
And then lastly, the Advisory Commission on Special Education's annual report for the 15-16 year is now out, will be in your boxes any moment.
And again, this is a very active commission with members who really take their responsibilities seriously, and I'm grateful for the work they do to inform us through this time of rapid change in our education system.
That brings us to CTC.
Maybe you could mention what CTC has been doing about special education teachers.
So actually, CTC is meeting today and tomorrow.
So normally, it's the opposite month from us, but it just got scheduled on the same day.
There's lots happening here in Sacramento.
So actually, on their agenda today, they are revisiting special education and program induction standards.
That's on the agenda today.
They are also talking about subject matter programs for elementary authorization and administrative standard service updates.
So there's a lot of talk in CTC about updating standards to be with our current expectations but unfortunately I'm not in the conversation today since I'm here.
But they are doing actually an exciting it's another in October in San Diego I think it's on check on the 19th but
They're doing the, all the deans of the departments of education for all the schools.
And Tom Tarlix and I were on the panel last year.
It was really fun.
But it's the first time I think in 20 years that all the deans of the colleges of education in California were in the same room.
It was public and private.
And so actually we've been invited to be on a panel to talk about the relevance and quality of teacher preparation programs, retention issues,
how we're going to deal with the demands of the teaching force and so we'll have a report I think for the November meeting but it's a really exciting opportunity and it's CTC plays an important role in coordinating that meeting that's coming up.
Okay, California Collaborative on Educational Excellence, Board Member Burr.
Well, I'll start by saying I'm sure that Dr. Carl Cohn and his staff breathed a huge sigh of relief with our vote this morning because they were waiting for the evaluation rubrics to be adopted in order to start their training.
So just by way of background, I think I shared before, but the budget this year provided $24 million to the collaborative
of which up to $20 million is available for statewide professional development on the evaluation rubrics and the revised LCAP template, and up to $4 million for pilot projects for the CCEE to do a trial run on what kinds of services they're going to be providing to LEAs.
So if you look on the CCE website, which I would encourage you all to do, they now have information about nine workshops, I think Nancy mentioned this briefly in her presentation, that will run between November 2nd and November 18th.
Online registration will be available by tomorrow.
And they're all throughout the state, and that's the first sort of broad brush conversation about what the rubrics look like and what the LCAP template will look like.
These are mostly county people that are in this first round or not?
It's y'all come.
Everybody come.
Anybody who wants to learn about it is in this first round.
There's also a parallel process going on for what's called an early adopter network, and these are intended to be professional learning communities.
that will be more enduring.
Some are already underway, and so this is a way to give them some additional funding.
The contract with those early adopter networks will be finalized by September 19, and all of those will come to our next CCEE board meeting, October 6.
We also discussed the draft of the professional development plan at our August meeting.
That draft will be posted with revisions by September 16th on the CCEE website, along with the survey seeking feedback.
So people who are interested in providing additional input into what the next phase of professional development looks like, I'd encourage you to take a look at that.
And then again, the final version of the professional development plan will be brought to the collaborative board on October 6th, so stay tuned.
The CCE is very much geared up right now.
I just want to mention that I think I said at our last meeting, Sandy Thorstenson, who was our chair and was the superintendent of Whittier High School District, retired.
The governor has appointed Matt Navo.
Many of you know Matt.
He's a superintendent in Sanger.
to replace Sandy, so Matt will be joining us in October.
But that means that Matt has to resign from the CPAG, from the California Practitioners Advisory Group, which takes me to my next just reminder that we are now recruiting, President Kirsten mentioned this briefly at the beginning of the meeting, for three advisory committees
The California Practitioner Advisory Group, we need one member who has to be a superintendent or an other administrator.
We're recruiting for two members for the Nutrition Advisory Committee.
We need teachers and or curriculum coordinators for those slots.
We're recruiting for one slot on the Advisory Commission for Charter Schools.
That's the county superintendent slot.
And for each of those three advisory committees, the deadline is October 6th for applications.
All the information is on our website, on the state board website.
and although we welcomed Olivia today we are already recruiting for her replacement.
As you all know the student board member term is short.
It's only one year so we've initiated that recruitment as well.
There's information about for students to submit applications and those applications are due in October 10th and then we will be making recommendations to you all in November for appointments to the advisory committees.
Okay, so that's all I had from that.
Go ahead.
I just want to thank Superintendent Torlakson because he will be visiting Long Beach Unified in a couple of weeks and in particular he's going to visit my husband's school in downtown Long Beach.
So thank you very much.
I think it's such an honor for that school community to welcome you to so you could see some of the good things that happen in Long Beach.
Unfortunately you can't attend my kid's school, visit their school but I'm also happy to report that I now have two official kids in the school district
TK in first grade, yes, because she was in preschool.
Now she's in TK.
And I always bring that to mind because I want to make sure that people know I talk the talk, but I walk the walk.
And I know that every decision I make will have an impact on my own kids' education.
And so even though they think I just fly and go to meetings, they have no idea what I do, I always tell them, I'm doing it for you.
And that's exactly what I do here.
Thanks.
All right, so we're adjourned for the day and we got through faster than we ever thought.